48 hours of non-fiction books
saturday through monday morning on book
tv
the works of german philosopher
friedrich nietzsche in the last century
are often quoted today in political and
public policy discussions
recently we interviewed philosophy
professor stanley rosen of boston
university who's written a book about
nietzsche entitled the mask of
enlightenment nietzsche zarathustra the
interview is about 50 minutes after the
interview we'll look at a philosophy
book group in maryland as they discuss
friedrich nietzsche
dr stanley rosen of boston university is
in boston and we are in washington and
we're going to have another one of those
informal conversations we had a number
of months ago when we talked to dr rosen
about plato this time and i'm not even
going to try to pronounce it tell me who
are we talking about so we can get the
correct pronunciation from you friedrich
nietzsche
who was he
nietzsche was
one of the most extraordinary thinkers
and writers of the second half of the
19th century born in germany
in 1844
uh
he uh
had a relatively brief productive
lifetime he
went mad when he was approximately 45
years old
and uh died in 1900
so we could call him a a extraordinary
influential
thinker and one of the truly great prose
writers of german certainly in the 19th
century that would be my first reply to
your question
and how much have you thought and
written about him in your life
well actually i first started reading
nietzsche when i was an adolescent
uh and in fact
in my day that would be more than 50
years ago
nietzsche was not studied uh
really in philosophy departments
and was regarded as a kind of a
mad poet rather than a serious thinker
uh that's uh interesting because i kept
reading nietzsche for the next 50 years
and finally
uh his influence caught up uh with me
here in the united states and he's now
one of the most widely read most
influential
thinkers of our time and books pour from
the presses on nietzsche uh really quite
unusual so he's had a tremendous impact
uh in the
second half of the 20th century in the
united states
why do you think
well for several reasons first of all
he's a is a man of extraordinarily
powerful uh rhetoric
uh some people would find the pros in
zarathustra
uh a bit too
flowery and passionate it's written in
the style of luther's translation of the
bible
but
his other works are extraordinarily
beautiful and really extraordinarily
articulate that's the first reason his
great his great prowess as a writer
secondly however nietzsche
states in the most powerful way
a criticism
of the modern epoch in a particular late
modernity and still more precisely the
the
latter end of the enlightenment he stays
with the greatest power
uh a criticism of that uh epoch which uh
has now become rather fashionable
uh there's a big fight going on and that
has been going on almost since the
beginning of the enlightenment
as to whether it was ultimately good or
bad and it would be going too far to say
that for nietzsche it's all bad but
nietzsche takes the the
view that what looks to others like
progress scientific progress
technological progress materialism
egalitarianism the spread of democracy
even the advent of
national socialist i don't mean by that
the nazis of course socialist parties
many people regard that as great
progress nietzsche saw it
as great decadence
and this uh quarrel
within the uh the heart of the
enlightenment is one that has been
articulated in the most powerful way by
nietzsche
so if i could add brian one last point
that occurs to me
nietzsche is a
prophet of revolution
and uh
to define exactly the content of the
revolution that he advocates is not so
easy but one thing that is clear
is that nietzsche is
preaching a destruction of traditional
values in particular the values of the
christian tradition
and secondly but
with considerable importance the values
of the greek philosophers
nietzsche
preaches creativity originality
uniqueness self-overcoming
and these have all become extremely
popular uh
notions in the 20th century think of all
the liberation movements in our time i
mean
the black liberation women's liberation
gay liberation
all the uh
revolutions by young people
which you and i will still remember from
if i'm not giving you too many years
from the vietnam times
people who wanted to break loose from
society break loose from tradition
reject christianity reject
the sterility of the middle class and of
the bourgeois society all turned to
nietzsche for
solace and for inspiration whether he
would whether he intended to give
inspiration to these diverse groups
that's another question but those are
some of the main reasons why nietzsche
is so popular today the impetus for
asking you to join us again is a
richard hall c-span richards hall
produced
event at biblio's bookstore near
uh baltimore at timonium where the
philosophy book club meets once a month
and at the end of our discussion we'll
show that discussion among everyday
citizens talking about philosophy
let me ask you just a general question
what what is the value
to people who are adults
sitting around talking about philosophy
well now that's a rather difficult
question to answer in a simple way i
would say for some people there's no
value at all
but
those would have to be extremely uh
thoughtless people who are
we're going to exclude them from this
discussion the group
that i saw i looked at the parts of the
tape
obviously consisted of very bright
concerned people who were interested in
understanding
uh themselves and therefore in
understanding the structure of the
historical period that produced them
and in particular they were clearly
intrigued by the extraordinary
uh power and i should say uh ambiguity
of nietzsche's writings so in other
words an intellectual treat a sheer
pleasure
and an an essential
element in the process
that characterizes us as a species and
that is that we want to try to figure
out what it means to be a human being
and how to live one's life whether that
be the life of a
carpenter or an electrician or a
physicist or a philosopher is really
irrelevant ultimately man i think if i
may say so is the philosophical animal
and so uh in considering philosophy we
are simply exercising our common
humanity
for those who missed our earlier
discussion on plato would you mind going
over the details on that dr stanley
rosen uh give us a little background
how long have you mentioned earlier
about 50 years of teaching
well it's 50 years of studying
philosophy yeah i uh uh i i'm a graduate
of the uh the old hutchins college of
the university of chicago
and i went on from there to uh take my
doctorate
with the committee on social thought
very well known
interdisciplinary program that has had
many famous people in its faculty
and then i studied in
greece for a year
my wife was an archaeologist at that
time
then came to penn state university uh
where i spent 38 years with a lot of
time uh you know taken up by traveling
or studying in various places in europe
in the united states then i retired in
93 and took a chair at boston university
where i now am i'm the borden
parker-bound professor
of philosophy and a university professor
at boston university how often can we
find you in the classroom
[Laughter]
i i teach a full load uh john silber
who as you know is still the chancellor
of bu wisely i think insists that the
senior people teach
that's honored uh you know they're one
or two exceptions of
famous poets or novelists but the
academic people teach a full program
which is uh two courses
and one is a graduate seminar that meets
for three hours a week the other is an
undergraduate course as it happens i'm
teaching nietzsche zarathustra this
semester they're largely honors students
about 15 or 20 and that takes three
hours a week
so it's five six hours of teaching plus
all the time i spend uh with my graduate
students reading their dissertations
preparing for classes and so on what do
you notice about the undergrad students
when they come into the classroom at
what point do they
start to understand this stuff
uh
again that depends on the kind of
student
i i if you're if we're talking about the
large 150 persons classroom in fact i've
had as many as 350 in the classroom
there the the problem is extremely
serious because there are so many people
that it's hard to focus their attention
they come from very diverse backgrounds
for most of these kids philosophy is an
a three-hour
requirement in humanities
many of them not at all interested and
they have to be made interested and the
only way to do that
is by translating the material into
ordinary language
which uh goes directly to the roots of
their daily lives
uh
how deeply those roots uh uh go will
depend upon how how well they respond
so that's one group of students and i've
had some luck with with these people uh
in particular i found uh teaching a
novel like dostoevsky's the brothers
karamazov
which is is in a way closely connected
with some of the themes although it
takes different positions closely
connected with some of the themes in
zarathustra
the real joy however is in teaching the
kind of course that i'm giving right now
to what is essentially a group of honors
students say 20 honor students who are
there because they want to be there they
in effect begged me to put them it was
admission by instructor only
and this is wonderful because they're
bright highly intelligent imaginative
eager to learn they want to be there
and if i may say so this might sound
peculiar to our audience they don't know
anything that means that they're not
their brains are not obstructed by
professionalism as sometimes happens
with
senior students or graduate students
they don't already know everything they
don't already have a rich culture they
don't already have a familiarity with
the 10 or 15 different interpretations
of nietzsche and so we can get right
down to business and and excite them you
know in a way like in a platonic
dialogue in which uh socrates is talking
to young young boys who are who are
highly intelligent and simply they're at
that age in which they want to know what
it is to be a human being what is life
all about that that kind of thing so
that that's a very exciting but that's
quite a different experience from the uh
teaching of you know large introductory
classes
you keep mentioning zarathustra and i
have here uh
modern library series thus spoke
zarathustra fill in a couple blanks for
me and i i admit to not having paid a
great deal of attention but
the movie came out 2001 odyssey years
ago
and and i i think i remember the theme
song being thus spoke zarathustra that
was a by richard strauss wasn't it yeah
had nothing much to do with nietzsche i
mean it was uh
i did see the movie many years ago
but strauss wrote a piece which was
clearly inspired he was inspired by by
zarathustra
uh i wouldn't be able to give you a
commentary on the piece out of the text
however but what i guess my question was
what who is there
that's a different matter
how does this all fit right right
zarathustra the figure is uh
historically a persian who is reputed to
have been the
father
of uh
moral moral uh moral philosophy we could
put it that way philosophy had been
formal
he was the the father of morality
according to that tradition and
nietzsche
chooses him
as a prophet
of a new morality which nietzsche
personally is in the process of
developing you see so zarathustra is
symbolic of the beginning and the end of
the long tradition
of the
middle east and western europe the long
tradition of morality which nietzsche is
now going to transcend
one of nietzsche's most famous and i
think best books which he wrote as a an
attempt to explain zarathustra which
people found difficult to understand is
called beyond good and evil
now the phrase means not that nietzsche
is an immoralist but that he is an
amoralist
with respect to the tradition that is to
say beyond good and evil lies a superior
version of goodness and evil
so zarathustra is a kind of symbolic
figure for a shift that is coming
zerathuster is a prophet a prophet of a
new morality and the morality of course
is the one that that nietzsche
articulates uh sometimes uh
mysteriously but sometimes with great
power in zarathustra
go back to nietzsche as a person uh
again what year was he born 1844
and
you remember his exact age when he died
he died in 1900 but he had been mad for
a good 10 years before that where
where was he kept for those 11 years
that he was or 10 years well most of the
time he was kept at home by his sister
who took care of him i can't tell you
exactly where he must have died in a
hospital i saw happen to see his death
head in uh
in stockholm it's very impressive but i
i honestly don't remember
you know where he died but that was the
the his life was quite tragic
uh he was he suffered uh really from his
mid-20s early 20s from terrible vision
serious migraine headaches nausea and
yet he produced you know 30 or 35
volumes of really gorgeous pros very
deep pros
always ill
and uh at
the age of 45 he went mad in italy
and uh his sister uh
got a hold of him and took him home and
took care of him for the remaining 10
years of his life was he married no no
no
his relationship with women uh is uh not
clearly known i mean
the assumption is that he was entirely
chased never had any relations with
women he seemed clearly to be in love
with a with a woman named lou salome who
also wrote a book about him uh a woman
of some interest in her own right but
they had intense it was a kind of
platonic love affair as far as we know
they had intense philosophical
discussions uh otherwise nietzsche lived
a life of almost total solitude i mean
he spent his life moving from one
furnished room to another
uh changing the
location in accord with his very bad
health you know always looking for a
place where he could breathe more easily
and
be free of his nausea it was a lonely
lonely existence but uh one which was
spiritually as rich as
as that of anyone i know in this uh in
the last 200 years well if he wrote 35
items of material how much of that do we
know sold back then
benicia uh
didn't sell much at first but he soon
became rather popular and
especially after the you know when he
was
the 10 years or so when he was already
mad
people from all over europe were
beginning to intelligent and uh highly
artistic people were beginning to
discover nietzsche his influence grew
steadily throughout the first half of
the 20th century and people like d.h
lawrence the english novelist g b shaw
man and superman you know that play
uh
strindberg
thomas mann the german novelist who
moved to the states
really the list of people influenced by
nietzsche is endless even sigmund freud
who denied
incidentally he denied having studied
nature clearly was influenced by
nietzsche and borrowed a number of
notions from him so one could say that
nietzsche's influence
exploded all over all over western
europe certainly russia
and uh north and south south america
you know if you get on amazon.com
and and put in the name stanley rosen
yeah uh you come up with
oh i don't know at least 23 different
items
some of them are written by an imposter
who's a specialist in chinese studies in
other words there's another stanley
rosen
but but the point i wanted to make
though is it did you've written a lot
and i've got i've got one of your books
here the mask of enlightenment yes
which is about nietzsche's uh
zarathustra correct when did you write
this
uh the book is a consequence
of uh lectures graduate seminars that i
have been giving on on nietzsche on and
off for oh i don't know 20 years but i
actually sat down and put the manuscript
together in 1993.
is it available still people want to buy
it oh yes yes yes it's
it's published by cambridge university
press and uh is easily available yeah if
you know let's say uh 150 years from now
people are looking around and they say
oh there's uh the stanley rosen the
philosopher
is there a rosen philosophy
uh no
not in not in the in the sense that i
suspect you mean it i am not one who has
built up a a system
uh
which purports to give the principles of
all things
and uh nor am i in a happy position of
being able to clear up all the the
mysteries of human life uh my philosophy
if you want to call it that is uh
really inspired most by uh the platonic
socrates
uh i'm a a man who like many others has
devoted his life to examining
fundamental questions
fundamental principles and trying to
understand how these fundamental
principles have been spelled out in the
history of philosophy and the shape that
they've taken in our own time and what
they you know every age has crises we
have our crises and i've tried to take
some
tried to find my bearings and to help my
students to find their bearings with
respect to these these philosophical
crises so in short
many of my books not all but many of my
books are about somebody else i've
written books about plato or hegel or
nietzsche i've written books about
heidegger and so on
and
that's not because i'm a pure
philologist or scholar but because i
believe that uh
philosophy must be studied
in the context of its development from
the beginning because uh it's not like
science
in which only the latest results count
you know in the what happened previously
has been transcended
since i don't believe that there are any
final answers to the deepest human
questions uh i think it would be really
quite foolish to uh reject the thoughts
of the wisest members of our race
so uh that's the rough story of uh where
i stand on philosophy i don't know if
this works or not but if uh
nietzsche were here today
based on what you know yeah and this
sounds may sound like i'm reaching but
what would he think of the discussion in
this country ongoing
at least
the history of this network 21 years on
abortion
god
i mean how would it fit into his
morality
i honestly you know can't give you a
direct answer to that question it
doesn't it doesn't come up
in so many words we would have to uh
reconstitute a position for uh for
nietzsche and i would say there that
for nietzsche the issue of abortion is
not as it is for most of us today or at
least that's the the way in which the
the issue is argued today is as you put
it a moral question in other words is a
fetus a living being at what age at what
stage of the fetus the development of
the fetus
does the soul
religious religious people talk uh
manifest itself you see what i mean it's
a moral question for nietzsche it would
be a political question
that is to say
nietzsche would ask
if we are going to pro something like
this if we were going to produce
a race of what he calls in zarathustra
superman
funny express in fact the standard
translator walter kaufman calls it over
man because he doesn't want people to
get mixed up with the comic strip
character you know clark kent
however uh it to try to answer your
question
by some kind of indirect
construction
if our goal is to produce a superior
race then abortion in principle is not
to be rejected by nietzsche for example
let me give you a a an example from
plato
in plato's republic
reproduction is very carefully
restricted by class in other words the
most intelligent superior people must
breed only among themselves suppose a
member of the most intelligent or
highest class of philosopher kings as
they're called guardians
suppose one of them breeds with somebody
from
the lower classes the workers
that child will be exposed on birth and
or aborted if if
it's discovered before it's born the
reason for that is that for for plato
and the republic in order to have a
superior city you must have a superior
ruling class and plato knew or thought
he knew from
the process of breeding dogs and
breeding animals that people could be
bred in the same way and that you had to
have uh
the children of superior parents
as
members of the highest class now that's
plato but i mentioned it because it it
really casts a bit of light on on the
answer to what nietzsche would have said
i mean nietzsche i don't think would
have had any uh interest in aborting
children for the convenience of the
mother
i mean again this issue is played out
you know in terms of the united states
which would not be uh applicable to uh
understanding nietzsche's own position
but we can summarize this this line of
thought as follows
uh whether children are allowed infants
are allowed to live or die
is a political decision and that in turn
is made on the basis of the intrinsic
splendor of the
culture and values
of the civilization that we're building
and you might say well isn't the uh uh
is some people would say isn't abortion
itself
a defect of our civilization and
nietzsche would say no in my opinion you
know if you ask someone else you might
get a different answer but i think
nietzsche would say no you would say you
that's sentimentality that comes
ultimately from christianity now there
are many people who are not christians
who are opposed to abortion nietzsche
would have called that secularized
christianity in other words the
christian morality transformed into a
morality for non-believers but people
who have still been influenced by
christianity he would have said the same
thing about socialism for example as a
kind of secularized christianity
so is that helpful at all and
yeah what would he have said uh if he
were here at the table this morning what
would he say about the fact that this
is um one of the largest church-going
countries in the world
or the highest percentage of people in
the world that go to church
uh and also that what would he say about
our democracy
nietzsche
what uh you know karl marx's famous
phrase religion is the opiate of the
masses
well for nietzsche look i can ask you in
this way nietzsche wished to destroy
christianity and replace it with another
religion a religion of the superior
human the superior human being in other
words nietzsche's teaching is a very
radical uh
extremely rhetorical version of what's
been going on in modern western europe
for the last 300 years
i mean
it's a kind of
carrying out of descartes the french
philosopher in mathematicians
in his discourse on method that
science
and with it the correct philosophy will
enable human beings to become as masters
and possessors of nature that was back
in the 17th century now obviously
if we become masters and possessors of
nature that means that we throw out the
previous master and possess her that's
god so i mean there's an intrinsic
atheistic element uh in modernity and in
particular in the modern philosophical
tradition that's not to say that all
modern people are atheists but that has
to be recognized nietzsche is another
one as was marx of those people who
wishes to
allow for
a superior the development of a superior
human being
and in order to do that he sees that we
have to destroy the culture that has
produced the previous human beings so
that's that's uh uh that's uh
uh one part of my reply to you now what
does religion have to do with this well
the previous religion let's just call it
christianity must be destroyed because
the values of christianity have been a
major ingredient if not the major
ingredient in the preparation of corrupt
people i mean now let's put some flesh
on those bones so that your audience can
know exactly what nietzsche didn't like
he did not like weakness he did not like
pacifism he did not like egalitarianism
he did not like jesus turning the other
cheek he did not like jesus appealing to
the poor the crippled the lame the blind
and the halt he saw christianity
if i may put it colloquially as a
religion for losers
he wanted to uh inculcate a spirit of
warrior-like creativity of people who
would not be bound by sentimentality for
the average person or for the uh the
inferior person or for the disadvantaged
as we call them today
uh for the tunisia this would have all
been sentimentality so he would he would
not at all been impressed by the fact
that we're all going to church
the second point you asked about was
democracy
now this is interesting brian because
nietzsche today is extraordinarily
popular
uh not not simply among right-wing
thinkers but among left-wing thinkers as
well i i mentioned earlier in this
discussion that there are our our
century of the 20th century has been one
of any number of liberation groups
uh it's also been a century of
the spread of uh democracy
uh it's been a century
of uh the spread of ideas of
egalitarianism fairness and so on i mean
these are terms that intellectuals in in
london or belgrade as we now see with
excitement on the on the television or
new york all use with equal frequency
nisha was
really opposed to that
i mean nietzsche was what i would call a
revolutionary of the right
he is confused
by i think many well-meaning
people from the left
because he's confused as a spokesman for
for their views because he talks a great
deal about uniqueness and creativity
uh and individuality and so on but what
he meant by that was that the superman
would have to create a new civilization
such that
the non-creative people namely the great
majority
would benefit simply by participating in
others by exemplifying the values of
nietzsche's morality
which would replace christ morality i
mean
from a christian standpoint
christians are uh
obedient to the teaching of christ
nietzsche wishes to replace the teaching
of christ by his own teaching one of the
books that he wrote was called the
antichrist
the last work he wrote ekko homo you
know it's a biblical expression
behold the man
nietzsche quite seriously uh saw himself
as a great historical rival to christ
that was his ambition
to replace
everything having to do with
christianity and democracy unfortunately
for uh
our own uh taste from nietzsche's
standpoint democracy was uh was inferior
it was a kind of version of the
sentimentality that once he's
exemplified in christianity so those are
my answers they're not very pleasant i'm
afraid to to contemporary taste but
those are the answers now may i add that
if you have five other people on your
program
uh you might get five different answers
i don't think it's that they would be
right i mean i think that nietzsche was
not a liberal he was not a revolutionary
in the in the left sense of the term he
was a a man who believed in rank
ordering as he often said my key concept
is rank ordering he was a man who
believed in the nobility nobility of the
spirit he despised the rabble the people
the crowd as he called them variously he
wished them no harm
on the contrary he wished to raise them
up but the only way in which they could
be raised up is by being trained
properly if i could put it that way i'm
speaking for nietzsche not myself the
only way in which the people could be
raised up is by giving by being given a
proper education i mean this is not a
notion that is foreign to us today but
the content of the education that they
would be given would be quite different
from the one that uh obtains in modern
uh 20th century european democracies so
in short anti-religious in the
traditional sense and by no means in no
sense of the term a democrat
as that word is used in contemporary
political discussion
professor stanley rosen who teaches at
boston university is in boston talking
with us about friedrich nietzsche
depending on how you want to pronounce
it and he'll be with us for about
another 25 minutes or so and we're
leading up to
watching the philosophy book group that
meets monthly at the bible's bookstore
in timonium which is up near baltimore
about 40 45 miles from where we are here
in washington um
i want to ask you
why should we care what this man thinks
and and who has made him
someone that you read and think about
his extraordinary influence
and when i say that i don't mean that
the influence necessarily worked out as
he had intended it
but
nietzsche states
in the most
effective way that i'm familiar with
the following view
traditional philosophy traditional
morality
is all a lie
life is in fact
chaos
that is to say intrinsically it's chaos
whatever order exists in the world has
been produced by human beings
orders
live are born live mature grow old and
die just like individual people
when an order a political order or a
social order or a set of values
a society
historical epoch all of these terms
amount to much the same thing when such
a a structure begins to get old and to
deteriorate then it leads to what
nietzsche calls decadence i mean decay
and if the decadence is allowed to
proceed
untreated
you could make a medical analogy here in
other words if you have a tumor and you
don't treat it then it's going to spread
throughout the body politic and it's
going to deteriorate the standards and
the
values of the
civilization and this will be a long
drawn-out process in which people will
become more and more decadent and more
and more
uh mediocre
consequently what we have to do
that is to say what a man like nietzsche
has to do is to destroy that destroy
that civilization and he states very
radically
uh the need to destroy tradition and
that is a very appealing i mean the 20th
century is a century still of
revolutions
and he also uh speaks very very
clearly
about
the inadequacy of moral moral teachings
which restrain us
and people who don't wish to be
restrained by moral teachings who don't
wish to be as they would put it slaves
of a supernatural being uh find
something extremely appealing in
nietzsche
uh nietzsche was influential in bad ways
very bad ways for example he influenced
not intentionally but the nazis were
influenced by nietzsche i mean there are
horrifying passages in zarathustra uh
one passage about the blonde beast who
will come down from the north you know
into the the plains of the mediterranean
and destroy the mongrel races that are
living there i mean that's uh you know
hitler uh and his propagandist made use
of passages of that sort because
nietzsche as part of nietzsche's uh
teaching about uh
uh the superman there was a kind of
biological uh
superman the notion of a biological
superman of a being of enormous strength
and health
nietzsche himself was quite sick as i
mentioned earlier and
people have speculated you know that he
had a kind of
almost desperate romantic uh
interest and enthusiasm for health
because of his own miserable physical
existence however that may be
uh nietzsche had uh uh influences
which uh depending upon your own
political standpoint were either good or
terrible but they were enormous
and uh
one has to understand i think you know
the conditions of one's own time and one
can only understand that by studying the
great masters people like nietzsche who
prepared the time in which we live
uh is that a helpful answer to your
question but could you do this and this
may be a little bit uh
harder
who in this country today that we know
or maybe a better profile of the person
would be walking around with
thus spoke zarathustra in their pocket
as kind of their bible
can you define the kind of person the
kind of thinker today
well
again i have to begin by emphasizing
that
nietzsche
is sufficiently difficult to understand
and sufficiently ambiguous that he's
inspired people of widely disparate
views
so you could find using this terminology
of the left and the right
not in any polemical way but simply uh
because i think everyone's familiar with
it
uh you will find people on the right
who are very impressed with nietzsche's
critique
of christianity
as a kind of religion of as i put it
earlier losers
a religion which uh weakens the
distinction between the noble and the
base
which
turns our attention from the high to the
low let me jump in to ask when you say
the right wing but would would
right-wing
born-again christians feel that way no i
doubt that they'd ever heard of
nietzsche but i mean uh would they agree
with his discussion well let me let me
give you a specific example
perhaps one of the two or three most
famous philosophers of the 20th century
a man named martin heidegger
dead for some years a german philosopher
who wrote a great deal on nietzsche
and who shared nietzsche's
distaste
for modernity
and for many if not all of the same
reasons
uh
i don't think that you would find jerry
falwell
appealing to nature because nietzsche
was an antichrist
but those people who saw themselves
as freed or wishing to be freed from the
traditional forms of
judeo-christianity or for that matter
islam
those those who in particular saw
themselves as wishing to be freed from
christianity
would find nietzsche extremely appealing
now who are the people who wish to be
freed from christianity just to follow
out the single thought well they can be
on the left or the right right i mean
there are right-wing atheists and
they're left-wing atheists left-wing
atheists i mean by that again nothing
abusive but people who uh believe that
man makes his own values and we must
respect each individual person
and we must be fair and just to everyone
and there is no single point of view
that is truly right religion and even
many philosophies are therefore quite
dogmatic
and
that leads to a notion of a kind of an
egalitarian democracy
now these people could find themselves
uh
using nietzsche
to justify some or all of their views
sometimes they would be right sometimes
they would be wrong nietzsche was
anti-christian but he was not he was not
a democrat
so
one has to reply to you rather
cautiously you could find admirers of
nietzsche in almost every sector of the
intellectual world and that's why the
cumulative effect of nietzsche's uh
writing has been so powerful go back to
uh when he lived uh did he have uh
parents alive when he was doing all this
his father died at a relatively early
age uh his mother lasted longer
and uh
he however
once he passed you know he was a
university professor in his early 20s
and
then just went off on his own he knew he
had he had a mission he had to write
these books
and uh he had he wanted complete
independence he had a very small pension
and uh i think his mother sent him some
money he was extremely poor you know by
any
normal standard but he had just enough
to live on and he preferred to live
alone
he didn't live with his family where did
he well first of all where was he born
he was born in germany uh a village
called
a little village i think that's the name
uh and uh he went to uh
he went to school in uh he went to what
we would call a a classical uh uh
gymnasium that's to say what we would
call a high school something like that
then he got a job teaching in
switzerland in basel he was a professor
there
but uh for various reasons one of which
was his health he gave that up at quite
an early age and took his small pension
and whatever money he got from his
family
and proceeded to spend the next uh 20
years writing these thousands thousands
of pages in one small furnished room
after another many of them in mountain
areas in switzerland and he ended up for
example in northern italy he went mad in
torino
which still has a sign on the house that
he lived in you know in the final days
of his sanity and and how did i think
i've
read either in your book or somewhere
that syphilis was the cause of his
insanity that's uh if i'm not mistaken
uh that's the the the consensus view of
the medical people uh he was himself
uh a a medical order leader in the war
of franco-prussian war you know he
served as a medical orderly and
apparently he got infected while
treating somebody
medicine obviously was not as
advanced as it is today he apparently
got infected uh uh
from someone who had syphilis
and uh got it and the result was paresis
now no one knows this no one knows for
for absolute certainty that nietzsche
did not contract syphilis you know
directly but that's that's the story
that uh that i think is currently uh uh
accepted now what was his relationship
with ricard wagner the uh yes yes at a
rather early age he attracted wagner's
attention and they became rather good
friends wagner was a very tyrannical man
rather nasty bit of goods if i may say
so anti-semite and uh
lots of lots of faults quite an
egomaniac but he liked nature because he
saw nietzsche's genius and nietzsche
revered wagner in the early stages of
their friendship he revered wagner and
thought of him as a
an artist of universal competence
who would be able to produce works of
art that would contribute to you know
the elevation of the spiritual
development of european men at a certain
point however when wagner became
extremely sentimental and celebrating uh
christian elements in his operas
nietzsche became disgusted with him and
broke with him
and he wrote a book called the the fall
of wagner and uh
wagner became extremely irritated with
them and their their relations were
ruptured
but nietzsche apparently retained a
lifelong
respect for the influence that wagner
had had on him and he also liked
wagner's wife very much cosima
it's interesting that a man who lived
this life of complete isolation
uh he had one or two male friends but
the two people who made i would say the
greatest impression on him as human
beings
uh were uh lou salome and cosima wagner
who are both women rickard wagner to be
sure but only for a short period of time
you know today if you uh were to analyze
the success of a lot of people in our
society you would always go back and
find the great mentioners
whether it's politics or philosophy or
professors or entertainers i mean
somebody somewhere mentions people and
that's how the whole thing begins
if you went back in his life when would
you find people starting to mention
friedrich nietzsche
was he discussed in the papers was he
discussed by others publicly
when did he come
into the public being where people all
started to say this is somebody you got
to read yes i would say that began uh
in the period straight oddly and sadly
enough
uh after his uh
during his madness and after his death
in other words 1899
thereabouts nietzsche began to become an
international figure who did it
well
uh
some of the people whom i mentioned
earlier strindberg and
shaw uh
great variety of uh uh writers and
artists uh
who's doing it now well now yeah now
nietzsche is the hottest item in in
publishing uh
one of my publishers uh editors told me
once that you we could publish a book
called nietzsche's laundry list and it
would still sell five thousand copies
why
well uh
it would be difficult for me to to
answer that without repeating uh many of
the things i said before yeah but i mean
is there is there uh are professors in
schools like yourself saying you got
oh yes no how to study this yes yes i
mean nietzsche is extraordinarily
popular
i think perhaps the best answer i can
give you is this
it was the influence of martin heidegger
whom i mentioned previously
uh that really led to the explosion in
our generation it was heidegger
published his major work on nietzsche in
1960
and uh heidegger was a man of world
influence
and he influenced in particular a school
of french thinkers
who are variously known as
post-modernists or deconstructionists
people like jacques derrida and michel
foucault to mention the most familiar
names and these people were very much
influenced by heidegger and through
heidegger uh by nietzsche and they
spread the picture of a revolutionary
what i was calling earlier i hope not in
in any way in any confrontational manner
i was calling a left-wing nietzsche and
this became extremely popular in the
united states uh i can also indicate it
to you in the following way
in in the in the american academic
philosophical community
for let us say 50 or 70 years
philosophy
was dominated by people with a strong
interest in science mathematics
people who uh regarded themselves as
analytical thinkers rather than
synthetic thinkers with broad visions of
human life
now
uh to be quite candid about it except
for the professionals themselves the
students are not interested in this sort
of thing
and many people who uh who are who are
not professional philosophers but who
are academicians are looking for
something richer than the you know no
matter how wonderful it might be in
itself the analysis precise analysis of
concepts structure of mathematical
arguments and so forth that doesn't give
you a lot to live on
and nietzsche gave us
an extraordinary portrait of human
existence i mean we've managed to cover
you know only the most exciting and
notorious aspects of the teaching of
zarathustra but in nietzsche's 30
volumes you will find discussions of
world literature
of the greeks endless discussions of
greek greek civilization greek archaic
civilization you will find elaborate not
always philologically accurate but
nevertheless elaborate criticisms of
german philosophy of the 18th and 19th
centuries
uh
all of this uh this this extraordinarily
gorgeous prose this very provocative
writing
these wonderful observations on
standalone and on uh
china and on
political events and on human psychology
and i'll end that with this with this
point nietzsche was a master
psychologist
and this is among other things in age of
psychology you know the age of anxiety
the age of freud and jung and so on
and nietzsche there too is one of the
great great psychologists he when he
discovered dostoyevsky incidentally he
said that dostoevsky was was uh
the other great psychologist i mean if
you think of novels like the brothers
karamazov and the the idiots and so on
nietzsche liked that very much this
extremely fine-grained
exaggerated obsession
with the subtleties of the human psyche
uh nietzsche is just marvelous on that i
mean he really gives wonderful portraits
of human types and this is mother's milk
to 20th century intellectuals stanley
rosen of all your books that you've uh
written over the years which ones sold
the best
uh
well actually
the one that's selling the best by far
is a book that i edited for uh
the book of the month club and random
house did the
uh trade edition it's a it's called uh
the examined life
and i won't try to describe it in any
detail but of my own uh monographs or
philosophical works i believe it's
correct to say that a work called
nihilism
has done the best that was published
many years ago by yale press and is now
out again uh uh released reprinted by
saint augustine press i i would guess uh
the nihilism book how many of your books
are still in print uh all of them
so you can buy everything that you've
written everything i've written
that's unusual
well i've been very fortunate
i have
a contract with the st augustine press
which commits them to bringing into
print
everything of mine that has gone out of
print so they've reprinted uh four or
five titles of mine you know which after
20 years went out of print who is uh who
are they who's the saint augustine press
uh that's an outfit uh located in the
notre dame in south in the south bend
indiana
and uh
they publish uh
they reprint scholarly philosophical
religious books which have gone out of
print but which you know still command a
certain audience and uh they do a bit of
uh original publications i think they
intend to expand that side of the thing
but they brought a wide range of
philosophical works uh back into print
and plan to keep them there it's now not
so difficult i gather i can't explain
all the technicalities but apparently
new techniques of producing books enable
publishers to keep them in print longer
than was the case previously
so yes uh i have been very lucky uh
they're all in print
our uh book tv producer richard hall is
responsible for putting this all
together and in a few moments we're
going to see
a discussion by a group called the
philosophy book group meeting at
bibalo's bookstore in timonium maryland
they meet every month it's just north of
uh baltimore and they met on august the
28th for seven that was actually seven
days after the 100th anniversary of
nietzsche's death nietzsche's death
you've seen this tape professor i saw
about 15 minutes of it yes uh what's
your sense uh i didn't count the number
of people there but probably what 20
people in the room at least it was a
larger crowd i thought than the one we
did then the one that was discussing the
republic i had the impression it was a
bigger room and a larger crowd
uh
maybe 15 people yeah that sounds right
and what did you think when you watched
the 15 minutes of it well i was
fascinated as always
i i would say this
these people got exactly right how
dangerous nietzsche is
those of your audience who will stay
with the show you know and watch the uh
the discussion will see that come out
quite clearly these people these the
people understood clearly that that uh
that nietzsche is a dangerous man
why is he dangerous well because he's
teaching us to destroy tradition to
create new values that's always
dangerous he's uh he's not a democrat i
think they saw that very clearly for the
most part uh for all the in other words
the reasons that i gave before they
perceived those where they went wrong
to the extent that they did go wrong
is that there was a tendency on the part
of some of the members of the club
to interpret nietzsche to be saying that
every individual must create
his or her own values you see that would
be too democratic an interpretation of
nietzsche it would also from his
standpoint and frankly from mine lead to
complete chaos nietzsche was not
teaching that every individual person
created his or her own values what he
was teaching is that the great person
the superman
create a new set of values which will be
disseminated down by teaching and other
modes of influence into the multitude
and thereby raise them up i don't think
they quite got that right a third point
that interested me was that
they seemed to feel or at least a vocal
segment of the group seemed to feel that
nature is very cynical
now that's not the right word i hope i
i'm not misperceiving them i think
that's what they said nietzsche is
ironical and he has a wonderfully uh
complicated sense of humor
and he doesn't share many illusions of
the average person but he's not cynical
a cynical person i take to be someone at
least in the current usage of the term a
cynical person is someone
who really doesn't believe in anything
and wants to cast doubt on everything
and as a kind of a destroyer rather than
a creator you see from nietzsche's
standpoint cynicism is dissatisfaction
of a powerless sort you know we just
make fun of things what nietzsche does
is to make fun of things in order to
destroy them so that the ground can be
cleared for him to create something new
so i think these people perceive
something in other words they notice
that nietzsche is an ironic and and in
many ways an entertaining writer but
he's not cynical they took his violent
denunciations of democracy his
invocation to war his statements that
blood will flow in the streets that the
blonde beast will come down and so on
they took that as a kind of cynicism if
i understood them correctly towards uh
humanity in general and that's not quite
the way i would describe it cynicism is
not quite the right word from what you
know of him if he had to live in this
time
and had to do the circuit the television
shows and all that stuff in the lecture
series what would what would people
think of him before he became mad
well he was
a great gentleman i mean he's
interesting contrast you know this man
who uh
who advocates violence and and and right
wrote one book uh true many people think
he was mad when he wrote it
ekko homo behold the man one one chapter
is called i am dynamite and section is
called why i write such wonderful books
i mean he was really obsessed with
himself he knew his own greatness you
know i mean there was no
i wouldn't call it well there was no no
false modesty in nietzsche on the other
hand as a person from all the accounts
that we have and you know many people
have left their reminiscences of
encounters with nietzsche he was a
gentleman he was extremely gentle which
is
a separate term not just a gentleman in
the the sense of having polished manners
but he was a gentle person i mean i
don't think he could have heard a fly he
was very considerate of other people and
uh
very quiet and uh
i think quite engaging it could be good
fun you know at parties was a very witty
person i think people would like him
provided that the uh that the
interviewer did not go on to ask for
further details of teachers
philosophical uh positions because once
those came out in our time
if they came out if in other words if my
interpretation of nature is correct
nietzsche's statements would be regarded
with horror by uh most intellectuals and
uh uh thinking people
in the uh
present uh social and political
circumstances so he was a he was one of
these
prophets of violence who was himself an
extremely quiet man that was apparently
not true of karl marx i mean i'm not a
big expert on marx's life but
i do uh know that he was a rather
disagreeable and uh nasty fellow no one
could have said that about nietzsche
nietzsche was extremely nice by the way
a bit in case people have just joined us
uh stanley rosen who teaches at boston
university uh has written this book
that's in print called the mask of
enlightenment nietzsche's zarathustra
did zarathustra live
i don't think anyone knows
i mean it's just one of those legendary
figures
so just
when did nietzsche did he make up the
is it no no no i mean it's a traditional
figure from
ancient persian mythology the ostensible
inventor of morality
he might have there might have been a
man who did this i i wouldn't know when
you're teaching nietzsche yeah
what
what do you find the reaction of your
students to be to him after they've had
a a lot of him
some of them are repelled by him for
reasons that will be clear to anyone
who's been listening to this interview
but on the whole i find that the
students are excited by nietzsche
and you know the reasons are various but
nietzsche is just an extremely exciting
guy for example i found uh to my great
interest years ago i used to try to
teach kierkegaard
whom many people sort of link sometimes
for good reason sometimes for bad
reasons
uh with nature he lived somewhat earlier
than nature kierkegaard was a very
exciting writer he was a brilliant
epigrammatist
and a critic of uh the establishment he
was a religious writer the students
don't go for him they don't they don't
they don't like him nietzsche appeals
nietzsche is interesting
there is something about the uh
something about nature that excites
students and it certainly is his
invocation to uh
go to the heart of things
not to be
bound by tradition
to understand or to try to understand
what it means to be a human being and
the various emphases upon creativity and
self-overcoming a lot of students like
it but some a significant minority are
repelled and frightened by it dr
rosen i'm sorry we're out of time and
right uh we really appreciate you
spending time with us and
telling us all about this and uh
thank you and good luck up there at
boston university and we hope to talk to
you again soon thanks brian so much for
inviting me enjoyed it
next we go to timonium maryland for a
discussion of friedrich nietzsche's thus
spoken zarathustra the book was written
in four parts by the german philosopher
between 1883 and 1885. first published
as a whole book in 1892 the work is a
set of parables about a prophet who
proclaims the death of god the
discussions about two hours
philosophy book discussion
i don't know if any of you know it but
last saturday was the 100th anniversary
of nietzsche's death
at uh i think you'd be
puzzled and but gratified to see a
turnout like this or
talk about is
that's true i think his most personal
work seems judging from his letters it
was the the work he cared most deeply
about was the work that he felt revealed
himself the most and the work that
he thought
would introduce him
to the uh general public
you know he's
okay hopes for it very anxious about it
too very anxious about
its reception
he's afraid to come across a bit of
literary entertainment
and i think uh
that
accounts for the the
strangeness of the work and then
yes i might ask you if any of you felt
that wondered if you were reading
philosophy
and
reading
the spake sarah after the star
did you have
or is there anything in the uh in the
book that you particularly struck you
any passages that
puzzled you
all they'd like to
hear from you
uh what your reactions were to that i
think are very
unusual work
i thought i was reading a new theology
okay
where he
emphasizing creation
created
another story about jesus christ
he he has his own jesus christ
and the story that that man tells
is very different from the traditional
stories
that jesus christ would have told he
used some of the same he uses some of
the same
scenery
from the bible
but
but the impact is totally different
okay can you think of an example of
and that he talks
remember the sellers
who say they see him
in the air
and then the next passage i believe
he's on the boat with them
and they're frightful and i recall that
from the bible
but i'm not a i don't remember too good
from the bible but i recall that story
and he he uses that
he uses different numbers associated
with the bible the seven days
all right
seven seals
but was it wasn't he using that uh
that technique to really uh
contradict christianity
he wasn't he wasn't supporting christina
he was
he was uh
refuting christianity he thought it was
a weakness of of man religion or morals
or weakness
in man not a strength
and he was using the structure of of the
new testament sort of
as a way of refuting the new testament
not supporting it
no he wasn't supporting it is because i
said he created his jesus christ
but as a christian as a counter to jesus
christ it's different from the
traditional jesus purposely
sort of opposite of christ
that's right well i think that's
opposite because his very basic premise
is
that god is dead
right and that uh there is nothing
higher than
human
the highest element he would speak of as
the
over man
or the ubermensch who is beyond
human beings
or at least have attained a very high
level
but
he
some of the same things that he says are
the things that jesus said
the idea of to be strong is to be humble
and
his
picture of the over man
is one who has the courage
to be humble
wouldn't he agree that uh god is uh
for that man
god is dead for people who like uh
monks or uh go in the forest and uh uh
don't uh uh circulate in in society but
the strong man the healthy man
uh
has his god uh
a a
god who protects the healthy uh uh
openness of man and strength uh
the superman uh really
and uh
the the the the the man who conceives of
god as being
something that you take in the forest
and you pray and you
become very withdrawn from society
yes for him the god is dead
see i would like to present another
consideration that the issue isn't so
much god the issue is the individual yes
that we have the opportunity to create
our own lives and should not depend upon
someone else whether it's a vision of a
god or any kind of protector so i don't
personally think that he was disclosing
his personal values i think he was only
saying that you in essence have to have
your own he may very well have thought
god was special to him but it was his
decision and the purpose of his writing
this book isn't so much to tell people
what he thinks
but just to tell them to think for
themselves of course
so he isn't saying literally god is dead
he's just saying god is a figurehead is
someone you count on rather than be your
own person free to become isn't there
for you i think he would say we are free
to become ourselves because god is dead
that we don't have this authority figure
that looms over us and says this is what
you must do and he saw that in the but i
think it's a symbolism rather than the
reality we don't really know whether or
not he had a god based on this reading
we just know that he's trying to promote
that concept for people so that they can
be their own creator
at least that's my impression i'd like
to go back to ted's original question
and follow up what you're talking about
he asked if this was a philosophy or
literature i'm not too sure
nietzsche was writing philosophy i mean
i
i always think of philosophy as being
more coherent you know this follows this
there's a tremendous amount of
ambivalence here and i'd like to then
follow
keeping that in mind
what is the source of ethics then if
indeed we say we no longer have this uh
this deity to
worry us
we are free of course the idea of him
being a prophet saying do this is
oxymoronic i mean
you know to do this is a command you
know and my command is don't listen to
me uh which is kind of oxymoronic but
where is his source of ethics in this
where does he refer is it just simply
our whim
is this going to be the finality of
of all
our decisions philosophically as i have
a whim to do this therefore
he doesn't tell us that i think it's on
purpose that he does doesn't tell us his
source of ethics because he clearly
wants us to have our own from our own
heart and soul
we're not going to really know his
ethics based on reading this we're only
going to know that he promotes that you
have your own ethics could i beg the
eternal recurrence
could i could i ask you to comment on
that as a source of ethics possibly
nietzsche's source of ethics is this
eternal recurrence which to me
sounds awful
did you say a little more about it so
people
are context well for one thing nietzsche
wasn't real sure what he was talking
about and even when you read this it's
just it's very vague
and scholars have argued this but in
essence it's everything is being
repeated exactly and precisely over and
over and over again it's it's groundhog
day you know over and over and over and
over again so if you can do something in
this life that would make life pl the
same thing is going to occur but if you
have the correct
using a modern term the correct attitude
uh then life will become very pleasant
even though the same things are
occurring
so there's an obligation on the part of
the individual to make life pleasant
because this is occurring again and
again and again i don't know if the
issues make life
pleasant take responsibility
and put your heart into what you're
doing because it could happen over and
over and over again and approach life is
if that's really going to happen
over and over again and if you do if you
approach life that way perhaps you will
be very conscious of who you are and
what you promote as a person see that
that little thing that you said as if
now is it really an as if or
is it
oh i think it's clearly and as if okay
so that's a little different than the
way you would approach a morals and you
i'll believe this as if or
i can't imagine he was saying any
different than that
there's no other indication in his
writing that he believes in all kinds of
lies and stuff eternal
occurrence i've read
explained in a in a very different way
uh
not that he believed in
a repetitive
you know like a cyclical
repetition
but that he believes in more of like an
eternal now
conspect
concept
where everything that's happened up to
this moment
uh has built upon
every previous moment and therefore
every every moment is
in effect a recurrence of of the
previous
moments
um
so it's as though it's a repetition but
it's really not a repetition because it
each moment is slightly different but
basically it's a recurrence you mean
it's just kind of a summing up of what's
happening right it's just summing up
going all the way back to
to the creation uh
and
i can't believe that nietzsche believed
in in our cyclical
uh
recurrence as as
i think you've stated
because he was too too bright of a
person for that well i think there's
yeah
in fact i think in absolute terms
he believed that everything would recur
in a cycle if you like
and therefore there is no real death
but but what's your basis
this one
first of all i don't i don't know if he
understood biology but certainly there's
no real death and mild there's just
cyclical events and there's certainly in
the cosmos
there's just expansion and contraction
so i i don't know where his science was
but
to clarify some other things i i i think
there's no question that
he
believed that there was no
transcendental ideal or
or god is is dead
and
therefore as you say
the individual must take over and i
think there's a problem because he also
said
and i don't have it exactly but that
all anticipates work
simultaneously and that's not even a
paraphrase but that's
my language
in other words the the old aristelian
idea of either or is not going to work
anymore both and will work so one can't
exclude his
unconscious mutterings
but then again one can't totally include
them either
so that a society or an individual
has to
pick and choose at the moment but that
all may be true and valid
yeah
see the question about where is where
his moral
standard or basis comes from i think
that's the big question and
and i think
to to assume that nietzsche actually
believed in his eternal recurrence as a
cyclical thing is is selling him very
short
he knew of uh
in his time i mean he he was well
educated to his time he knew of
darwin
he he understood all that
so
so the whole notion of this
this
old hindu type belief in this recurrence
i just can't believe that he would ever
have believed that um
yes a particular one maybe we shouldn't
be focusing on this too much that's not
what we're trying to learn suggest
another approach does what difference
does this make to your ethics whether
you believe in an eternal return
you believe in a kind of a straight line
of existence
as to his morality i believe that he
would say
that the unconscious readout of the
primitive
in me
as a leader ruler
would be the ethical and virtuous
stance that i might have
that to
be weak and humble
and considerate of my fellow man
is a stance of
slavery and will not
result in
uh
new paradigms being created or imagined
and will result in a kind of stasis and
therefore to be rejected i think
uncontrovertibly he says that over and
over again
well it gets rid of that very sloppy
thing called judgment day
yeah
i mean it really does and it's a very uh
to him that's an obnoxious thing you
know the idea that or can we say that um
conversely every day is judgment day
is that fair to say
resolution day but because you have a
responsibility to make to make something
out of out of every day does that make
every day judgment day or does that make
no day judgment day
i think every day is overcoming day and
overcoming is really examining not
substantially succeeding
judgment as well any talk of of uh
nietzsche and uh ethics rules and all is
is anathema he uh he uh
is very clear
that that these
rules morality ethics are the
uh uh refuge of the weak
and uh that
you know
we we should retrust simply
uh the healthy attitude that
uh we're living now and that life is
open and full
and that
morals don't matter ethics doesn't
matter it don't matter isn't that an
ethic what you just said what isn't that
an ethic what you just espoused is the
idea that we are strong we are living
the earth belongs to the living we do
that sounds like a pretty strong beauty
is the way he covers this or doesn't
cover it is the two things that he
continues to emphasize are happiness and
silence
neither of which can be defined and
that's the beauty of it he doesn't want
you to know what the ethics are he
doesn't want you to know what the things
are he wants you to make it for yourself
not for everybody else so the issue of
happiness the issue of silence neither
one of those can be clearly defined
per se they're individually interpreted
and that's all he's really getting at
okay yeah you are not a judge that's
right an ethics would have to be
relative
that's right that's exactly what he's
saying
well his words transitory notice
the word he uses for ethics is good and
evil there's tran
you don't have it right left you
recognize a good and evil or transitory
some of that effect
well
but but you mean you mean that they come
and go yes
and and uh
what do you mean by evil or isn't that
something that that that you conceive
uh in other words
but you conceive the good you can see
the evil and uh they come and go
what what's the ground uh where
where do we where is he
where can you stand if you
uh your
sense of evil your sense of goodness uh
come and go
i isn't isn't the basis uh
uh
the the strong life that that that don't
take uh
uh
refuge in uh
rules or
or
concepts of of humility or helping this
one or helping the weak and all why of
course you do those things but but the
key is to be
big strong
and
healthy and make your own decisions not
about particularly about good and evil
which
i'm just not so sure where that fits in
but but uh
about being uh
uh
uh
aware of life is open and fullness and
and things like that
solves all the problems of rules
well john you were talking about
humility not uh five minutes ago where
does that fit in let me cite another
passage
he says
you say it is the good cause that
justifies war
i say it is the good war
that justifies any cause yes yes very
very very uh
i'm not going to be bound by
external rules right
i'm being bound by what i'm doing but
you're not going to fear war either no
he says that he goes on to say war and
courage are a have accomplished more
great things and than love of neighbor
not your pity
but your courage has so far saved the
unfortunate
it comes from within him
rather than some external standard which
he has to obey
and that's why he says god is dead
because that standard is no longer there
well he values
he values the individual strength over
everything
yes and he has no
no care for
individual suffering
he he mentions that
that he realizes if uh if the over man
ever ever
materialized
it would cause tremendous upheaval in
the world there'd be wars
uh like has never been seen before and
he
he takes the approach that that would be
a good thing
because to him
what we consider christian ethics
is total nonsense it's the weakness of
the human being not just not his
strength
and
so he's very very strange person yeah
thinking that way
but it's one of the things like richard
was saying is nietzsche really a
philosopher
is one of the problems that
that uh these poet philosophers i i
think of them as nietzsche is one sartre
is another uh
emerson and thoreau these people
who
they don't go a b c they don't follow
their thoughts uh in such a way that
that they're easy to interpret
and so somebody like nietzsche can never
really be interpreted
to
in
a really
abc understandable way
every writer that writes about nietzsche
has a different opinion about him yes
they do yeah well that's that's that's
how philosophers are all that's what
they're all about i mean philosophy is
to raise questions and not to have
answers
so there are many interpretations of him
and i'm sure everybody that's what he
really wants he wants people to take it
upon themselves to be an interpret from
him and let that be their lesson i mean
based on this book what's that yeah but
philosophers
like kant and and aristotle and plato
those people
they can be understood to some extent
the poets poets can't be understood
because because they're not coherent
they're they're here they're there
they're everywhere and and nietzsche is
a poet well let's say that that's the
case let's say that nietzsche wants
us
to do something different with his work
then just for the sake of argument then
kant wanted us to do
what do you all think that nietzsche
wants from us as readers what do you
think he wants to happen to me when i
read the spake zaratustra i mean what's
he get what is he going for i ask myself
that question
before i even think for myself do you
think i mean because i think he wants me
to be angry i think he wants me to be
shocked
i think he wants me
to
be disgusted
and i think he wants me to feel i mean
he calls it all in one lump nausea he
wants you to get nauseous before you go
to the next fight well there it is i
mean it's prior to something else in
other words he thinks that i i get the
feeling he thinks i need to have these
feelings before i can get beyond them
and i think that's true with most things
in life we don't change until we go
through a catharsis which allows us then
to be another place because he is an
annoying human being yes he there is
this part uh
the stillest hour it is the last part of
two
and before he goes into three now three
is his exposition on
the eternal recurrence
and when i read this it sounded very
much like the dark knight of the soul
kind of thing i mean here he has reached
a point where
this voiceless voice is talking to him
about life
and the voiceless voice says you know
the answer don't you and he says yes but
i'm not going to say so
and and this voiceless voice goes over
and it ties in with what you said
earlier uh and i'm sorry your first name
again john and and you said
this phrase i said
thou art not yet humble enough for me
humility hath the hardest skin
and i just thought wow i mean is he
saying that
this this philosophy of violence is
really at its core
the most humble
i mean is this what you were getting at
earlier
the person who's i'm humble i'm humble
is usually the one who's after something
and he's weak
it's the person who
truly becomes strong who can truly be
humble
can let go
hmm just to confirm what you say
those who give charity are doing it out
of a power play of sort so if you're
really a powerful person
there's no problem in your giving
charity and being empathetic to others
it's the same yeah
that's what you give charity you're
really giving up for yourself yeah
exactly
isn't one of the attractivenesses of of
of nietzsche
the fact that
he encourages you to face danger
uh don't be afraid you know
do
act
the the man who falls off the wire is
congratulated because at least he faced
danger
don't take refuge in
humility or
doing good or things like that you're a
human being who faces uh who who who
does things who is strong
and
and uh
anxious to act
but this i i need to clarify this
stillest hour it constantly comes to me
it's right before he is giving his
strongest
ideas
this strong man that you talk about this
rugged individual this you know this
anne ran kind of you know fountain head
kind of you know nothing will stand in
my way you know uh i i get the feeling
that he's saying i there has to be this
moment of
deep deep reflection about what it is
that you truly are
before you boldly go into matador you
know that there has to be this moment
and
he says it in there then it spoke to me
again without voice you must yet become
as a child and without shame the pride
of youth is still upon you you have
become young late but whoever would
become as a child must overcome his
youth too yes he goes through that then
he says and laughter surrounded me alas
how this laughter tore my entrails and
slid open my heart and it spoke to me
for the last time oh zarathustra your
fruit is ripe but you are not ripe for
your fruit thus you must return to your
solitude again for your must yet become
mellow
and that's basically what this stillest
hour tells him he's not finished yet he
must yet become mellow yeah i just my
concern is that we in his rejection of
christianity that we don't go back to
the gladiator but we go forward to
something even nobler i mean greatly
nobler than christianity i i i i get the
feeling sometimes that it's
we're seeing nietzsche as this
the spokesman for the gladiator and i
said i i don't think this is what's on
his mind i really don't i think he was
profound he was disturbed by something
that
uh that we have to take that time
and to overcome requires that moment is
there some connection then between this
uh
risk taking and
humility
today yes
i can't help but wonder if there isn't
is that is humility something very very
difficult
right there's a long discussion of the
sort of the ethical uh
as you call it uh ethical food chain in
that chapter on the self overcoming the
weaker obey the strong and
the strong obey somebody's stronger and
somebody stronger and the strongest of
all are the most obedient you know and
i
the outcome of humility as i think he
saw it in large was
the concept of the quality of man
and then you would have if we're all
humble
we would have democracy and
utilitarianism where one
in uh
the greatest good for the greatest
number
and you would eliminate
elitism
and therefore eliminate in his terms uh
conquest of uh nature of uh intellectual
conquest and you'd
make everything
moderate into a dull
repetitive uh
life and he saw that as
as evil and i think he believed
uh that
england in their ascendancy and
in their uh protestantism and democracy
in quotes
was a real uh
problem for europe
and uh
he would in his writings
create a rebirth a rejuvenation
of the fierceness of the
north european
blonde blue-eyed
conquerors like the northmen
a very dangerous guy
[Laughter]
we're trying to trying to figure out
what his ethics really are but
you think there's a real possibility it
was just a cynical he's just a cynical
person
and he's just playing around with uh
he's obviously a
a true genius
and what does a true genius who's a
who's a good
tremendous writer
one of the one of the best writers of
the german language ever
uh what does he do to occupy his time
i mean
he may very well just be playing games
do you think it could be both he could
be cynical and idealistic at the same
time able i mean we possibly sure but
but the idea that he's he really has a
real
morality uh or a real
uh plan for for for man's future uh but
no matter he may not let me ask you this
is it possible that it was a selfish
gesture on his part and he really just
wanted to overcome his own hang-ups
about his illness absolutely
is that could that be enough that no
matter who he was he was human i mean he
he knew that like maybe that was his
moment of humility i mean he he isn't
god he can't write history he can't
write the future
this is his idea his philosophy
maybe but he will never know the final
thing is a hoax i don't see any humility
in nietzsche at all put in a blender to
two facts that
uh which both are
perhaps incorrect that that man is an
individual and sir
and his best self-interests are to serve
himself
no one else and put in
also the
the
the fact that uh
the darwinian idea that their survival
of the fittest and all well it also
included god is dead
i suggest if you have any courage you
come out with uh
some variation of the spake has arrested
a lot of love whatever you know i mean
what else can can there be he he was
courageous enough to jump
that
that hurdle and say yes
uh the the normal readout of human
beings as animals if we're
totally self-interested
and if there's survival of the fittest
and those that are fittest uh are the
ones that fit into the environment then
you come out with his whole morality
i think we have to talk about
those
concepts that i just mentioned are they
correct or not but if you assume those i
think you have to come out with that
well i think you have to look at
humility
uh as one concept
uh
on the other side of it you know uh it's
it's well to be humble but you know if
you if you start taking refuge
uh in just being humble all the time uh
it becomes an overwhelming aspect of
your life and and
that isn't really what life is all about
if you if you take christian ethics and
you take refuge in christian ethics why
uh
you you
become so involved with that doing right
which you think is right and so on so
forth whereas if you are
a healthy open individual you'll see of
course you have to be
humbled sometimes or be nice to people
or things like that but but but the the
importance is that you are an individual
an openness a
a
a matter of strength to uh to others
and and uh you know the the the key is
not to take refuge
uh in uh
what we call ethical concepts uh because
that that doesn't make life
i don't think
there's any characteristic
that we may call a virtue
or a a positive
point
that isn't susceptible to his criticism
nothing is sacred nothing is safe
not even humility
you're safe
in the sense that you're strong
you can you can decide what what
these things are if you're if you if you
determined to be an individual
but you but you're it seems to me you're
looking for goodness in nietzsche oh yes
and you're you're thinking that that
this notion about
not relying on chris christian ethics as
a as a crutch
can be overcome in a positive way
uh
i think you're you're warning nietzsche
to be positive here but he's not i don't
think he is bots
i think he is he he he grew up in a very
strict
domineering christian family
he he rebelled against christianity
and he is a religious
and
he thinks religion is the weak weak
weakness of man
and
man at his best is
immoral
and i think that's what what he believes
and to try to read
morality into that belief i think we're
fooling ourselves
and here's the passage where he says
look my uh a strong man has the god and
and his god is
uh
one who likes soap bubbles uh
butterflies uh i would have the god who
dances
right
we'll see
his idea is that god
has been
projected as
the after world
and he is saying that your god should be
on earth
that people are of or of earth and that
their god should be of earth his eternal
reoccurrence
is not similar to reincarnation because
he tells his disciple disciples you're
the first one who will teach it
and it's this idea that
the individual
must
overcome over and over and over again
until the person gets it right but not
in the after world right here
it's teachable
the eternal
recurrence is teachable
right here on earth
what is to be overcome follow him
he's a nasty man
[Laughter]
oh one thing is equality
is to be overcome well all right what
does he mean what does he mean by
equality i think you're right but i
think again what is he well i think i'd
be pretty clear on what in this book
why do we have to see that literally the
way we see it instead of the way i think
he meant it i think he means overcome to
be examined
not master but examined yeah
and way and if you look at it that way i
think you can take a totally different
interpretation of a lot of the things
that he says you have to be careful
there because now you're bordering on
the socratic concept and you know what
he thought about socrates i know that he
admired socrates a lot
i
yes
i absolutely feel that you do i
absolutely well i i don't think he had
that much admiration for the man he was
a greek scholar and i the little i know
in the greek philosophy
was this concept of allothea or aluthera
maybe you know
yeah the truth but the truth is
is within it's not
external and so
part of the surpassing or at least in my
translation but surpassing not overcome
is
to find that within one
in addition to surpassing
others
as a way of
validating your own manhood and humanity
yeah
but it doesn't stop there it has to be
manifest
it isn't just simply
looking within and saying i found it it
has to be manifest it comes behavior
this fourth part which to me is totally
different than the other three i you
know i found the fourth part almost
burlesque you know he
i know really i mean just some of the
incidences there i was just laughing at
you know hysterically i mean and
and yet he's like
yeah right no i'm saying i mean that but
that has a lot of symbolism i mean i
think that would be a neat discussion
what did he really mean by this as
festival and these long ears and why was
that such a prominent thing well in
literature that's the manipian parodies
in other words
i will tell you something but that's not
really what i mean but you really know
that's what i mean
you know it's that kind of play back on
work and in that he he comes up in part
four with some of his
great ideas and he kind of slides
things in the middle of this humor he
jesus you know god hath died now do we
desire we desire the superman to live to
live not just to know it
but to live we are we are that and it's
a
i like that idea
this definition of life was
to go beyond
in other words
we in this room
by his definition are not even alive
or exist have to be to over munch in
order to be alive
you have to be an examined person
well you have to you have to whatever he
never really defines i don't think
exactly what that is but you have to go
beyond
the human being to even be alive in his
in history
well elsewhere
i don't well in other words i'm sure
there is but but he said
i think he
he he purposely is defining life in in
that way i mean uh that that human
beings with with christian ethics are
not alive to him
so when he says
when he refers to that
you know that's what he means i think
how about a person who is humble and who
is taking the risk of examining how
things are
does that person get any credit for
taking that risk for living in that
danger zone rather than
spouting bromides and uh
and being humble so they have no
decisions to make i mean in each's work
does that person get some credit for
having begun the process of dancing
instead of walking probably humble
within himself humble humble in the fact
that he he is uh
he is
intellectually honest to himself humble
but not humble before other individuals
he gives no credit for that right
and the whole purpose of the whole book
is that is to go and examine and then as
a result of that become your person so
certainly he not only gives credit but
that's what the whole book's about is
going off and examining yeah it's not
freedom to decide it's freedom when you
decide exactly i mean it's there's a
little difference there but it's there
it makes a difference in the way you
live and at the end of this chapter this
one you're talking about he decides he
knows he's not quite ready yet but this
hour this whatever i forgot the chapter
still establishing number 44. he is at
the point where he has the laughter but
he knows he hasn't gone back and
finished dealing with his youth and some
of the problems yeah right
we can't move on yet but recall that in
an early chapter he ridicules the
academic professor
who uh
thinks good thoughts but doesn't act
well so so clearly
performative behavior
is essential it's not enough to think
the good thought or have the good ethic
or have the the great campaign system no
that's not it yeah
well
yeah the academic is the one who puts
people to sleep you know that is his
purpose uh is to uh
uh
act um
on principles and and things like that
which uh
which uh
is a sambulant uh
attitude uh it's the received wisdom as
opposed to the kind that comes from
within
the
no no
it's the kind that that challenges
people
uh you know uh uh
the professor has
is is a challenging character
is is the what is the professor a
challenging character to nietzsche quite
the quite the opposite
exactly exactly yes uh the the the the
the challenge comes from uh
recognizing you're in danger
and
you know you you
respond to that
there is a passion that backs us up he
gets to round to the point of academics
and
it sounds like today in some ways
famous wise men being the professors
famous wise men are asses
hitched in front of the powerful man's
horses to lead them in the quote right
way yes
that's what happens many times
[Laughter]
i think that's hilarious
no longer a scholar
so he was once a scholar yes so he's no
longer a scholar so but he's but his
path
this metamorphosis is not
clear to me
what what has he done to separate him
from
these people
nietzsche is arthur
zara
oh he's had an epiphany of some sort
right
what is it
that's what it is he's just all of a
sudden
he's he's the messiah all of a sudden
he comes off the mountain what do you
want he could have stayed there for 10
years sound like all of a sudden well
at the moment of messiah them it's all
of a sudden
moment is even if it's at the end of 10
years
i don't know well he didn't have to be
ready to come down from the mountains
yeah right
what does he what do you feel like is
the is the catalyst for him to come down
my personal opinion is that he finally
dealt with the he got rid of the nausea
and he finally dealt with the issue of
pity
which for him was fear
and it was pity
and i think again it ties back to his
own personal life you mean nietzsche's i
think it was getting over pity for
himself in terms of his own illness and
his own sickness
and being able to move out from there i
mean i think that's the whole purpose in
writing this book was to deal with how
he was going to overcome
his illness and be able to work to be
able to write
and i think at the end he even says that
that
now that he is able to be in happiness
and silence what he really wants to do
is work
and i think now he can do it because
he's dealt with
the big fears
and he's dealt with his pity for himself
now he's ready to go back to work
what is the danger of people pitying
themselves and others i mean what what
is nietzsche afraid of
afraid about for us
if we live our lives
looking at other people and saying oh
poor thing
or looking at ourselves and saying oh
poor me
what's that what's the really big danger
there
yeah doesn't he put it in a funny way if
you you pity say the uh the lame man or
the blind man aren't you
suddenly in fact you're taking away his
lameness or you're his blindness
uh
i guess what other crutch does he have
you know his blindness his lameness
well does he
maybe that's it
does he think that the
lame or the blind ought to ought to be
crutched
that way
well he thought
that his own illness
was the best thing ever happened to him
in his in his
philosophical development right and so
here's a man who suffered physically uh
or why very greatly apparently
and yet he he felt like it was the the
best thing that ever happened to him i
think so why should he pity why should
he pity he gave him the opportunity to
examine and then to come under exactly
and then to come over yeah now coming
over is examining
it's under is when he's able to teach
what he's learned yeah and so why is it
why does he think it's a better starting
point to have suffering than to be that
person who just seems to have everything
and everything is easy for that person
why is it easier to be the one who
starts from suffering i don't think you
ever get any place unless you've been
through a lot as it were in this case
to think and examine your life in a way
that maybe that person has everything
hasn't felt that that
compulsion to do that maybe like if they
have everything they don't have the
reason to ask why am i suffering
that somebody who is sick might have
yeah yes and christianity would
trivialize that according to him
because your reward is in the next world
and you're not taking the suffering now
you know you're really saying well i'll
really get my reward elsewhere i'll
suffer but there's really a great reward
yeah that tiny tim yeah kind of
mentality that's good and isn't his is
it his reward laughter and courage
uh pride and wisdom
well that's what gets him where he gets
yeah i mean it's the laughter and
courage the rewards but the things that
got him through were his two animals his
one representing pride the eagle on the
other representing
wisdom which was the serpent so they
were with him in silence and
courage and so in a sense
they were with him through this whole
process and then at the end when he was
able to enjoy who he'd become
it was as a result of the happiness and
silence that they basically gave through
to him which ultimately gave him
the ability to be able to be have
laughter and courage i i like when he
comes off the mountain he raises a
question to the son
and i had not i completely missed this
until someone asked the question in this
room and i said i got to go back
and it says thou great star
what would be thy happiness if thou
hatched not those for whom thou shinest
in other words you'd be the same
whether or not any humans were down here
you would be as brilliant and as bright
and as magnificent as you are whether
anyone was here or not and i said wow
that's a very powerful urge to go
through life with that feeling of i am
who i am i am magnificent period the end
and no matter what influence i'm still
going to be this magnificence i didn't
take it that way but would the sun be
magnificent if you didn't have people to
explain how it is magnificent that's a
good point
it would rather remind me of the
question about the tree falling in the
forest you know from a audiologist's
point of view there's no sound unless
there's
something
an ear to hear the uh
you know remember he is he is a poet i
mean he is speaking as a poet in this
respect i mean i don't think he's really
addressing the sun either i think he's i
think he's really referring to himself
right you know but but no no i mean
because i think this
struck me as a central point that the uh
the sun's
magnificence is only
magnificent if there is someone to
appreciate it
and furthermore the sun's real
magnificence is it's going under
as it's sinking down and spreading out
over the sea
and as you know every commentator
reminds you the word for going under
that comes over over and over again is
the same word in german for perishing
and
somehow
that
you know on the one hand i want to think
of the guy who got out of play to his
cave and goes
goes back
dragged the others out on the other hand
this is a suggestion that in your uh
that in yourself overcoming your
perishing too
well you have to
you would have to perish before you
you overcame and established yourself
you would have to the old self has got
to die i mean you know period i mean
it's it can't be lingering in it so it's
you know
i mean it's interesting i i thought and
well even maybe even the wholesaler i
thought that
passage
there was
absolutely crucial
and suggests
how incorrect nietzsche really is
because i think
he mistakes
the natural
self of man to be an individual a self
contained corpus and i think
that's obviously incorrect i think
we are all born to families and of
course
in primitive life there was kin
uh
and
the altruism between kin
was absolutely natural there were
hunting groups that shared there was no
way in
in
the development of man to survive as an
individual in fact we're we're built to
be
gregarious now here's a man who uh never
married
uh
never fondled children uh
uh lived by himself he doesn't
understand the satisfaction joy is
delight
of others
and from just a mechanistic point of
view a biological point of view
our parents or our children have half
the genes that we do
and
if if the purpose of life is replication
of genes then if two survive
that's equivalent to use so clearly it's
in our genes to be
it's a bad word altruistic or or have
feeling no but it is for others and he
he bases his whole concept of everything
on individual man and that's why he's
in fundamental and
in every fundamental elementary way
absolutely incorrect and i think that's
that's the the
the the the flaw in the whole
death is a perfect i mean his own
breakdown is a perfect example that the
man does have feelings he saw somebody
beating a horse and it totally totally
took him under it i don't want to use
the word under totally did him in
because he couldn't stand to see the
horse suffer well doesn't that
be 300 pages before that you know well
i'm saying i i think it's it's coming is
making a judgment about somebody who
wasn't into being judged
he didn't talk about his feelings that
was the whole thing of it he wanted you
to talk about yours
but if you look at what what he had the
nervous breakdown over and what really
took him under it was because it pained
him and broke him up seeing somebody
beating a horse and he went over and put
his arms around the horse and
i mean that's not a man without feeling
that you're irrelevant
it's not irrelevant well it's the whole
point of of this oberman is to overcome
what you just said nietzsche recognized
the fact that man uh had evolved he knew
darwin he he recognized the social
evolution the
biological evolution and he saw that as
a weakness
and and the whole point of the overman
is to overcome that
you know he hated the idea that great is
good for the greatest number that was
like an awful concept i mean it was just
terrible and
yeah and you went back to this altruism
i i i wanted to ask you earlier john you
you're saying that there is no such
thing as an altruistic act
is in essence because you were going in
that direction and i oh would that be
true if you're strong enough
if you're strong enough to include to
overcome your own self-interest
but say can you give charity knowing
that you're doing good for yourself but
also doing good for somebody else does
that invalidate your charity
i mean
well i think nietzsche's problem is that
people can't tell the difference the
people any people give to charity
they're really doing it to benefit
themselves
according to nietzsche and uh
without you know considering whether
it's going to benefit the uh recipient
see there's a clarity that i'll be very
honest with you i hope i don't put me in
this classification with him but i enjoy
that clarity the idea of no there isn't
an altruistic act everything you do is
selfish why don't you just admit it and
live with it i mean every act that you
do i mean even the the nuns who go to
the leper colonies yes yes yes we
understand but what you're getting is
little green cards to go to heaven i
mean that's what you want but don't you
think that some acts
while they can still be complete they
can
come from a selfish perspective the
result can be more or less selfless i
mean not every single act
well now you're judging by consequent
rather than motive right yeah
well
this is the whole thing he's saying
don't be judgmental to begin with so it
doesn't matter
i think in this case he does he does
want to make a judgment here because
he does think that there are some
that that
there's a kind of charity that is that
does harm both the giver and the
recipient
yes yeah you know even if the uh
it's a kind of charity that's
done for the wrong reasons is going to
have the wrong consequences
even if the consequences appear to be
beneficial
they could they can like uh
you know giving your
you know your four bits to the homeless
uh man on the corner
all right if that's
you know preventing that homeless man
from uh doing something to amend his
life in a productive way in the long run
uh that's ultimately harmful that's a
kind of a
rough example like
well what about the
the tough love movement um
that some people might know a little bit
about i don't know if anyone's had
personal experience with it but the
tough love movement says that the nicest
thing you can do for any other human
individual that would include your own
children is to treat them like a
responsible person even if they're not
acting like a responsible person hmm in
other words so throw them away from
yourself what would you say to a mother
who's suckling her child
is is she being selfish there
or is she extending
her uh
selfness to
someone else
i mean it seems to me this individualism
that he proposes just breaks down
right away in families
in groups that have to survive with
consequences that they can only live
together
certainly farmers
or when agriculture came you needed
protective groups you needed
and he
says nothing about that he believes that
darwin's ideas extend only to the
individual and not to social groups and
of course that just ain't true
right
the individual
thing so that that was an issue right i
agree exactly that
that's that's where he's mistaken you
think because well that's if you decide
that that's the way it should be but
he's deciding should be different
or that he's just not going to discuss
that now you know he's just talking
about this subject not another subject
i'm trying to talk about truth and
reality what
what is
real shall we
live according to our primitive will
as individuals is that a correct way of
living does that make sense or does it
not make sense because of the way human
beings inherently are because his
arguments are that human beings
inherently are willful and we might as
well just
forget about the taboos of repressing
all these
unconscious
motives of of wanting to kill a need and
conquest and just expose them you see
but
and that's based on
on the idea that they're that we are
just individuals
but if
that's not the case
if the currency of human beings are
groupings then clearly i don't want to
eat the the people i'm depending on to
hunt with me you see
was it conceivable
you have to figure out
what what your expression is going to be
about before you could create it and i
thought he was just in that creating who
you are and expressing it period right i
think that's and that's phrased mistake
well unfortunately he didn't talk about
communities and families because he
really didn't have a lot of personal
experience at that he talked about what
he knew exactly but but that's not
necessarily wrong that's just what he
could do well don't you think that it's
wrong that we human beings are
isolated individuals
no i think that's judgmental i think
some people that's always going to
happen to them and i think you can go to
other philosophers or poets and learn
something else but this is what you can
learn from him if you choose to if you
assume that we're individuals if you
choose to that's right and that's all
he's saying i'm not going to try to make
all people's needs met through my
philosophy i'm not dealing with things
that i can relate to and suffering was a
big one he could relate to
right
isn't he saying look let's accept all
this of life
all this uh this uh uh
wars uh uh
greed uh things like that uh that's part
of life you must you must accept that
but but the worst thing is to give in to
certain things like
like uh
um
greed or
aspects of life that that you know are
surrounding you
but the healthy attitude is to rise
above these things
uh to uh to recognize them to treat them
even with laughter as he says
and to
make a full strong life
not surrounded by
rules against this or not thinking this
or or rules uh i hear or or or or
ironic tra
humility where you you do something uh
for um uh
uh an ulterior purpose or something like
that but but there's an aspect of life
that everyone must feel i mean everyone
here must feel that that that you know
you can you can rise above these things
and and and lead a full happy uh
strong life without uh restrictions and
things like that without
worrying about christian morals or
anything else
you don't live by
in that context how do you explain his
statement and he he made the statement
several times that
if someone has cursed you
don't get mad do some cursing yourself
well what what's the difficulty
uh
if someone curses me
uh i shouldn't be angry no but you no
you should not be angry you should curse
that person
well well isn't that a natural reaction
is there anything wrong with uh with you
know if somebody whacks me in the nose
and i whack them in the mouth
i mean after all this is life
do
is it your position that if someone uh
whacks me over the head with a stick
i should say thank you or
that i should say uh
i'll turn my back and let you whack the
back too and all
doesn't seem to me that's a very
practical thing what about initiating
hitting someone over the head with a
stick who me yes you
well i i you know i would have to have a
purpose there well you just will it you
you won't well i'm not that early but
but that isn't that isn't reality is it
uh you know if i'm er
i don't go around with the reality of
the
his will is expressed but it's not whim
it's will of course okay
let's make sure we don't get the two
if you're saying i have the capability
of doing that yes i will agree with you
but but if if you say in reality i would
do such things why i think that that
that's a little uh removed from reality
and you don't it doesn't doesn't work
here uh
well i i i don't see it in
reality i i i see nietzsche uh saying
that you as an individual to survive if
you need to whack the person over the
head with a stick my next question would
be if you're hungry are you going to
whack your mother over the head with a
stick you
uh i think that's
suggesting that we're each individuals
your mother
and you and i think that's a false
notion
well does does does being in a group
mean you're any less of an individual
somehow i think this distinct
i wonder about this distinction between
individual and group
well i think so
from what i know is that
uh
before say 2500 years ago or so all
human beings survived in terms of groups
and only with the beginning of the greek
city-states
did this
whole concept of individualism
uh start being propounded as uh
really as a way to
give responsibility to individuals who
are now
separated from their tribe or or group
so it's a very artificial
situation that we really aren't
individuals
we're we're in groups and furthermore
in our heads we're extended
in time and and place we don't
just
in fact we never quite live in the
present so
i think if if you factor in all those
ideas i think
that
you have to say that nietzsche just was
incorrect could i ask you to define
census of philosophy club what is the
difference in your opinion between an
individual and a personality
because individual to me sounds like
it's just a biological thing
yeah an individual would be sure
a separate uh
reproducing uh source
a personality i don't know how that's
relevant but to me it would be
the
the mind
which
lives not in the present but i can live
well like i'm constantly being in the
future where i'm going to be i i live uh
in the past time you know so
i
i'm not just in this corpus box of
individuals exactly so i mean perhaps
nietzsche is working on this concept
that the overcoming is the overcoming of
the individual to become personality and
individualism is just a point of view uh
well personally if you consider yourself
an individual uh
then you are an individual if you
consider yourself just just a an
appendage of a group
then that's what you are and you be both
no i don't think so i mean
you can't be an appendage you can be a
member of a group and still be an
individual but you can't definitely you
can't be a finger on the same hand no
and and be an individual
but people also act differently within
um
as a group than they do
i mean like sociologically now their
studies that
exist
but nietzsche would say that that's an
evil
because the highest the highest
aspiration of a human being can be is
his individuality not his function as a
group and i don't think he as far as i
know he he never
extrapolated this this this uh
philosophy into a political philosophy
he didn't he didn't try to create some
utopian notion about what his society
would be like
he as you were saying he this is uh this
is uh
focusing in on on human nature and what
he thought a human being uh
should be
what a human being's highest aspirations
were
and forgetting about the social and
political aspects of it right and
obviously i mean i think we probably all
agree that the political aspects of this
whole notion are are
just incomprehensible
it just isn't something that won't work
in a in a society where there's more
than three people well let me let me ask
you
um i
i have heard it said that friedrich
nietzsche is a psychologist and one of
the first
are we saying that the nietzsche's book
is really a psychology book yes
and that he does not deal with these
implications and that other people have
taken his work and have interpreted it
for their own purposes when they want to
think about uh the state
when they want to think about ethics but
for nietzsche
he's talking about
the struggle of being one human person
is it possible he's a psychologist
well he's giving zorbo meaning he's
giving you know i mean
zorba the greek is is this personality
it's incredible it's very free it's very
it doesn't talk of equality it talks of
expression manifesting it you know it's
a true personality it isn't simply i
follow the group and this is what you're
the herd mentality is is what you're
trying to get rid of you're trying to
get the master mentality and my thought
is that's the beauty of the whole thing
he is nietzsche just like the word
psychologist the word philosopher the
word
writer the word teacher
he is all of those things and yet none
of those things and that's the beauty of
it he refuses to be put in a box he
absolutely refuses doesn't ever use the
word uh state or group he used the word
heard
that's his pejorative uh
aspect yes he does because
his lines uh freud said that nietzsche
was
was the most uh
he knew himself more more than anyone
who's ever lived
and likely ever to
ever will live
so freud had a very high opinion of
nature
[Laughter]
but still in all when you talk about
psychology
what does this say does this bear just
suggest another view of philosophy here
if you're going to say i mean at least
we almost sound like you're suggesting
that for nietzsche philosophy originates
in psychology
instead of say metaphysics
i wonder
i wonder
i don't know i can point to passages
here where he talks about
the might this has something to do with
his celebration of the body
the earthly
the dionysian what difference does it
make well that's a very good question
what difference does it make what your
starting point is and i wonder if
nietzsche thinks that the starting point
has to be
the confusion
um
of human beings in the face of
impermanence whether it's a group of
human beings or whether it's an
individual human being but that that
sort of confusion kind of does
start here
i think it makes a difference i i i
think it does make a great demon i think
he inherited
schopenhauer's eye
concept which
i think i'm quoting the the world is my
idea
meaning that
the the world is
my perception it doesn't exist as is it
exists
in my head so
if i can pull out
my real unconscious motives
which he does and articulate them
well then you have a clear page of where
to go from here i mean that's that's the
greatness you think that's what do you
think
do you like that idea
well i i'm
it doesn't really matter if i like it i
think
it's it's it's one of the great jumps in
the uh
history of uh
well
aside from all that do you do you uh so
aside from all that you associate your
life with that do you do you find
anything interesting in it
schopenhauer's use of the idealistic
mind for the world
is that of any well used practically
i i think it's absolutely true i think
it can be shown
that all i don't want to go through a
whole i could with you after but that
really all what you
think out here is reality is
just a perception of a mind that he
evolved in the late place to pleistocene
age do you think that
of course i think that i would be
telling you if i didn't all right all
right that's that's that's
the point how how how can you bump into
trees then
if if your world is only in your mind
forces holding the molecules together i
don't want to get into that but i could
explain that to you and and you would
perhaps understand in fact i just gave a
lecture on that uh just uh
nietzsche
was not an idealist he had contempt for
idealism yes certainly
define your terms
idealism meaning a
world is
totally or a universe is totally mental
totally in the imagination nietzsche
didn't believe that but i don't think
that's what he meant by idealism he
meant saying that this world is created
by our mind that is a form of idealism
well this world is my perception this
world is the universe but this chair
exists but it's also my perception of
this chair oh well and that but that's
not that's not what idealism means
though
the idealism from a philosophical point
of view means that that chair does not
exist except in your
if it's mind it's real
but it doesn't exist outside of your own
perception
and that would be idealism a classic
idea undoubtedly correct well you think
so i don't think so
it makes how we talk about things very
difficult to explain if that's correct
you're talking about you know you asked
about the tree that you bumped into well
it's of course the my idea of a tree
that i bumped into which can't be the
same tree that anyone else bumped into
but but right well exactly
there'll be enough of a tree to talk
about it as a tree not if it's just my
idea but if your idea of a tree is so
incrementally different than my idea of
a tree we can still talk about a tree
no not unless there's a tree out there
but and you say like my perception of a
tree can be different from yours but it
can be so close but just that much
different that we are able to talk about
that tree
do you see because we come from a
culture where that sees this tree and
defines the street and that's where it
goes
how do we decide
how close our ideas are
because we know because we can converse
about this tree oh but i think that has
to do both with similarities of idea and
the fact that there's a tree out there
we're talking about and also linguistics
and as we read in wittgenstein a few
sessions ago
it it's just a like perfect nature
because this is a language
this is
excuse me it's just a language game the
only function of language
is performative you can get things
done with it but it means nothing means
absolutely nothing
and that's it's i know that's so
difficult for you to no it's not just
difficult it's nonsense
what you're saying can't mean anything
if that's true right you can't say look
out for the falling tree well there are
no there are no
as far as i know there are no
serious idealists left
in the philosophical world
idealism is a is a
notion that came and went
royce well everybody on the other hand
people argue that nietzsche is the uh
this was the summa
of idealism and
again for this uh this very
particularly in his regard to his his
ethics
this
idealism applied to uh
morality
oh yeah but that's a different type of
idea that's that's just a mental
idealism as opposed to a physical
idealism
i mean uh
i mean okay i'm wondering if there's
anything i can i keep wondering if there
isn't i
doesn't bridge the two somehow or what's
the connection between the two
i don't think so i think he was a
realist
uh
from a
i mean the rare fact of his contempt for
for religion and things spiritual he was
a realist
so the idea that he would also be an
idealist
especially when he says he's when he
says he's not an idealist i think is
unlikely you don't think an ubermensch
is an ideal huh and you don't think the
idea of the ubermensch is an ideal
something it's an idea it's not it's not
an ideal it's a it's a different word
it's a platonic ideal because the in the
ubermensch is merely potential the
ubermensch can you define what you mean
by ubermensch
no
superman i think it would be important
because that's exactly what i'm saying
the ubermensch is an ideal
it's it's something transcendent it
cannot be reached it has potential it
does not exist
objectively and i would suggest that
there's another way to look at the
ubermensch as just plain anybody who
really examines themselves
that's really all i think he's saying
with ubermensch
truly examines oneself
do we have anything in the book can
anybody think of a anything in the book
that uh might contribute to what is the
every time he refers to uber it's an
examination every time he refers to
under it's teaching
well he talks about man as we know him
as a bridge as a tight rope between the
beast and the uh over man or ubermensch
uber mensch
he talks about
excuse me
his definition changes sometimes because
at one point he says under and then you
have a semicolon and he has dying
had one
dying
well if it's a semicolon it's another
thought if it's a colon it's not but a
semicolon that's another thought that's
what the english teachers say but that's
something well
he he's certainly in the context of the
statement
i can't find it right now
could it be that the superman in some
real sense
is a secular christ
that's where we started isn't it yeah
uh
i still say uberman is the person who
examines himself
but by whom total
intellectual intellectual honesty is
the ability
not to fool yourself right who will
we'll know if you i mean i'm just like
you can keep heart you have people yeah
you have to keep examining yourself
constantly in order to be intellectually
honest
right but i think that's part of that
actually
there's no way there's no standard is
what you say there's no absolute there's
no ultimate reference for any of that
well it cannot be individual it can only
be individual intellectual honesty no
one no
what i'm saying right now you don't know
whether i'm being honest or not only i
know
if i'm not only being honest
with relating what i think but also
if i'm not only being honest with
relating what i think but also
what i think
i have arrived at in an honest way an
intellectually honest way you're quite
unaware of regressions suppressions and
all of that you know that's what
nietzsche is getting at he's trying to
reveal his unconscious or we're back to
some things we said before when you get
that terror when you get that danger
feeling when you get that
fight-or-flight response you might be
close to the truth
you might know
and it doesn't mean alfred knows that
you're having that feeling in the pit of
your stomach that you're telling
yourself something true that you really
wish weren't true about yourself
and the beauty and the absolute
brilliance of the way nietzsche writes
is that he never tells you about himself
the whole book is about the process
is the process of getting there and then
going from there but he does not
contradict because you never find out
who he is in terms of what he examines
and where he gets to in terms of his
process you wouldn't agree that he's
saying every one of us is a superman
no i'm saying absolutely not every one
of us is but he's saying everybody's
capable of being an ubermensch it's just
a matter of whether you have the guts
and the courage to go there
did you find a passage that you had
wanted to read
198 on page 198. what's in this
this edition modern library
now i wait for my own redemption that i
may go to them for the last time for i
want to go to men once more under their
eyes i want to go under dying i want to
give them my richest gift
dying comma is not the same as going
under it's a total another thing by
going under he's saying i want to be
able to go and teach
and then die
dying calm in other words he's still in
the ubermensch phase he's still
examining dying at this point is the
same as examining
i want to give them my richest gift
examining you said was over
the over right now if there's a
semicolon there he's not saying under
and dying are the same word he's saying
i want to go under semicolon in dying in
other words just say dying
i want to get to give them my richest
gift okay so that's substitute
let's go for under let's say i want to
go teaching
i want to go i want to be able to teach
by examining i want to give them my
richest gift i want to be able to give
back to teach
his riches
and underwent with teaching so if you
substitute teaching here
i want to go under and under is equated
with teaching
right he said i want to teach and then
he wants to die
right he wants to give them his richest
gift he wants to be able to do that to
go down and give and
tell them what he's learned through his
examination why does he call it his
redemption and this is
this is the uh
the only past where i can at least the
most uh
obvious passion i can think of which
over man and
redemption
which over man and secular christ
perhaps seem to be associated
here and like redemption is like being
born again it's like in other words by
getting through the examination process
and becoming in this case he refers to
creating the child to again be redeemed
born again so that he can go and teach
so that he can be a child
i like the i like the sentence um that
begins the next paragraph he says like
the sun tsar2stra ii wants to go under
now he sits here and waits surrounded by
broken old tablets and new tablets half
covered with writing
the message being i've done the
annihilating i've done that hard work
and i'm in the process
of creation
it's not that he's got the old tablets
are broken and the new tablets are done
here everyone here's the truth i i went
through the process and now you don't
have to because here here's the truth
the new tablets are only half covered
with writing and the broken tablets is
the ability for the superman to say his
deepest deepest commitment
there is no god
it is ceased to exist it is dead
finished now let's get on with the
business of evolving
you know this is this this concept god
has really held us back
that's done with
now see i have trouble with saying that
it's held us back because i mean
i want to read it more like the
psychologist version that lisa talked
about which is
the book even opens up but you've got
the sign which socrates used as a
analogy for the good
and now it's the sun that rises up to
the cave and it's the people on the
earth that give the sun its meaning
although he did in this passage we just
looked at learn from the sun
but it seems to me that
god's death
the
the
literary play he does with the son at
the beginning of the work
all point to this idea that these
transcendental notions of
morality ethics the good they're gone
yes they're they're not there
and what
perhaps we are going to be faced with in
an eternally recurring way is the fact
that
they're gone but we still have to make
evaluative judgments and
the perhaps the ubermensch has to
recognize in the face of no
external measure
that he's got to make these choices or
she has to make well for nietzsche he's
got to make these choices
and
i don't admit my time to being humble
also
i'm not doing the right thing
but i'm recognizing that i have to make
these choices and
i can't turn anywhere else for it i i do
them but the the
the objection was the idea that we can
get on i mean other than just
recognizing that
each choice we make is ours
yes there's i'm not sure that it would
not that he has to be consistent but
that it would be consistent for there to
be
a kind of progress after realizing this
in the sense that there may have been a
progress for plato or for jesus or
christianity and progressing towards
some sort of ultimate being
that was a useful fiction in its day but
it's finished now right right it's the
kind of well or
maybe just wrong all along
not that it was useful ever it's just
an illusion that we
could we say
um for nietzsche that people are works
in progress but that we won't be
finished or does that just make no sense
at all in other words that you're
constantly a work in progress not toward
any particular goal of being finished
and and perfect in that sense of
you know completely
completely yourself can you be a work in
progress but by definition never be done
yeah exactly exactly
just
again like i i i interpret it as being
the same but not the same
over and over and over again and you're
going to break the tablets and start
writing on some new ones
well man is yeah yeah
people are and of course every
individual has to do it himself that's
another thing right it's not it's not a
cultural thing it's an individual thing
that's that's picasso's
that was picasso's idea finish the art
and you destroy the artist
does that mean that everyone's a
superman
decide for themselves or these things i
think you have to recognize that that's
what you're doing
yes yes and i think it's pretty i mean i
would would say it's clear that's not
everyone
yeah well then how do you make the
distinction are you allowed to say that
you're on what grounds
that's a good question did everybody
here did everybody hear jesse's question
because are you allowed to say that
you're an uberment
sure woman because because it's true
actually
is not male or female exactly
sure because because an overminch would
would be uh brave enough to admit that
he was an overmatch so you're allowed to
what would the fact that you think
you're an
ubermensch mean that you're not one
well
doesn't it doesn't mean this that that
you begin to see
uh
you know what uh
what it means to be
an
ubermensch
and uh
isn't that open to everyone no
i would think no
the becoming one should be open i hope
somebody says no because
well he
he has no use for the uh
bourgeois and by that he means the
business people heard yes well no he i
think he has the the herd and rabble in
a different category there of course uh
clearly not
uh but the
people who have been successful and made
a lot of money
in busyness and in my book it's be a
b-u-s-y and
just keeping busy
uh certainly or not and he mentions that
there would have to be blood
there which i take to be a genetic
uh
factor
so i think he's suggesting
that
the old european aristocracy
has a possibility of being the
ubermensch if they meet some other
uh criteria
which uh
i tell you is is rather dangerous kind
of teaching uh thinking about uh
the history
of uh
european aristocracy and the kinds of
warfare and chaos that
has been created as a direct result of
their rule constantly it reminds me that
wags have said you know the the old
greeks had this idea of being real men
by surpassing other men and there are
very few of those greeks left you know
they killed each other off and i think
perhaps
nietzsche's philosophy if it were taken
intact
as
as a way to perform
would of course result in destruction
and i think and i don't know how much
hitler read of nietzsche and was
following those precepts but i think
that probably is a good example or is
probably the best example that you could
probably give of
of acting it at will absolutely i think
that that's dangerous though is to read
hitler yeah
absolutely well there is
i i agree there is a caveat he says
never will something that is beyond your
power
so you've got to be very honest about
your capacity to
manifest that will it isn't just simply
whim gee i want this or i'm going to go
over there and beat people up it's no i
will will this because i know that i can
do it and it will be manifested
i mean when you were saying earlier
about schopenhauer i mean the will is
world i mean everything in this room
everything in this room is the will of
somebody
it's just a frozen aspect of their will
from table design to books it's the will
of a lot of different kinds of people oh
yes but then no not a one person no it's
some individual is saying i will this
are the electrons running around that
table conforming to your will
i mean be serious i am very serious
that the world is well that they they're
they're in that table but the the shape
of that's why we're designing the table
is your perception
of
of the
of the light beams coming from the
surface of that thing
but the person who conceived of that
table originally had a concept of table
and he exerted that will somewhere to
make sure that table became manifest you
know maybe it was somebody forgotten and
but nevertheless somebody's will was
exerted there well let me raise another
consideration elsewhere nietzsche says
that living is willing
or that just to be alive is to will
but his definition of living was
different than
most definitions
he didn't consider a normal or a present
day let's say
man as being alive
you know one who's able to exercise his
will and be a true individual and
control exercises will to where he's a
he's the master of himself
that that person's alive
one who isn't is not alive
could we say
um for nietzsche that people are works
in progress but that we won't be
finished or does that just make no sense
at all in other words that you're
constantly a work in progress not toward
any particular goal of being finished
and and perfect in that sense of
completely
completely yourself can you be a work in
progress but by definition never be done
yeah exactly exactly
again like i i interpret as being
the same but not the same
over and over and over again and you're
gonna break the tablets and start
writing on some new ones
well man is yeah yeah
people are and of course every
individual has to do it himself that's
another thing right it's not it's not a
cultural thing it's an individual thing
that's that's picasso's
that was picasso's idea finish the art
and you destroy the artist
what does that mean that everyone's a
superman
decide for
themselves i think you have to recognize
that that's what you're doing
yes yes and i think it's pretty i mean i
would would say it's clear that's not
everyone
yeah well then how do you make the
distinction are you allowed to say that
you're on what grounds yeah
that's a good question did everybody
here did everybody hear jesse's question
are you allowed to say that you're an
ubermensch
sure woman because
they're true actually
is not male or female exactly
sure because because an over minch would
would be uh brave enough to admit that
he was an overmatch so you're allowed to
what would the fact that you think
you're an
ubermensch mean that you're not one
well doesn't it doesn't mean this that
that you begin to see
uh you know what uh
what it means to be an
ubermensch
uh and
uh isn't that open to everyone no
i would think no
becoming one should be open i hope
somebody says no because
well he
he has no use for the uh
bourgeois and by that he means the
business people heard yes well no yeah i
think he has the the herd and a rabble
in a different category there of course
uh clearly not
uh but the people who have been
successful and made a lot of money
in busyness and in my book it's be a
b-u-s-y and
just keeping busy
uh certainly or not and he mentions that
they would have to be blood
there which i take to be a genetic
uh
factor
so i think he's suggesting
that
the old european aristocracy
has a possibility of being
the ubermensch if they meet some other
uh criteria
which uh
i tell is is rather dangerous kind of
teaching uh thinking about uh
the history
of uh
european aristocracy and the kinds of
warfare and chaos that uh has been
created as a direct result of of their
rule constantly
it reminds me that
wags have said you know the old greeks
had this idea of being real men by
surpassing other men and there are very
few of those greeks left you know
they killed each other off and i think
perhaps
nietzsche's philosophy if it were taken
intact
as a way to perform would of course
result in destruction
and i think and and i don't know how
much hitler read of nietzsche and was
following those precepts but i think
that probably is a good example or is
probably the best example that you could
probably give of
of acting it at will absolutely i think
that that's dangerous though is to read
hitler yeah
absolutely well there isn't there i
agree there's a caveat he says never
will something that is beyond your power
so you've got to be very honest about
your capacity to
manifest that will it isn't just simply
whim gee i want this or i'm going to go
over there and beat people up it's no i
will will this because i know that i can
do it and it will be manifested
i mean when you were saying earlier
about schopenhauer i mean the will is
world i mean everything in this room
everything in this room is the will of
somebody
it's just a frozen aspect of their will
from table design to books and it's the
will of a lot of different kinds of
people oh yes but
no not a one person no it's some
individual is saying i will this are the
electrons running around that table
conforming to your will i mean be
serious i am very serious
that the world is well that they they're
they're in that table but the the shape
of it it's why we're designing the table
is your perception
of
of them of the light beams coming from
the surface of that thing
but the person who conceived of that
table originally had a concept of table
and he exerted that will
somewhere to make sure that table became
manifest
you know that maybe it was somebody
forgotten and
but nevertheless somebody's will was
exerted there well let me raise another
consideration elsewhere nietzsche says
that living is willing
or that just to be alive is to will
but his definition of living was
different than
most definitions
he didn't consider a normal or a present
day let's say
man as being alive
you know one who's able to exercise his
will and be a true individual and
control exercises will to where he's a
he's the master of himself
that that person's alive
one who isn't is not alive the first
question i had was would does he imagine
that a uh
a plant is willing
no but he doesn't consider him alive and
it it but then what are they well i
don't know but i mean i can't think of
anything more persistent than plants or
nature yeah but but he's he's using
life in this regard as
as a
in an allegorical way i mean it's like
like saying you must be born again or
something well we're not actually born
again i mean physically we might be born
again emotionally and and spiritually
but so he's saying
that life
in in that context when he said uses the
word life he means
in i guess a life worthwhile is is life
a life that's not worthwhile
making between
living and existing yeah and in
the way i can do it is because we read
here under your tutelage
uh introduction to metaphysics by
heidegger
a few months ago
and heidegger traces
the word
being the english being back to
early greek or maybe sanskrit maybe i
had that wrong i'm not sure
as faisas
and
greek is that faith okay
uh and
there's a distinction to be made between
and and fisus
meant
living in the sense of becoming and
creating that's a man
existing
is another word which uh you
according to heidegger anyway and i'm
sure nietzsche is familiar with because
he was a greek scholar
and so the plant would be existing
the drudge who's a farmer you know just
planting and
he's existing you see the ubermensch now
he's in physicists he's living you see
so there's
that this distinction
i'd like to ask just a question to the
group where is love
in this ubermensch
this superman's existence or life
is does love play any part in this
at all
in any kind of love i mean are we to
even overcome love
well he says that
one of his more provocative passages
doesn't he say that women can't love
because
women can only love
i'll look for it ted while we're talking
about that that's what i think
um
actually love is the key part when you
look at nietzsche's uh
interest the worship of uh the god of
wine and dance celebration dionysus
that's what he was after it's a
celebration of life um
i was thinking that maybe
uh
this helps me illuminate at least the
first part the symbolism in the first
part of the book with
zarathustra in the mountains he's not
alone though he's with a serpent
and the eagle and what's
separating him from them
john paul sartre
wrote about this what
the real difference between man and
other creatures is his uh
awareness of
his own existence is mortality
and we that's what leads to our
stuckness because
we lose the essence we're more focused
on existing existing for its own sake
um
we have these beautiful animals the the
eagle and the serpent and
we understand them
in terms of their essence
and that's what makes them so beautiful
as
humankind we're
at least as john paul sartre would
describe it we're disconnected we're
alien to
we're aliens on this earth because we
feel very disconnected from nature
nietzsche seeds zarathustra right into
nature living in the mountains living
with the plants and
the creatures
um
to come down is his
moral responsibility to try to raise
everybody else so i guess that's how i
see the uh
what um the ubermensch is is actually
the essence becoming the essence
well two if if you look at
ubermensch
as an essence that's examining
love isn't something you examine it's
it's something that you manifest
as a result of who you are i mean
people don't examine why they're in love
you are either are you aren't
and it's not it's sort of like a silence
and a happiness it's not anything to be
examined in something that's known
and that's why i think he doesn't
specifically address it
but it's there
or not
for him yes i don't think it's something
he went up to the mountain to examine
but i think it's something that will
manifest itself in his behavior
as a result of his having accomplished
through silence and happiness the
ability to laugh and to have courage and
to be able to be who he is i think love
will manifest itself but it's certainly
not something that's to be defined and
examined
and preached what about this idea of
coming back down is that love
for mankind it's certainly it certainly
manifests itself
through what he can do and share with
other people as it did with that group
at the end i think he felt a level of
that for them and with them as they for
him
but it's not the issue that's not what
the book is about i think the book is
about the principle of how you go and
you examine and then you teach i don't
think it speaks so much to love in
particular it's only inferred that it
must follow if it's part of who you are
i apologize for interrupting no no
if i could just finish about
sartre and you brought this up about
nausea
well he's talking about when we're when
we
we are no longer of our essence but more
concerned about existence
only that that's how we feel going
through life you feel nauseous
and you
um
i thought maybe that's what white
household there's a sick man
headaches
lasting two days he can't eat spicy
foods
can't sleep
and he worships the god
the bakkai the dionysus and
he can't achieve it and maybe he looks
at other people
any type of
at least in in many cases the dance is a
pretense it's uh
it's a mockery and we have to get to the
go across that tightrope
become more in touch with back in touch
with the essence to be able to truly
dance and celebrate
in the spirit of
of dionysus
what would compels me to be to want to
become an uberment
what would compel somebody to want to
become an uberment
you mean somebody other than nietzsche
right like
or why does he like what
what
makes him want to live instead of exist
according to his definition if you don't
have a choice yeah the word the word
over men's is just a word he has for the
perfect man
in his
his notion but i think jesse's question
is
at what moment
do you say okay i'm too nauseated to
live this way anymore i'm going to live
that way look what what is that moment
what is that moment that's what it comes
to in someone's life if you mean
a real example even
well that's what he clearly says that's
why the whole purpose of the book is to
talk about being an individual that you
have to decide for yourself there isn't
an answer to that it's something that
has to come within your soul and heart
there's no guidelines but it is a it is
a legitimate question to say you know
what would prompt it like what what kind
of thing would happen well let's use him
as an example i think what prompted is
that his physical suffering was clearly
impacting negatively upon his ability to
work to write
and he knew that he had to overcome that
or he couldn't do what he really wanted
to do that made him happy which was to
work
so he took this on as a personal
personal thing for himself i think
that's all he's suggesting other people
do is consider that you have that option
you have that option to examine yourself
if you ever have an obstacle in your
life and you have the option to go
through what it takes through it takes
to get through it i think that's all
he's saying yeah i don't think you make
a decision to do that i it's like an
artist it's simply i have to do this and
but look at the suffering why would i
ever want to be an artist like you
don't
i mean you know i mean if it's if you're
driven to this yes but
by god i mean if you you don't make a
decision today i'll be picasso i mean
it's no picasso is because it because
picasso's picasso and that's the end of
it he will do what he has to do even if
it means
you're going to kill him
so be it i mean but i'm going to do my
art
he never described himself as an
overmensch i don't think
i mean over manchester was beyond
himself even
so i i think your idea that anybody can
be an obermensch if they if they examine
you know that
yeah i think there are a lot there are
15 different interpretations in here as
to what that means but but he himself uh
didn't claim to be an obermensch it was
that was that was something in the
future doesn't everybody in the room
have sympathy
for the sense that life uh should be
lived in a healthy way a
a
rejection of uh hiding behind morals and
things like that that you should open uh
yourself to uh to uh life and be uh big
and and and healthy and and uh strong
and and in that sense uh uh
everyone shares in this idea of being a
superman above uh the pettiness of uh of
the herd and so on so you don't think
sometimes examining your life
is a painful process
i mean and then why if you would see
somebody else going along like maybe
somebody we were talking about earlier
who
seems like they're given everything they
don't need to suffer so they don't have
that moment they don't have the natural
questioning
and you have envy for that and the
simplicity there and maybe they're not
the ubermensch but maybe they're happier
i mean is that not considered i mean
the whole idea of examining seems like
up and breaking the tablets let me
answer the question of course of course
you you might may suffer
but the fact of the matter is you
shouldn't be afraid of this
that that that that of course there are
dangers in the world but you shouldn't
be afraid of them you shouldn't withdraw
from the world to to uh
uh uh caress some um
humility or things like that you should
uh recognize these things are open of
this part of life and and uh it's it's
part of being um
a living and strong
and those are the things that are
celebrated by a superman by a uh this is
the antithesis of what that book's all
about by the way what you're saying
really show me
well he's saying just that that that's
the whole the whole thing is you do have
to go and examine what do you mean you
don't have to be afraid he's scared
jealous i mean through the whole process
he's nauseous he goes through it himself
you know he's not suggesting that you
should be brave i think the average
person well he's suggesting you come out
at all
i think the average person has no desire
to examine his life absolutely or
anything i i don't know maybe you live
in a very wonderful place but maybe i'm
jaded but the masses of people that i've
seen
no i i didn't say anything wrong i'm
simply sorry that's a judgment you just
judge
that they don't wish to exist maybe you
live in a perfect world where they do
and i don't i live in this world oh well
i was thinking i wasn't trying to judge
in a large sense but they go on so when
he refers to the rabble wouldn't people
who live day-to-day
struggling to like to find shelter and
food isn't that really living
or i mean that's like the two
things
you know
no i'm saying
no but to me absolutely what i'm saying
can that in some ways be more real than
you know
breaking tablets
well remember aristotle it says in a
very famous phrase once uh you don't
have to
worry about lions chasing you
and where you're gonna get food
and uh how you can get out of the
weather then maybe you can think about
philosophy
but not before that we're just lucky in
my day aristotle says that all our needs
are met and and we live in such a
comfortable way that i can think about
philosophy
why would you want to think about
philosophy you don't have food and the
question is right and the question is
can we can we become our fullest selves
if we have
not
uh
wade through the water and all you know
don't you sort of have to take care of
the
body a little bit and this nietzsche may
be saying are we too comfortable now now
is it is it way way too easy
not to think about philosophy all over
again because we are so very comfortable
we're halfway to philosophy we're
philistines
[Laughter]
with all the addictions
all the denials
that we live all the stuff we collect to
hide from ourselves
i think i think philosophy is so
um
i think it's i think people do seek
philosophic questions today if they
allow themselves but there are a lot of
distractions out there
computer games alcohol drugs stuff to
collect
the evils of the society
but i think she's talking about the
individuals
many individuals
yeah within the society
the toys
well that's the point though they do
have to choose it's easy not to have to
choose because you don't have to choose
there's there's enough distractions
that you don't need to go to
we consider ourselves so comfortable but
is this serving us you know
uh
could we choose philosophy perhaps be
more inwardly
together
and touch well sure but it's an
individual thing that's all it's not
it's not a societal
question i don't think we can't be we
can't choose the united states will be
the philosophical
self-examining society it doesn't
represent then you've got the plato's
republic
right and i don't want that
no pellets there
no poets in plato that's right
using today's
would anybody consider this to be a
self-help book
a question yeah sure
yes
no i don't think it is because self-help
gives you steps how to get there he
really doesn't
he really says you got to figure out
your own way to get there self-help
usually has you know this and then this
and then this i don't think it does he
make you want to figure it out after you
finish it yeah i think but it's not the
same as self-help if somebody was
confused about life or had certain
questions would would this be a good
book book to go to to get answers no no
it would just make you feel more upset
that you don't know where you're going
it won't make it it won't make it on the
oprah show
[Laughter]
i think it did it it does model
bringing up
repressions and the taboos that maybe
you're inhibited from
facing about
oneself so in that sense
he doesn't give you steps but he does
model yeah
i think we should go to the self-help
section and see how many of those books
start out by telling us that god is dead
forget all we have to create ourselves
right
the biblio books philosophy book group
has been meeting once a month for about
five years to discuss a work of
philosophy
thus spoke zarathustra the focus of
their discussion was written in four
parts by friedrich nietzsche between
1883 and 1885 it was published as a
whole book in 1892 the work is a set of
parables about a prophet who proclaims
the death of god
friedrich nietzsche passed away at the
turn of the century
next on book tv jennifer ratner
rosenhagen talks about the impact of
german philosopher frederick nietzsche
on both the left and right in the united
states
this is about an hour and 15 minutes
i'm so pleased to welcome my friend
jennifer ratner rosenhagen to the
newberry this evening jennifer is the
merle kerdi associate professor of
history at the university of
wisconsin-madison she earned her phd in
history at brandeis university and her
ba from the university of rochester
prior to landing in madison jennifer
taught at the university of miami in the
history department where we were
colleagues not so many years ago
jennifer's book american nietzsche a
history of an icon and his ideas was
just published by the university of
chicago press
in the book jennifer examines how
nietzsche's philosophy found a home in
america
nietzsche's writings about the death of
god and the challenge to universal truth
have inspired american thinkers
journalists academics philosophers
theologians poets and others have drawn
on nietzsche for inspiration we learn in
american nietzsche
american nietzsche already has been
reviewed widely and positively new york
times book review editor alexander starr
wrote
today's inescapable and perplexing
nietzsche is not necessarily the same
nietzsche who inspired readers in the
past and it's the achievement of
jennifer ratner rosenhagen's american
nietzsche to show how that is the case
stars correct to praise jennifer's
ability to help her readers think more
deeply and more historically about
nietzsche and american intellectuals
than we might have in the past it's one
of the great successes of her book
in a compelling prologue to american
nietzsche jennifer ratner rosenhagen
recounts nietzsche's fervent reading of
ralph waldo emerson beginning in the
1860s she writes it was emerson who
first instructed nietzsche about
philosophy and life
nietzsche was powerfully drawn to
emerson jennifer explains because he
understood what it meant to travel
imaginatively through time and space in
order to find a thinker to think with
i know a few individuals who travel
through time and space as imagined as
imaginatively or who are as compelling
thinkers to think with as jennifer
herself so we're all in for a real treat
this evening thinking with her please
join me in welcoming jennifer radner
rosenhagen to the newberry
[Applause]
thank you danny for that lovely
introduction
thank you newberry library and ac
mclaren bookstore for hosting tonight's
event and thank you all of course for
coming out tonight
all right
so it is very fitting that i find myself
in chicago talking about nietzsche
because it was in chicago in the early
90s during my gap years between
undergraduate and graduate school that i
began to read his philosophy i knew i
wanted to go on to do graduate work in
u.s intellectual history but like many
people interested in ideas i was
nevertheless drawn to european thinkers
karl marx max weber emile durkheim
sigmund freud and nietzsche most
especially nietzsche
after i moved on to graduate school i
continued to find nietzsche's thought
pretty intoxicating and i felt a little
sheepish about my attraction to it after
all i had gone to graduate school to
study american intellectual and cultural
history
and so i felt compelled to turn back to
my american thinkers ralph waldo emerson
margaret fuller w.e.b du bois john dewey
reinhold niebuhr
i thought it was time for me to find
myself back on american intellectual
native grounds
but in my effort to put nietzsche to the
side i came to discover how difficult
that was going to be in contemporary
american intellectual life
especially in the american academy
in higher education nietzsche's
philosophy figured prominently in
scholarly monographs journals and
university courses in all fields of the
humanities and the social sciences
there wasn't a university library
or major bookstore that didn't have a
nietzsche section
but even as i widened out from the
intellectual world of the academy i was
repeatedly foiled in my efforts to move
away from nietzsche and move back to my
america
even the most casual survey of american
culture at the time made it unmistakable
that this 19th century german
philosopher was a towering public
intellectual in contemporary american
life
he was everywhere images of his furrowed
brow and imposing mustache were on our
coffee cups and our t-shirts
his aphorisms were on our bumper
stickers and our tote bags his phrases
his concepts like will to power slave
and master morality ubermensch result
them all we're studying our morning
papers and our advertisements
nietzsche could be found in contemporary
novels from tom wolf to scott terreaux
as well as our
television shows and movies including
the simpsons conan the barbarian blazing
saddles a fish called wanda clueless and
i couldn't resist putting a few
recent uh shows on and that includes the
sopranos the day after tomorrow the
eternal sunshine of the spotless mind
and little miss sunshine
nietzsche even made it to off-broadway
in richard forman's 2000 bad boy
nietzsche along the way i would come to
discover that nietzsche had inspired
some food including ben hillman's niecha
pops
there is a nietzsche wilt about wilt a
power bar which is the official
nutritional supplement of the superman
and for those of you who are weak will
to powered like myself and eat too many
of them there's even a nichian diet
as advertised in the onion in the
mid-2000s new diet lets you eat whatever
you fear
most and we even have a plush 11 inch
nietzsche doll to snuggle with at night
so there was this quirky harmless figure
of our material culture but of course we
know there's also the menacing teenage
rambo nietzsche as well
right in the early years of the project
sixteen-year-old luke woodham of pearl
mississippi exemplified the figure of
the angry disaffected young man who
brandished a nietzsche text in one hand
and a gun or knife in the other and this
of course became
quite conventional as we moved
throughout the 1990s and into 2000 with
the 1999 columbine high school massacre
the 2001 brutal double homicide of a
husband and wife dartmouth college
professors in their home and more
recently the shooting of congresswoman
gabrielle giffords and 18 bystanders at
a meet and greet in an arizona parking
lot last january
trying to move back to american native
grounds move away from nietzsche going
to politics was a bad idea i discovered
very quickly that nietzsche is there too
in his address to the joint session of
congress on september 20th 2001 the
first major address that president
george bush gave after the 9 11 attacks
he
condemned the 9 11 terrorists for their
vicious will to power
but i came
to see that nietzsche was not simply a
figure of the right but he was also a
figure of the left or the center left
depending on your angle of vision of
course it was many years later that i
would learn in an october 2008 interview
that then candidate barack obama who was
asked by the new york times about his
philosophical and literary influences
would name friedrich nietzsche as one of
them he had come into contact with
nietzsche while a student an
undergraduate at accidental college
i could turn to popular music and again
nietzsche was there as an inspiration
from performers as diverse as gothic
rock singer marilyn manson and the folk
icon joni mitchell joni mitchell even
named her oscillate cat nietzsche and
dedicated her 1998 song man from mars to
him
mitchell explained in an interview what
nietzsche that is the philosopher
national the feline nietzsche meant to
her
quote nietzsche was a a hero
especially with the spoke zarathustra he
gets a bad rap he's very misunderstood
he's a maker of individuals and he was a
teacher of teachers end quote
and just in case you think that this was
some curious fluke
on your ride home tonight turn on the
radio to a top 40 station and you will
very likely hear kelly clarkson's a hit
song
stronger which the lyrics for stronger
are nietzsche's maxim what doesn't kill
me makes me stronger
and i won't sing it for you um and if
kind of light rock is not your fair you
prefer rap then you can listen for kanye
west 2007 hit version also stronger also
using nietzsche's maxim
so so let's back up a bit what was
already clear from the outset of the
project was that nietzsche had the
dominating presence in 20th century
american intellectual and cultural life
and yet it was pretty easy for me at the
time to assume that this fascination
must have been of a relatively recent
vintage
to track it i thought we maybe we could
do that look at the psychic and moral
dislocations of americans trying to come
to terms with the horrors of the
holocaust and the atomic bomb and the
post-world war
i thought maybe it's even more recent
than that maybe i can trace it to the
temper of the 60s when americans coming
of age struggled with the bankrupt
ideologies of the cold war world and
bristled against the lingering bourgeois
conventions and come stuckery of their
parents
and yet in my effort to reclaim my mind
for more german pardon me more american
thinkers
i was
foiled yet again as i thought let me
just move back in time and surely this
will go away
in fact it didn't take long or much
effort before i started to take note of
the curious nietzschean traces in
american thought from earlier periods
indeed in the very text i was reading
while trying to get back to my american
native grounds
william james's variety of religious
experience
ruth benedict's patterns of culture
richard hofstetter's paranoid style of
american politics martin luther king
jr's autobiography and david riesman's
lonely crowd all of them had engagements
with nietzsche in them
anita under every bed
not quite
although there are a lot of niches under
lots of beds but in this effort to move
back in time i was able to start to
connect the dots and see how much
nietzsche was cropping up in fact i was
able to connect the dots all the way
back to the turn of the last century
when the interest in nietzsche was so
intense that observers could without
hyperbole talk about a nietzsche vogue
this was the term used uh in the
beginning of the 20th century and as one
commentator put it and he was right
quote he who will know the zeitgeist
must know nietzsche
and yet at every new discovery i could
not help but ask the same question that
the nietzsche commentators i was reading
were asking themselves and that is
why
what's the work of an anti-christian
anti-democratic anti-enlightenment
thinker doing in a culture like
ours
in asking these questions my project was
born
why nietzsche and why in america
so in the time that remains what i'd
like to do is to try to offer some
answers to these questions about what
nietzsche's philosophy has been doing in
and has done for 20th century thought
and culture in the united states
my book examines nietzsche's
long-standing impact on 20th century
american thought and culture
it examines how nietzsche's denial of
universal truth together with his
sustained critiques of christian
morality enlightenment rationality and
democracy have compelled generations of
americans to question their religious
ideals their moral certainties and their
democratic principles
i trace out episodes in the history
including and i'm just going to name a
few the early 20th century christian
commentators use of nietzsche's
philosophy as a register of the soul of
modern man under secularism
i look at early 20th century literary
and political thinkers who turn to
nietzsche's nomadic intellectual life as
an example of the perils and the
promises of the freelance intellectual
life that they hope to inhabit
themselves
i look at the debates about the
nietzschean roots of imperialism during
the first world war and totalitarianism
during the second world war um i think
can think of no other philosopher who
has been blamed for the two world wars
but in fact that's nietzsche was blamed
for both world war one and world war ii
and i looked more recently at
developments in the american academy in
popular culture when nietzsche was
transformed into the father or if you
will the grandfather of post-modernism
many of the names of the commentators
that i discuss in the book are will be
familiar to you
their names like h.l menken jack london
emma goldman walter littmann george
santayana josiah royce khalil gibran
william jennings bryan clarence darrow
thomas man hannah arendt lionel trilling
huey p newton judith butler cornell west
and harold bloom
while some were enlivened
by his writings and others were
mortified by his writings none were
indifferent to the implication of his
philosophy for the promise of american
life
and yet today however i want to look at
different a different kind of reader i
want to look at a very different kind of
source and namely i'm going to look at
the fan letters that were written by
nietzsche's american readers and sent to
the nietzsche archive in weimar germany
i do so not only because they give us
access to the intellectual world of
quote unquote average americans of often
lost or at least overlooked by
intellectual historians
but because they signal how and why
nietzsche's philosophy and his image of
the suffering martyred mad genius became
so instrumental in american intellectual
life
we see how americans pressed nietzsche
into service using him to criticize the
shortcomings of american democracy the
moral timidity of their priest
and the hollow promises of enchantment
by a secular pop culture
the value of these letters as historical
documents as historical sources
it seems to me
is not
their philosophical value that is to say
how good they are at doing full exegesis
on nietzsche
one can surely read them for their
philosophical merits and shortcomings
but what i think is important is to
listen for their historical value
and i think that has nothing to do with
whether they get nietzsche right or
wrong
those kinds of judgments matter but
they're judgments for another day and i
think probably another book
but not for the historian who is
interested in using these letters to
listen in as it were to people from the
past
to listen in to people's moral reasoning
to listen in to people's longings their
pathologies and their fears
so that's what i i do with these letters
is to
listen uh to how people are making using
nature to make sense of their moral
worlds not to adjudicate who's getting
them right and who's getting them wrong
and the beauty i think of doing that is
that we begin to understand how and why
nietzsche goes from being an obscure
thinker in the 19th century in 19th
century german germany to a pop icon in
american intellectual life
if book sales are a measure of literary
achievement
friedrich vilhelmicha in 1881 was a
positive failure
his first work the birth of tragedy of
1872 caused quite a stir among a small
circle of wagnarians and philologists
but failed to catch the attention of the
broader literary press and reading
public
and yet this was the best-selling book
during his lifetime after that it was
pretty much downhill
the next year his essay david strauss
the confessor and the writer of 1873
the first of nietzsche's untimely
meditations received some initial
attention but then also quickly faded
from view
the works that followed human all too
human of 1878 daybreak of 1881 went
virtually unnoticed
and nietzsche never
tired of contemplating the travails of
the untimely genius in a letter to a
friend in august 1881 he bristled about
an indifferent reading public who let
him starve on silence as he wrote quote
if i were unable to draw strength for
myself if i had to wait for applause
encouragement consolation where would i
be what would i be
there were certainly moments and whole
periods in my life when a robust word of
encouragement a hand clasp of agreement
would have been the refreshment of
refreshments and it was just then that
everybody left me in the lurch end quote
but a few months later as the protracted
neglect exacerbated nietzsche's
frustration out of the blue three
admirers from baltimore maryland sent
him an epistolary lifeline
i realized it's not very easy to see but
it's a very old letter it's from 1881
and these things don't reproduce well
but this is alisa finka's letter of 1881
and let me read you what you can't read
for yourself in translation esteemed
hair doctor perhaps it is a little
concern to you that here in america
three people often sit together and
allow nietzsche's writings to edify them
at their most intimate
but i don't see why we shouldn't at
least tell you so once we are counting
on the fact that due to the depth of
your thoughts and your sublime diction
we will never be able or one to ever
read anything else again
we need not merely imagine how pleased
nietzsche was to get this letter for
preserved on the back side of the letter
in uh
written on the backside of the lev
letter that is now preserved in the
nietzsche archive is his handwritten
note to self
airsteer americana should brief and it's
gloria
the first american letter
introduction to world glory would be
literal a better translation would be
the beginning of world fame so first
american letter the beginning of world
fame
finally it seemed the world was awaking
to his genius
during the next few months however
silence settled back in nevertheless
nietzsche enjoyed a stretch of exuberant
productivity in which he wrote his next
work the gay science it was also during
this period that he was rereading one of
his favorite philosophers ralph waldo
emerson and thanks to his renewed
inspiration used emerson an emerson
quotation for the book's epigraph
how fitting then that while writing his
philosophical love letter to his
american hero that a second letter
should arrive from the states indeed
from the very native grounds of the sage
of concord
and a letter from boston dated may 29
1882 a professional violinist by the
name of gustav don reuter wrote to
nietzsche to express as he put it quote
my most humble thanks for the benefit i
have derived from your works and the
wish which i have long entertained to
possess a likeness be it ever so small
of the man i have learned to adore for
the greatness of his mind and the
sincerity of his utterances now bear in
mind that was a translation from a
german sentence and germans are allowed
to write much longer sentences than we
are so uh this was this was actually
quite an elegant sentence in the
original so dan moyeter uses this letter
also as an occasion to tell nietzsche
that he had a such admiration for an
essay that he had written on
schopenhauer in his untimely meditations
that dan reuter had
as he put it translated a quote no less
than three times not so much with a view
to publishing my feeble reproduction as
to that of becoming more intimate with
your work but in spite of my efforts my
version fell so far short of an adequate
rendition of the original that i was
only too glad for the sake of your
reputation to keep the manuscript in my
desk
since then i've quite destroyed it but
the memory of exalted moments remains
and i am sure that my work was at least
not wasted upon myself
we have no record of nietzsche's
response
but one suspects that he might have
figured that though the cultural
philistines of germany were unwilling or
unable to recognize his genius perhaps
the america that had produced his
beloved emerson might also have created
a people with ears to hear his untimely
message
two letters from america weren't much
but given the paltry response to his
writings back at home this surely seemed
like an auspicious beginning
perhaps the dawn of nietzsche's world
fame was breaking in the west
except unfortunately
that it wasn't these are the only two of
the three extant fan letters written
directly to nietzsche prior to his
mental collapse in 1889.
during the 1890s a handful of letters
from american nietzsche enthusiasts
trickled in first to naumborg where the
invalid philosopher stayed in the care
of his mother and his sister elizabeth
forrester nietzsche and then later to
weimar where he spent the last three
years of his life in a room atop the
nietzsche archive
which was now administered by elizabeth
who was now his self-appointed literary
executor and she administered it up
until her death until 1935.
by the time these fan letters arrived
however nietzsche was totally unaware of
them
his days of intellectual ecstasy and
agony were over but so too was his
ability to read write or even recollect
that he was once an avid reader and
prolific writer
on their own these two letters from
american fans cannot tell us much
but when we read them together with the
letters that started arriving at the
nietzsche archive in the immediate years
following nietzsche's death in 1900 we
can see that they are indeed a foretaste
of the feast to come
the confessions of esteem for and
adoration of nietzsche and finka and dan
reuter are repeated innumerable times in
the letters written by subsequent
admirers fans young and old male and
female pious and agnostic left and right
immigrant and native born wrote to
express their devotion to the thinker
who had changed the way they thought
about themselves in their moral worlds
they wrote for a picture they wrote for
an autograph they wrote sometimes simply
to say thank you and sometimes they
wrote to offer their assistance in
spreading the nietzschean gospel in
america
these letters might appropriately be
classified as american nietzsche
ephemera
for they offer really just a snapshot in
time and some of them are no longer than
a paragraph sometimes too
in most cases beyond having their names
listed in census records or crop up in
tiny obituaries there's really little to
nothing left in the public reference
record giving evidence of the fullness
of these letter writers lives or the
extent to which they incorporated
nietzsche's ideas into their daily
conduct
nevertheless in all of their imperfect
fleeting brevity these letters offer
insights into how nietzsche's ideas not
only traveled in the world but also how
they helped make americans moral worlds
anew and they show how and why the kind
of culture that nietzsche took as his
enemy would come to welcome him as one
of its most vital thinkers
the fan letter suggests to me as an
intellectual historian that sometimes in
order to behold a large picture format
of american intellectual life we have to
start small
given nietzsche's increased presence in
american intellectual and cultural life
commentators
many commentators echoed the sentiment
as one observer in 1910 put it that he
was quote in the air
they wrote about nietzsche as if he were
a transcendent spirit
however the letters also remind us that
nietzsche's thought was no mere vapor
rather they demonstrate the material
dimension of ideas
because for many they experienced their
initial contact with nietzsche's
philosophy as so transformative that
they recorded in these letters the form
in which they first encountered him
either as a photograph and a magazine a
name and a newspaper review or an author
for sale at their local bookshop
the letters testify to the ways in which
the embodied forms of ideas that matter
to people take on a psychic value much
greater than their monetary one
letter writers thus commonly referred to
their nietzsche copies
pardon me to their copies of nietzsche's
books as quote unquote prize possessions
they shared with elizabeth forester
nietzsche which books they owned which
ones they borrowed from a friend or
relative and which ones they hoped to
procure
many of nietzsche's american admirers
wrote to forester nietzsche in the hope
of gaining possession of some tiny
precious relic some little piece of the
man who for them
was the lived example of his heroic
ubermensch
one of the most common requests was for
nietzsche's signature
in big bubble cursive strokes the 12
year old john bougier jr of stratford
pennsylvania wrote in 1926 quote my
mother loves your brother's writings and
i'm going to read them when i grow up
but i read all about friedrich nietzsche
in a book that has just been published
by the name of
the story of philosophy by will durant
and i loved it end quote
we can imagine that budger wanted to
send nietzsche's autograph to pardon me
wanted to share nietzsche's autograph
with his mom or impress his school
boyfriends with it but he reasoned the
request with a simple unadorned
admission that he would quote just love
to have it
quote if you have one i could have i
would be so happy end quote
so this is just one of many letters
requesting
uh
autographs
the request for nietzsche paraphernalia
that is nietzsche pictures a lock of his
hair
a brush look so like just a little piece
of some writing that got broken off
these requests for nature paraphernalia
shed light on the broader context of the
longing and desire he awakened in as
american readers
in a letter from 1923 christoph hoffman
of mount vernon new york wrote to
forrester nietzsche for information
about where he could find quote a good
picture of your great brother and quote
he informed uh
pardon me he explained the earnestness
of his request in a lengthy narrative
demonstrating his devotion to nietzsche
two years earlier quote as a serious
student of the gay science of
zarathustra i drew a small circle of
healthy disciples around me we hold in
my library lectures on a small scale on
the philosophy of your unique eternal
hair brother end quote
in order to fully realize the experience
he and his fellow disciples quote mowed
through innumerable fine art galleries
end quote on a quote on a quest to find
the perfect picture of nietzsche quote
so that we can decorate our reading room
with such a holy relic but to no avail
hoffman sought to reassure her that this
request was not made lightly he added
that on behalf of his friends he also
wanted to express their gratitude for
her devotion to their suffering saint
and he wrote
please allow me here honorable madam to
mention that we venerate your honorable
person as true holiness we are fully
aware that without you your untiring
help the life of your brother would have
been a much more suffering one
and so as a token of his gratitude
hoffman did what is was not uncommon for
the letter writers to do which was not
simply to ask for something but to send
something
and so he sent inspiration a walk a poem
that he had penned in uh in uh
the flesh of his inspiration of
nietzsche and so again we see this in
some of the other letters
people put in photos of their houses
they sent their christmas cards
is the mic
on i had a funny feeling that it was off
just keep going can you hear me
okay
all right um
so if american nietzsche devotees wanted
to possess a relic of him it is because
he possessed them
they did not simply ask for valuable
goods to adorn their lives they
explained how the philosopher they
adored had taught them something
precious about the good life virtually
all letter writers confessed heather
encounter with nietzsche's philosophy
either emboldened them or chastened them
liberated them from old falsehoods or
settled them with new moral
responsibilities
helene back miller of dayton ohio wrote
in 1922 to let forester nietzsche know
that her brother had inspired the belief
that human greatness was still possible
in the modern world
though unworthy of his greatness he
nevertheless awakened and hurt her a
longing for something deeper in herself
nietzsche backmiller confessed had saved
her from quote her own inner emptiness
the ohio country she called home had
become quote tame and commonplace filled
with lives trivial and essentially ugly
for they are engrossed with matters of
money and motors not with work or faith
or art and quote
she regarded the methodist church near
her house as quote vulgar and
pretentious and quote
though disgusted by the offensive
mediocrity around her she was also
chagrined by her own limitations quote
it would be probably impossible for you
to imagine anything more superficial
than i am and quote but reading what we
can presume was forster nietzsche's
translation of the nietzsche richard
wagner correspondents nietzsche had a
relationship with wagner before he
didn't
before it ended explosively
and forester nietzsche documented their
letter exchanges and this was translated
about this year so i'm assuming this is
the book she's referring to
bachmulla writes reading this exposed
her to quote depths beyond depths of one
great soul striking fire against another
great soul end quote
reading about nietzsche strengthened her
resolve that quote all my life i will
hold on to my hunger if i never manage
to have a soul at any rate i will remain
by hook or crook aware of it and i will
desire one all my life
i will not accept substitutes
in bachmuller we see an example of how a
reader used nietzsche's philosophy to
explain herself to herself
nietzsche had given her justification
for and a language to articulate her
feelings of displacement and
disaffection in a world that seemed
content with ugly compromises
nietzsche's philosophy gained traction
in readers yearning for individuality as
well as belonging
in their desire for self-understanding
they fashioned their own version of
anita as exemplar of individuality and a
new self in that image
you um
i'm pretty sure
gonna have a hard time reading the
letterhead but the letterhead is from
one george e nitcha
of philadelphia pennsylvania
though george initia of pennsylvania did
not express back miller's sense of a
debate surroundings his letter similarly
shows a self-longing for exaltation and
connection
it was quite literally nietzsche to whom
he sought to cleave himself quote my
name as you will see from the above
letterhead is one of the few niches in
america probably the only one
unfortunately my grandparents in a legal
document left the e out and the error
was perpetuated
however i am proud of the name and that
probably my ancestors came from the same
stock as your illustrious as you and
your illustrious brother end quote
so in an effort to sketch out the
possible trunk of their mutual family
tree mitchell went on to tell the woman
he hoped was his not too distant cousin
about the moravian and bohemian roots of
their people and how his branch of the
nicha or nietzsche family emigrated to
pennsylvania in 1739
centuries and an open ocean separated
them he hoped quote to possess a
specimen of nietzsche's handwritings and
his autograph and also a copy of your
own biography of your illustrious
brother with an autographed inscription
in your handwriting and quote just a few
mementos of the thinker whom he hoped
was in his blood
this desire to possess a piece of
nietzsche as he had possessed his
readers reveals
that the strong affinity for nietzsche's
life and thought and it shows that it
takes many forms in these letters
john i bush of duluth minnesota for
example believed that he was nietzsche's
philosophy realized
on december 9th 1919 he sent the first
of three missives to forester nietzsche
announcing his good tidings he wrote
dear madam i beg to inform you that i am
here one who is evil enough and then he
refers her to the passage in this book
zarathustra where nietzsche has one who
is evil enough
he says written uh
uh chapter old and new tables aphorism
seven by friedrich milham nietzsche your
beloved deceased brother just in case
she hadn't read it uh herself may you
hereby have the consolation and delight
to have lived long enough to know that
the visions prophecies and hopes of your
brother have been fulfilled to the very
letter
for the author of the scribbling is the
very man prognosticated in the said
volume very respectfully john i bush and
then he has a bunch of uh
phrases from zarathustra a strange
figure from the north a man without
disgust one who is evil enough
when a week went by without hearing
jubilation back from the archive bush
followed up with a telegram and this is
it's a little off so i'm assuming that
it's transcribed by a non-english
speaker on the receiving and in german
germany and the telegram reads quote are
your yet or your living yet one who is
evil enough john bush
so inconceivable was it that forester
nietzsche might be ignoring his
extraordinary revelation bush seemed to
think that the only reason for her
silence could be that she was dead
why else wouldn't she respond to the
american ubermensch and so he sent an
aggrieved third attempt at contact in
january 26 1920 in which he could barely
contain his exasperation and it reads
quote dear gentlemen i the undersigned
do beg humble to inquire does the
elizabeth forrester nietzsche the sister
of the late friedrich w nietzsche live
yet
i would greatly appreciate it if someone
connected with the nietzsche archive
will kindly answer the above query just
one word will suffice please comply with
a small request and oblige
enclose please find self-addressed
envelope for reply it is as it is
inconvenient to remit postage i
neglected that part of my obligation but
hope that you will incur in that trifle
expense
any signs again thanking you in advance
i remain very respectfully john i bush
though bush's felt connection to
nietzsche's ubermensch was certainly
less abashed than most others the ways
in which he put nietzsche's philosophy
to work for self-fashioning was a common
strategy a strategy we see in all of
these letter writers they use
nietzsche's terms and aspects of his own
life to describe themselves to
themselves
one of the reasons why
so many readers sought to fashion
themselves in his language or after his
image was
as because as dr helmut marks of
rochester minnesota expressed it
nietzsche was quote more of a great
spirit than a human being end quote
and so what we see in a lot of these
letters is a very strong unmistakable
religious imagery
that demonstrates this felt spiritual
dimension of the american nietzsche
devotion
after the death of god
these writers still long to cleave
themselves to images of grandeur to
divinity but this time in the form of
human possibility
nietzsche was that image of human
possibility for them
and so what we see in some of the
letters and again it's not just in the
letters as i talk about in the book i
see this across the board even in the
highest of highbrow serious intellectual
philosophical works on nietzsche is this
transformation of nietzsche into a kind
of
secular savior
certainly a language that is shot
through with
religious
or spiritual words
we see this as people talked about the
nietzsche archive they talked about it
in terms of a pilgrimage making a
pilgrimage to the neutral archive or as
one letter writer put it the holiest of
holy places and that's a quote
so american reader's fascination with
nietzsche took many forms but a common
way of expressing that devotion was to
travel to the nietzsche archive to meet
his sister and to see his room in his
personal library some of the letter
writers refer to actual visits to the
archive while others refer to trips in
the planning stages and travel plans
aborted and delayed
expeditions both realized and not
provide a fuller view of the modes of
the american nature exchange
they remind us that when ideas move
readers
they do so both in mind and in body
nietzsche's american readers went to a
bookstore they went to a library they
went to a shrine in their friend's house
a nietzsche shrine in their friend's
house and some
not a lot but some
at least from these records made a
transatlantic voyage to germany to
weimar
the discussion discussions of travels to
the archives suggest that there's a
two-way aspect to this story of the
atlantic crossings of nietzsche not only
did nietzsche's texts travel to america
with his ideas but americans likewise
travel to germany for them
what's significant here is that the
niche admirers who long to see the
archive for themselves as i said cast
this in a language of religious devotion
we see this quite beautifully in elmer
schreiner's 1920 letters uh referring to
a trip
that he took not only to the archive but
also to reckon which was nietzsche's
birthplace where he went to see
nietzsche's birth house quote the room
which your dear brother was born your
father study the old kitchen
the tr trip proved so transformative
pardon me that he informed forester
nietzsche in a letter that it inspired
his next book project quote a
nietzschean pilgrimage it is a tribute
to nietzsche for nichians end quote
the transatlantic travels of nietzsche
texts and american nietzsche devotees
documented in the letters demonstrate
that the transnational traffic of ideas
flows in both directions
it shows how nietzsche's ideas and ideas
about nietzsche traversed national
borders thought to distinguish american
from german or european intellectual
life and i think in doing so it
encourages us to rethink the integrity
of our national narratives regarding
thought and culture in other words the
very national narrative that i was
struggling with initially as i thought
if i want to study american intellectual
history you got to stick with americans
or thinking that there's somehow a
distinct tradition here that is cut off
from
the wider circulation of ideas in the
world
the letters alone suggest that because a
german thinker proved so inspirational
to many american readers
that the periodic zeal in american life
to celebrate american exceptionalism
though sometimes admirable often sets up
a false intellectual distinction between
american world views and the wider views
in the world
the letters those small and fragmentary
help us to consider the ways in which
moral outlooks and social concerns in
america have been forged
through cross-cultural
transatlantic
wider world system of exchange
transmission modification and
transformation
in doing so these letters help us to
think or rethink some of the static
categories that we work with like
american exceptionalism or foreign
thought or we can talk about organic
ideas or truly american ideas or we poo
poo radical imports
but before we too zealously embrace the
artificial artificiality of constructs
like american or german foreign and
organic we should not forget the power
that such perceived differences had in
shaping of the lived experience of
people we study in the past and of
course we see it still today
as these letter writers show many
readers ideas about what's us and what's
them were sharpened not smoothed out in
the friction of this movement
the letters in their own small way tell
a bigger story about how the
transnational traffic of nietzsche's
image and ideas helped puncture and
rebuild traverse and reconstitute
intellectual borders between america and
europe
and so though we might be tempted to
view the vibrancy of nietzsche's
posthumous american career as a sign of
long-standing salutary national uh
transnational intellectual exchanges and
mutuality
many of american
readers here saw just the opposite
they turned to nietzsche not because
they thought he could make something
possible for the pedestrian-american
intellect but
precisely because in their view he
couldn't
the prospect that nietzsche's philosophy
could shrink the distance between german
and american culture was the last thing
on many of these american
writers minds
though they were reading nietzsche in
america they never thought nor desired
that his philosophy could find refuge
here they simply wanted more of
nietzsche more of the german pathos of
distance more of his philosophy with
which to shield themselves from the
crude anti-intellectual mob mentality of
american life
and so here we're seeing a very common
concern that we can see at the much
higher registers of american
intellectual discourse you know among
professional intellectuals that america
is anti-intellectual
and there's plenty of
we've got plenty of documentation there
but what's interesting is that the
letter showed that this was a concern in
the lower registers of american culture
as well
what we can hear in these letters also
is a gnawing concern about american
anti-intellectualism
what we hear is a worry that america
does commerce but it doesn't do culture
we can make
uh or build mcdonald's and make
dungarees and we don't even do that
anymore but we don't do ideas we don't
produce ideas
and so here we see in the letters this
fear of american anti-intellectualism
were burrowed deeply into the
imagination of general readers this
notion that nietzsche was a genius and
we could have never produced a nietzsche
here
that our cultural soil just is too thin
to produce this kind of genius
and so these letters document that the
longing for intellectual engagement the
reverence for ideas even if as a stick
to beat corporate capitalism or mass
culture with was not exclusive to
professional intellectuals
average americans long to inhabit the
world of thought that nietzsche created
and embodied
and so
the letters
and this was just a sampling of the
letters that i talk about in the book
but i think they start to signal some of
the ways in which american readers
enlisted nietzsche's image and ideas to
contemplate contemplate themselves and
to critique their america and i'd like
to end now with one that i think does a
nice job of pulling together many of the
light motifs of american nature devotion
the two-page type letter from the san
francisco-based td crittend
and
criton is a pseudonym for a
greek name that i won't say because i
can't pronounce it um
but
the pseudonym is kritan is
uh german for plato's
uh plato's krito so this is a a
pseudonym that he's taking from
plato and we see already in the
pseudonym self-fashioning going on
in this letter critten exalts a
prophetic nietzsche as a timeless savior
of modern humanity and a timely critic
of a world out of kilter
crittenden began by telling forrester
nietzsche quote the life of your brother
was the life of a christ's pure and
great no man suffered what he did on
account of his convictions not even
jesus christ end quote
critin informed forester nietzsche that
he a greek american who had emigrated to
the us as a child believed that
nietzsche and the german people from
which he came were like him the true
descendants of the hellenic spirit
he flashed back to 1914 when quote thus
bug zarathustra came to me like a
thunderbolt of zeus from olympus end
quote when america entered the unjust
war on germany end quote in 1917 he
opted for incarceration rather than to
bear arms against these quote true
greeks
unquote he was disgusted with american
literature which produced only junk
writers none worthy of her brother
and then in his letter he moved from his
critiqued of a botched american culture
to contrast it with his esteem for
germany and italy quote i only hope that
america might someday produce writers
worthy of nietzsche then america will be
in a place to show her savior as italy
and germany and quote
that these lines were written in 1933
can only suggest that hitler's rise to
power confirmed his view
of the un unfortunate incongruity
between
german greatness and american poverty
he concluded by thanking her brother for
having graced world history with his
timeless and timely philosophy of life
so crittenden's letter is packed with
many of the major themes running through
virtually all of the american fan
letters sent to the nietzsche archive
it reveals how general readers young and
old male and female from pittsburgh to
san francisco made and remade nietzsche
in their own image scholars writers and
general readers like critten all lent a
hand in putting their nietzsche whether
the personalist companion the secular
saint or the cultural critic to work on
themselves and their america and in
doing so they naturalized nietzsche as
an american or as one of us
for critic in particular nietzsche as a
hellenic christ not a hebraic one helped
him fill in the contours of his own
greek american identity helped him to
articulated why he felt such a distance
from american culture and helped him
hammer out his own political ideas
his use of nietzsche shows how his ideas
move through time and space
and every time nietzsche's ideas did so
they were reconstituted when they got in
the hands of an american reader
critten as did the others consider
nietzsche's books among his prized
possessions
by writing to procure additional works a
photograph a swatch of his handwriting
nietzsche's american readers saw
tangible records of the authors who
ideas had demonstrated practical power
in their lives
the only reason why they wanted to
possess some nichiana however was
because nietzsche had possessed them
crittenden's letter like the letters
written before his offer a preview of
the varieties of american engagements
with nietzsche for this for decades to
come
the letter puts an ink on paper what
many in the decades to come would put in
their blood and on their bodies
for crittend to get closer to nietzsche
he wrote a confessional letter
for the 21 year old jack kerouac 11
years later he wrote a nietzschean
quotation in his blood
he did so in 1944 of in an early period
of artistic searching and self-creation
kerouac had borrowed alan ginsberg's
library card to check out volumes of
nietzsche and in those texts he found a
vision of the transformative power of
art that he was trying to achieve in his
own life and his work
as if to ensure that nietzsche would
stay with him after he returned the
books to the library kerouac cut his
finger and with his blood wrote the
following words from the birth of
tragedy
quote art is the highest task and the
proper metaphysical activity of this
life
end quote
over a half century later that desire to
bring nietzsche onto and into oneself
can be seen in the nietzsche tattoos on
the bodies of 20 somethingers and and
upwards
like the actress megan fox who has on a
ribcage a quotation from zarathustra
and like
derek gottlieb
the indexer of my book
who incidentally is also an advanced
graduate student in educational theory
and comparative literature who at our
first meeting to go over the manuscript
and talk about the index showed me why
it was kismet that he should have should
be the indexer of my book
by pulling up his shirt and showing me
his nietzsche tattoo
that reads assist emmer
et vas vans in indirect this is
in and that is there is always some
madness and love but there is always
some reason and madness
how fitting that this quotation is
pulled from a section called reading and
writing in this book zerathustra where
nietzsche writes quote of all that is
written i love only what a person has
written in his blood
he write he that writes in blood does
not want to be read but learn by heart
end quote
and those in turn who wanted to learn
nietzsche by heart
they did so by bringing them in their
blood
example like derek's rib cage and carol
wax finger simply make literal what has
been figural in american history or 20th
century american history and that is
that nietzsche has been inscribed on the
american body
that nietzsche is in our blood
that nietzsche is as alan bloom put it
though we did so mournfully that
nietzsche is us
are the risks involved in making
critten's two-page epistle or derek's
tattoo carry more interpretive weight
than they can bear
can a tank
type a written
cranky letter or a tattoo really tell us
anything broader
a broader significance for understanding
nietzsche's importance for 20th century
american thought and culture
my belief is that they do precisely
because they speak to the ways in which
an astonishing range of readers
participated in a much wider circuit of
intellectual exchange than we normally
appreciate
in addition they show how nietzsche
worked by making the designation average
in average american no longer makes
sense to his readers as a term of
self-description
even for those who came to nietzsche
with a sense of inadequacy he provided
them a language to critique the church
the marketplace or their civics lesson
that help them to sharpen their sense of
distinction in themselves
enabling them to feel their own
particularity
the letters reflect a broader sentiment
that is also echoed in the published
sources
namely that nietzsche was a philosopher
prophet who worked not by issuing
instructions for conduct but by serving
as a guide to becoming
if they were unable to anchor their
beliefs in timeless universals they
could at least cleave themselves to a
thinker who had learned to live without
them
thank you
[Applause]
so i will leave up
the tattoos
um and i'm happy to take some questions
right now and i've just been asked
though that if you
want to pose a question to please wait
until the mic
uh comes to you
so that you can ask the question in the
mic
a lot of the um at least the letters you
selected
seem to be either in german or from
people talking about german solidarity
or
um with german names i wonder how much
of
nietzsche's at least early popularity
was a matter of ethnic solidarity and
mid-century immigrants who were longing
for a connection to the whole country
that's a wonderful question
a disproportionate number of the letters
are written by people with german names
um
and the letters and some some of them
are written in german some of them are
written in english where the letter
writer regrets that he or she can't
write in her his or her mother tongue
that this is that this is a source of
you know great consternation
um and so i think it is very conceivable
that nietzsche
really resonated with
uh german readers but as we look out to
the wider published sources it just
doesn't tell us anything it doesn't seem
representative um and first of all at
the turn of the last century most
educated americans i mean german was a
standard second language for educated
americans uh so you didn't have to be
ethnically uh german uh and and also the
first translations were already
available in 1896 so people could
already start reading it in translation
so it seems to me that the answer to
your question is sort of both yes and no
my sense is that for german
ethnic germans they there was that sense
of affiliation or bond i mean you see it
in someone like a niche but you see also
that longing to connect to nietzsche to
feel that nietzsche was a sibling soul
also extends to people who are not
ethnically ethnically german
i make one more point on that and that
is that nietzsche in the early years of
his uh posthumous fame as it were in
america was seen as a polish
was as polish ethnically polish and not
german nietzsche described himself as
the the descendant of polish aristocrats
and partly this was a way for him to
criticize uh germany and so this is
picked up and actually becomes a big
subject of conversation
and debate um
and i think it's very interesting so
nietzsche is polish in american
intellectual life
until
world war one
and it's at that point that nietzsche
began comes seen as
the monster or the inspiration of the
german mind so nietzsche becomes german
but he starts out
polish and i think
this is
often said to criticize nietzsche if he
were german we'd get him better right i
mean
our universities are modeled after the
german university we all are are reading
the great german thinker so this
wouldn't have made him exotic enough
making him polish made him made him
exotic
thank you for a wonderful presentation
and i can't wait to read the book
um as someone who's read some niche and
teach some of it here in the newberry
um one of nature's main themes is the
need for
self-criticism
and
an animus against
um
true believers and
ideologies and the seeking of disciples
one of his famous themes of zarathustra
is
where zarathustra
he tells him to go away
because you hadn't sought yourself first
and you found me yeah go see yourself
yeah
do you see much of an awareness of
that need and that theme in nature
coming out of
these american responses
or is it more along the lines of
looking for a new savior mm-hmm
that's a good question because i would
see that is where we see a split between
what's
you know the interpretations
and the letters and what we can see and
why more widely published sources so no
in the that the letter i mean the degree
that kind of self-criticism that we see
maybe someone like helene backmiller
comes as close this sense of inadequacy
but that's not quite what you're talking
about but for certain in the broader
reception many thinkers pick up on this
um
that to be a nietzschean you can't be a
nietzschean
um
so i mean already
james gibbons hunnicure who was a
one of the early in fact he's credited
for making nietzsche bringing
nietzsche's fame to america in the late
19th century early 20th century was an
early inspiration on h.l menken um he
said the only nietzschean that died
nietzsche was the only nietzschean that
died on pardon me the only
nietzschean died when nietzsche died uh
so you can't you can't
he he recognized how how ridiculous this
was and in fact he was very critical
that you know should nietzsche ever get
a
uh reception here in america should he
ever get famous here in america it could
only be if people misunderstand him
and so and he's not the first to pick up
on this i mean this is a theme that gets
picked up over and over and over again
the notion that he can't have a wide
readership
because
if he does then it's
a trope it's a
you know it's a um
it's a hero worship and that nietzsche
was deeply critical of this so there are
commentators who themselves are very
critical of this homelink is another
example i could go on and on and yet
they're oftentimes the very people who
are popularizing nietzsche alan bloom's
a perfect example of this
you know the only reason why according
to bloom in 1987 that nietzsche could be
such a figure in our pop culture is
because he's so badly misunderstood
um
and there is some truth to that
but anyway
a simple answer then to get back to that
question is that sense of criticism that
sense of
understanding that nietzsche didn't want
nichians
we see that
um in fact the person i think who
expresses this most elegantly is josiah
royce
uh who is a
sort of eyebrow-raising when people
discover that royce was a nietzsche
reader because royce was a firm idealist
in the heyday of philosophical
pragmatism so what does an idealist want
with an anti-idealist philosopher but
royce understood this about nietzsche
was that nietzsche
was
tore down the absolutes
tore down the foundations of our belief
but he didn't just leave it at that he
said it's our job to come up with the
images of the possible after this and so
royce understood if you turn nietzsche
into that that ubermensch you're missing
the boat
uh you're not really fulfilling what
nietzsche had had called for or or what
he envisioned
i think he just gave me a new idea for a
seminar
wonderful
oh i think wrote
me a top reference for you
national tv wants to get this reference
pop reference for you another pop
reference okay in the movie blazing
saddles there's a character named howard
johnson in a town where all the people
are named johnson but howard johnson has
an ice cream parlor in one flavor anyway
he starts to make a pomp of speech and
he says new jesus another character says
oh howard blow it out you know
so i mean there it's kind of a throwaway
line and assumes that nietzsche is so
well known that people would would
understand sure he's going to say god is
dead maybe i suppose but no that's
exactly i mean it's it's often now and
this is how we can know that nietzsche
is so conventional
uh that he's as i put it in an article
that i've written he's a conventional
iconoclast i mean he's the
quintessential iconoclast in american
culture but like einstein in a way right
people people know him or his image but
they don't know
much about what his ideas actually
and so obviously there are different
kinds of sources right a niche a
throwaway line in a movie you can't
subject to the same kind of uh critical
uh analysis as entire books that have
been written about him and in the book i
try to look at all of those
uses i try to look at all the various
registers in which nietzsche crops up in
our life but i think even those
throwaway lines
as you put it there's there or the
throwaway visuals i mean the best one
that i can think of now is um
little miss sunshine where the brother
the the teenage brother is a nietzschean
and the the movie uh has where he has i
put it up on the screen in fact i could
go back to it where he's doing with like
sit-ups or push-ups in his room do you
remember
pull-ups in his room you know he's kind
of uh
flexing his own will to power amidst the
backdrop of here let me just go back
here there how do i make it bigger
i'm not sure i can
maybe i'll leave it like that because
otherwise i'll press some button and
it'll explode anyway it's the one in the
middle where there's a sheet and it's
just nietzsche's you know profile with
the furrowed bra for a mustache and i
have to tell you when i saw this now i
don't know the date of the movie mid mid
2000s maybe 2005 2004 i saw this in a
miami
movie theater with a bunch of
people younger than myself let's put it
that way and as soon as this scene
cropped up they all burst out into
laughter you know and that's exactly
what the movie
was going for just the visual cue you
know the incongruity of it just the
absurdity of it do i think people in the
audience at all read nietzsche no but
that q
already suggested
you know the self-aggrandized teenager
the naughtiness
and
again i think
sometimes those are simply the point of
entry for me as a historian to ask why
you know how is it possible
that like in blazing saddles or in conan
the barbarian it can open with a quote
and it has immediate resonance for us
and part of what i try to figure out or
examine in the book is because there's a
long history of
engagement with nietzsche that he is
just part of our discourse his terms are
our terms
his image is now a standard
um icon um iconographic image in our
visual culture
so i'm curious
in the archive do you get any clues into
the elizabeth's role in what she either
in her voice back to these writers what
did she choose to save i mean i was
sitting here thinking huh is there hate
mail in there or would she have thrown
away hate mail i mean did do you
do you get another side of a reaction
and do you get do you in your archival
research did you
could you figure out how she
contributes to fashioning
what's left for you or is that well
thank god for really really talented and
hardworking historians who have cobbled
together the story of elizabeth foster
nietzsche's crucial role
in nietzsche's career
um when nietzsche has his mental
breakdown in 1889
he spends the last 11 years of his life
um
uh
really stark raving matt i mean it
gets worse but
he
and that's when she takes over
and it's already in those years of his
mental twilight where she's crafting
nietzsche as a prophet and she's largely
uh many nature scholars will admit we
have elizabeth forester nisha to thank
prior to his sister prior to some uh you
know early folks who discovered him
nietzsche had not his fame had not yet
break broken and she was instrumental
um the unfortunate part of that story is
that she
uh
was
anti-semitic
she was
very nationalistic and in fact she is
the one who
over the course of the early 30s helps
to make the nietzsche archive basically
an instrument or an institution devoted
to to the nazis there's a famous picture
where she welcomes hitler and there's a
picture next you know hitler next to
nietzsche so she's she she uh
plays uh
some
unfortunate roles in helping to
refashion nietzsche as a proto-nazi and
and make him serviceable to the nazi how
she fits in uh for and and then she's
crucial for getting the public you know
to getting the translations out and
getting publications out so she's really
crucial for just getting nietzsche out
there how did she respond to the letter
writers the problem in the archive is
simply the spottiness of the record they
do not have a track they they that were
unable to to have any kind of record of
whether what degree how many letters
the the letters that are still extant
reflect
um we in some cases have outgoing
letters that had been sent back and some
of them would seem very gracious and
very particular so we can see that out
of some of these letters she formed
relationships with some people she had a
relationship with h.l menken
she had a relationship actually with
hunnicutt early on um she had a relate
relationship with a northwestern
philosopher by the name of james taft um
hatfield who was an important
philosopher in the early early 20th
century and even sends nietzsche's
collected volumes to him so he can have
it at northwestern
but it's just very spotty what she wrote
back
what i can
so
neither
what i don't have is how much these
letters reflect a full you know how many
letters came in and we can't quite see
the extent to which she wrote back but i
mean i can see kind of funny things
where uh it's actually nicha writes a
follow-up letter saying oh dear forester
nietzsche foster nietzsche i understand
that you cannot send an autograph of
nietzsche you need to keep you know his
body of autographs intact and so i
respect that i'm like what she sent you
know i have records of other people
saying thank you for the autograph so i
think she might have been very choosy
and very selective and very savvy about
who she was going to foster a
relationship with and and who not
is the american response to nietzsche
any different than other nationalities
that's a wonderful question um and
it's a question
that um
you know i can answer with sort of
varying degrees of precision but here's
what i think is the the the clearest
distinction if you will so
one way to answer the question is no i
mean there's there's some things which
we see traffic
are in all of the receptions and of
course nietzsche is a worldwide
phenomenon and there have been works on
nietzsche and germany in france um
in scandinavia in spain and italy and
japan
and so what i can see is some of the
things that we're seeing in america are
happening elsewhere
what i think is particular
to the american reading
is that i have very few
nietzsche interpreters
who are
reading nietzsche as a political thinker
and by that
politics with a capital p
they're reading nietzsche
if he's a critic of democracy
he is a cultural critic of democracy
that is to say he's a critic of the
kinds of human types that democracy
fosters does that make sense so they're
reading nietzsche not as some great
visionary of a new kind of politics
which we of course see
in russia
in italy with fascism and mussolini and
of course with the nazis
we don't see that in america
that is to say there may be
conservatives who read nietzsche or you
know liberals who read nietzsche and we
see both of those but they're reading
him more as a cultural critic
of
the human types that democracy fosters
and i think that's very different
and i think that is very particular it's
again a
nietzsche about
american culture or nietzsche about
american individuality anisha a
commentator on american souls
but not necessarily on our political
system as such
the other thing i would just signal and
uh danny was kind enough to reference it
uh in his intro i think unless i'm
misremembering um was that as i
mentioned also in the talk that
nietzsche was an avid reader of emerson
um in fact emerson was the first
philosopher that nietzsche read he read
nietzsche read emerson already as a
teenager
i discussed this in the prologue
and so one of the things i try to
examine in the book or at least touch on
when nietzsche
first when his ideas first come to
america at the late 19th early 20th
century
uh
occasionally thinkers would say sounds
kind of familiar
sounds a little bit like our emerson
but then they often usually do this as a
way to make a distinction yeah either
that nietzsche is genius and emerson is
kind of saccharine and victorian and too
much a goody goody or that emerson is
safe for democracy he's wholesome he's
well he doesn't have a breakdown and
that nietzsche is a you know syphilitic
madman so for those early on who hear
the emersonian timber and nietzsche's
voice are often trying to draw a
distinction but what's interesting is
this connection
uh carries on in the american readings
and in the last chapter i discuss
in particular three authors uh the
philosopher richard rorty uh the
literary critic harold bloom and the uh
also a philosopher stanley cavell
harvard philosopher all in their who
each in their own way use nietzsche as a
way to get back to emerson
to to re-read and rediscover emerson for
an american audience and so i think what
might be distinct about america
or what we might be able to
say is somehow colors this reception is
that in nietzsche
americans are hearing
as bloom put it their own inner orator
they're hearing emerson
so i think that there's something
particular in that way
there's a one more hand maybe one more
question
she's going to bring you the mic
okay thank you
i'm i'm an indigenous person
uh a tribal person of this continent and
we see nietzsche as is very different
from i think most americans i think like
particularly in youth a lot of americans
uh
admire nature for his uh rebelliousness
uh iconic uh
ism
but uh we see him as someone without a
conscience for instance with his book
beyond good and evil and so we see him
as very much like americans and
we we actually consider ourselves to be
it's not really a matter of
of culture or philosophy i study
philosophy at northwestern um
but
we see ourselves as physiologically
different we see ourselves as like being
bound uh to uh a conception of
of
of right and wrong of what should and
should not be
and that cannot change uh depending upon
uh what we read or what kind of
education we get i i just to let you
know if uh i blog about this on the
internet uh as chief hunting there one
word no punctuation
thank you
um
well
that's i'm very that's
that's a very big question
but let me try to give you a a
a simple answer
and hopefully not a simplistic one but i
mean i think
another would say that nietzsche is
without a conscience but nietzsche
certainly
is calling into question all absolutes
nietzsche calls into question
all foundations
for human belief
whether it be god
or science
whether it's truth
so nietzsche's entire philosophical
project i mean he does a lot of things
as a writer but one clear through line
of his writing and certainly the one
that has the biggest impact here
is that nietzsche challenged
universal truth so that's the problem
that's what we see is a problem there he
doesn't uh he doesn't think that
anything is objective that um right yeah
that that is exactly what we see as a
problem
he thinks that there are no facts
they're just uh hypotheses that there is
no objective reality um that's a that's
a very good reading of nietzsche and
it's one that many americans um have
uh
share with you
and it's for this very reason that some
think that he's remarkable and timely
and needed
to get rid of the artifacts
of you know what it is fill in the blank
right decayed christianity whether it's
the artifacts of
sexism or racism whether it's the
artifacts of a dysfunctional democracy
and others see this as a terrible
um
destructive
um
set of ideas that cause puts everything
into question that has no reverence that
gives us no point of moral orientation
and for a country a pluralist country
trying to find its unity this is not the
kind of philosopher we need here
um and so you're you're not alone um in
in that reading of nietzsche and all i
would say to you then as a historian is
that there are many people who both i
think thoughtful uh really intelligent
really interesting readers did very
different things than with the
consequences of that
so you're on you're right and the
question for readers was
what what can come out on the other end
can we get a better america a more
humane america
a better democracy
or is this um uh
uh will this tear away everything that
we hold near and dear and
we'll be stuck in a
you know destroyed nihilistic age so the
stakes are very high in nietzsche and i
think most of his readers uh understood
that and just how they came to terms
with it how they came to terms with
their america is this the subject of the
book and the reason why it's the subject
of the book is because it's a huge part
of our intellectual history
and so today the letter writers are just
a tiny little sampling of a much larger
set of conversations worried ones uh
angry ones i mean today i showed you the
devotees but there are people who
dedicated their careers to taking
nietzsche down and they're they're
important too and they're discussed in
the book as well but what i hope to
simply make unmistakable is we under one
to understand these moral reckonings in
20th century american life we can't do
it with under without understanding how
nietzsche often figured in to this
conversation
so thank you
there was a there was a comment uh in
which he was compared to albert einstein
i saw that too because uh albert
einstein's ideas uh were basically uh a
popularization
of uh of uh uh moral relativity uh that
uh that uh that there are no
there are no absolutes and so my people
don't admire him either that's yeah i
mean but that's uh
that's nisha moral relativity um or
that that already actually let me let me
change that one could could quibble with
that philosophically uh richard rorty a
reader of nietzsche quibbles with the
notion of relativity um as itself bound
in the same kind of absolutes as
objectivity but
that gets a little high-flying for us
tonight at 7 30. but then the notion
that he's tearing away moral absolutes
is absolutely true and your your your
concern about the consequences for that
and also that it brushes up against what
you hold dear
is right now in in the united states i'm
what's called an indigenous terrapin
like t-e-r-r-a-p-i
tribes person and
our people are being used for medical
experimentation right now there's a
genocide against us and nobody cares
because
it doesn't affect them
and this is moral relativity if if
if there were
if if our morality was based on our
physiology and it was absolutely right
and wrong this could not be
happening uh that's uh i mean that's a
i i i i would just
try to uh bring to
uh awareness that there are many nature
readers who would think that nietzsche's
philosophy would be as outraged as you
are he would just use different
arguments why it's outrageous so anyway
thank you
thank you very much for coming
[Applause]
is there a non-fiction author or book
you'd like to see featured on book tv
send us an email at booktv cspan.org
books are interviewed watch past
afterwards programs online at booktv.org
university of wisconsin professor
jennifer ratner rosenhagen
who is frederick nietzsche
frederic nietzsche was a german 19th
century german philosopher
who
wrote
many many many many books a philosophy
in all sorts of different forms
and all of them so some aphoristic some
essayistic
some longer form critiques
and all of them had something to do
with the challenge of universal truth so
he he took as his enemy the notion of
universal truth
and pretty much all of his work has
something to do with his effort to
tear it down excavate it look at the
history of that idea
and to show that anything that we take
to be universals like oh god um are
human creations
but they're not
rooted in nature or necessity they're
not mirrors of reality
he wrote at one time god is dead and he
wrote that god is dead
um
and this uh make first makes its
appearance in his gay science
um and in it uh the gay science uh in it
it's a uh an aphorism um and it's called
the madman and so the aphorism is he's
playing with this this idea that a
madman runs into the to the town square
and says god is dead god is dead we have
killed him you and i and everybody says
oh he's crazy oh he's crazy and he
realizes oh my time has not come yet
um and so there he's announcing
what what's going to be basically his
intellectual project for the rest of his
his writing life before he goes insane
and that is the notion that god is dead
um
what troubled nietzsche was that
in over the course of 19th century as in
particular germans became more modern
and more secular that they continued to
go to church and pray to a god that they
didn't really believe in anymore in
other words he thought that modern
thought modern science the forces of
modernity were undermining the basis of
religion and yet he said
people still held on to it they still
clutched onto it because they were too
terrified to live without it and this he
found really despicable uh and that's
that's
that's what he he tries to work out in
his philosophy
where did he teach how did he come about
was he well known in his time
um nietzsche
well we have to sort of separate the
myth from
the the
from the reality which is that nietzsche
did have moments of um
modest fame um actually his first book
uh the birth of tragedy
had a pretty big reception uh but then
he did fade into obscurity um he was a
philology professor in basel so a
professor of language um history of
language the genealogy of language uh
but the academic life uh wasn't for him
uh he he suffered from a lot of physical
ailments ailments pardon me um so i mean
historians and philosophers debate why
did he why did he have such a tough time
in the academy although some of us in
the academy nowadays don't wonder that
much but anyway nietzsche taught for 10
years
in basel
with some success
but due to
reasons that we can only sort of
imperfectly suss out was it his health
was it what he said which is that he
needed to break free
nietzsche breaks free lives on a pension
the rest of his life
and gets to inhabit
the image of the free thinker
that he so exalts uh and worships in his
own philosophy
um so but nietzsche
didn't have a huge readership
most of his productive life and i say
productive life because in 1889 he has a
nervous collapse and spends the last 11
years of his life
um
[Music]
in
a very declining state i mean
and ends up in a totally vegetative
state
and dies in 1900.
he's discovered
so how does nietzsche become nietzsche
um he's discovered precisely
in those months when his health is
declining
shortly before this mental collapse so
one of the terrible ironies of friedrich
nietzsche's life and the posthumous life
of his ideas is that it's in the moment
when his when intellectually and
mentally you know there's a closing of
accounts for him that's the moment when
the floodgates open and he becomes uh
the superstar that he is today
who discovered him how was he discussing
he was discovered uh
this is a little tricky because there's
always a quest for a priority um people
were reading nietzsche uh but were those
people being read but i think it's fair
to say that the the the
uh danish critic george brandes who
himself had a big audience um
uh in the late 19th century he is
credited with discovering each and i
think
that's a fair assessment that he brings
the most fame to nietzsche um and they
actually do have a brief correspondence
in that last year just as madness is
closing in on nietzsche and nietzsche
thinks finally finally someone
recognizes my genius and then lo and
befo behold he has a mental collapse in
turin and that's pretty much the end of
his productive life
so brandes is credited largely with kind
of getting the word out in um northern
european circles
that nietzsche nietzsche is one to watch
and that's when nietzsche's reputation
boom really takes off
who followed him who
liked his work what kind of people what
kind of politicians
everybody
uh atheists religionists the left the
right women men black whites old people
young people so nietzsche now that's not
immediate because he needs to be
translated yeah uh nietzsche is not
translated in earnest until the late
into the 1896 1897 is the first round of
translations then there's another major
effort of translations that happened in
the early 20th century
of course in the late 19th century and
early 20th century a lot of educated
americans could read german so people
were reading him you know in the
original
but it really did require the
translations for him to take off
um
henry
um uh um eight why am i calling him
henry h l menken he didn't go by henry
um h.l menken
has a lot to do with nietzsche's super
stardom
now it's not to say that there weren't
other folks who were reading nietzsche
and popularizing nietzsche in the united
states before mankind but menken is the
one who writes the first full-length
monograph on nietzsche in 1908
and that's where we get a kind of
full-on synopsis about nietzsche's life
his travails his struggles with
christianity his struggles with health
we get a little bit about nietzsche's
sexuality it wouldn't be menken if there
wasn't a little something racy thrown in
and then we get nietzsche's ideas boom
and this book sold widely and sold well
and it helped do two things it helped
really establish nietzsche's reputation
in america but it did something else
which is of course it helped menken
become menken
so if somebody says
i love friedrich nietzsche i agree with
him what are they saying to you
professor
if they're just saying that not much
because
someone
i mean i use the example of
chest chest-thumping atheists and
bible-thumping christians could both
make that claim about nietzsche
and that's what's so startling about his
reception
is that he doesn't track right or left
um he doesn't track religious or secular
he tracks or rather he tracks
all over our intellectual spectrum so
just the statement i love miesha um
doesn't tell me much of anything other
than that's an utterly conventional
experience
um
to to you know find nietzsche
so powerful um in fact i think what's so
so interesting is how many people will
say and have said over the course of the
late 19th 20th century of course until
our own time how they felt when they
read nietzsche he was speaking to them
personally
so one of the things i argue in the book
is that nietzsche becomes a superstar
public philosopher by way of private
longings and private fears
um
so
you have a strange look you have a
disturbed look on your face
who wouldn't
like friedrich nietzsche then
oh there are plenty of people who don't
like friedrich who don't like friedrich
nietzsche and there were things
not to like
he didn't say very nice things about
democracy
he didn't say very nice things about
women he didn't say very nice things
about equality
and
so if these are things that matter to
you you're going to
take issue with him so let me give you a
concrete example of
what's
what's to like and what's not to like
about nietzsche and
oh gosh i can take any anyone but i'll
take one of the more spectacular
examples and that is the leopoldon lobe
trial of 1924.
so leopold and loeb are two university
of chicago students
who think
that they are the uber mention that they
are what nietzsche had in mind when he
wrote about the uber mention and they
wanted to prove it to themselves which
is beyond uh the ubermensch is the the
superman
it gets translated as the superman in
fact the superman as in superman comic
which we tend to think of as you know
americana has its roots in nietzsche's
ubermensch um in fact the two men the
two boys i don't know men who come up
with superman were readers of nietzsche
um
so it's just a little
and there's many cases like that i mean
even i think the fact that we have the
word uber you know
uber i think comes into our language in
the way that it does by way of the
ubermensch anyway but that we're talking
about an example where
we have
two views that say they have the right
nietzsche
and that is leopold and loeb they read
nietzsche they think that he's the
they're the superman he had in mind and
so they want to prove it to themselves
and so they kill they kidnap and kill a
14 year old boy bobby franks in the
south side of chicago
they get caught it turns out that they
weren't so uber as they thought
clarence darrow
the famed trial attorney becomes their
defense lawyer
and he's also a reader of nietzsche but
he's not a murderer in fact he's quite
sure that that's not what nietzsche had
in mind
and so the interesting thing about the
whole
leopoldon lobe trial which is trying to
save these boys from
these
young men from being killed themselves
is how daryl had to not make to both say
the reason why they did this is because
nietzsche is toxic and a dangerous
thinker and they misunderstood him and
yet nietzsche is an important thinker
that we need in modern life but we need
to handle him with care so so it's i'm
just something like that the leopoldon
lobe trial you see those sorts of
negotiations where nietzsche is both um
you know
public enemy number one
um as we see uh with
with the murder but we also see with the
clarence dara saying no nietzsche is the
thinker that we americans need in order
to embrace modern life
political movements that have
co-opted nietzsche
oh so many
i think
the one that i mean really the whole
20th century is a story of co-optation
i think the one that surprises my
readers the most or at least when i get
letters from readers or i get um or come
into contact with readers it's nietzsche
the hidden nichian origins of black
power
so huey p newton was a reader of
friedrich nietzsche
and in nietzsche
he discovered
he discovered a lot of things in
nietzsche but what he understood from
nietzsche is he he needed nature to to
tell him that the things that your
culture tell you are true
and are universal
it's in fact
made up or it's a it's a product of
history it's a product of chance it's
somewhat arbitrary but it's not true
and so don't take the voice
of a racist culture
um as the voice of your own inner
conscience yeah and this is what so for
huey p newton this is what nietzsche did
for african americans
is to help them hear
that they no longer had to pray to the
white man's god they no longer had to
make themselves prostrate to a religion
and in his view that made them
supplicants
and that they shouldn't take this
morality which tries to discipline them
and keep them down as something
universal as something timeless
and so huey p newton is is really
intellectually if you will cutting his
teeth on nietzsche as he and bobby seal
are coming together and formulating the
basis
of
black power
world war ii
no
the the reason why i sigh is
there are i don't know of any other
philosopher in history um that's blamed
for two world wars
um
uh but nietzsche was so you can't just
quickly
world war ii i actually think is the
more interesting story here
um
uh
because all the ways in which
nietzsche's reputation is just so
terribly damaged
but just quickly if i may world war one
um
nietzsche
uh
when world war one breaks out and this
is so shocking to american observers it
starts to come out you know it's
nietzsche it's nietzsche it's nature
rumors of german
ministers preaching nietzsche from their
pulpits it wasn't hard to
listen and hear traces of nietzsche and
philosophy behind the blood and iron
imperialism of
world war in germany during world war
one
um and so nietzsche is yoked to world
war one and has a very hard time well
those who want to try to save his
reputation and say this wasn't what he
intended this is just the misuse of
nietzsche had a really hard hard time
afterwards
um then of course leopold and loeb don't
do much for his reputation
and then
with the rise of hitler not not
mussolini initially who was a reader of
nietzsche and an enthusiast of nietzsche
um hitler the rise of hitler in
particular
was the more
um
i think those sort of the more
terrifying
development so over the course of the
1930s as we see the specter of nazism
and then later as americans started to
see mussolini as a greater threat than
they initially had
it was not hard to find nietzschean
traces behind nazi philosophy and
mussolini's fascism and so lo and behold
nietzsche you know yet again is seen as
the
the author and visionary of what would
become world war ii
of course nietzsche wrote up things that
were not so hard to turn into or to make
him implicated he wrote of the rise of
the blonde beast
um
so which people thought it took to be
his celebration of
of uh the aryan race his sister actually
was a proto-nazi and in her her her
closing years she welcomes hitler to the
nietzsche archive so
um there's a there's a linkage to hitler
and some very unfortunate pictures of
hitler and elizabeth forrester nietzsche
with the nietzsche bust at the nietzsche
archive so in the american imagination
nietzsche really gets linked to
uh
world war
ii and the entire nazi ideology
that not here we have the germans who
didn't just want an uber mensch but they
wanted an uber race and we know the
language of intermission
the subhuman people
which was all throughout germany during
during world war ii
nietzsche was just
implicated in all of this
what's his reputation today and who
who's the
anti-nietzsche philosopher who's
is there such a thing
oh there's plenty
um
yeah but i don't think they're as
interesting
um
uh
sure i mean um
george santayana
is not a
thinker that we talk about much today
though we should because he was a
towering intellectual towering
philosopher
and poet and novelist in the early 20th
century he thought nietzsche was
everything that was wrong with what he
called the german mind
that hyper-trophied self yeah the
hyper-aggrandized self
um he thought that that germ the germ
what he called the german mind or the
german temperament
and he traces this back to kant and up
through hegel and the nietzsche becomes
the great exemplar is
an intellectual
or a mind that just didn't couldn't deal
with limits
so he actually referred to nietzsche's
amateurish and and adolescent
so he's pretty dismissive of nietzsche
and that's an example of a thinker who i
think is a very robust thinker and a
careful thinker
um
there are plenty
there are plenty others i actually think
an interesting case here is
an example the example of alan bloom
um who
in the reception of his famous book the
um the closing of the american mind you
know a blockbuster um uh
uh book
um alan bloom says you know what's the
wrong with higher education it's killing
the souls of our children they're
getting all this pluralism they're
getting all this multiculturalism
um but what they're not getting is um
great ideas
uh and they're not getting the the
challenges of those great ideas so it's
how the how higher education is
impoverishing our nature our
the the souls of our
um of our children
and nietzsche is right there all along
he even talks about the nichianization
of american intellectual life
um and according to bloom
he thinks that so much of what is wrong
in late night late 20th century
intellectual life is that intellectuals
are reading their nietzsche
and kind of like what george santayana
says they're tired of universal truth
they're tired of power they're of
someone else's power they're tired of
authority and so he he says that all
that the counterculture of the 1960s is
is nursed on nietzschean um
anti-authoritarianism
and he said this is it's one thing to
have these kinds of protests in the
streets it's another thing to bring them
into the academy and make such a ruckus
so he's very critical of
the uses of nietzsche
so i hit the pause button here if you
read how
everyone's talking about alan bloom's
book and they were talking and they were
talking and they were talking because as
you know it was a major major major
blockbuster
people picked up on aha you know
nietzsche uh alan bloom blames nietzsche
you know it's the neutrinization of our
american intellectual life blah blah
blah blah so you would think that alan
bloom
you know had had a problem with
nietzsche
he didn't
he thought nietzsche was a genius
he loved nietzsche he wrote beautifully
about nietzsche he wrote longingly about
nietzsche he thought nietzsche was a
genius and his problem was that he
thought he was in a culture of
intellectual pygmies who could not
appreciate the genius of nietzsche
so um and so what he's actually doing in
the closing of the american mind which i
think is such an interesting move he's
not really blaming nietzsche
for the impoverishment of american
intellectual life he had the sort of
anti-authoritarianism that he finds so
despicable
he's blaming what he says is
readers who just aren't up to the task
of truly understanding this great genius
um so again that's not someone who's
critical of nietzsche per se
although he has a reputation for having
you know pinned all the failures of late
20th century american intellectual life
on nietzsche quite the opposite what
he's trying to do is keep his own
private nietzsche anita in his own image
against what he sees as
the slavish
inadequate impoverished american
intellectual life that just can't handle
these powerful ideas
jennifer ratner rosenhagen you've
written a
biography
of friedrich nietzsche are you a fan
if i may i would say i that i would
people call it a biography of friedrich
nietzsche but it's actually a biography
of his ideas
as they come to life in america
so one of the things i say in the book
is that it's not this is not actually a
book about nietzsche in fact some
readers have been disappointed
of course he crops up quite a bit but
the book is not about nietzsche i'm an
american historian
i'm an american intellectual and
cultural historian my interest is
the history of american thought and
culture
over
19th and 20th century what i discovered
is you can't when you get to the late
19th century the 20 through the 20th
century you can't talk about american
intellectual life without talking about
nietzsche's presence his curious
presence really and his influence um so
anyways it's just a little modest
correction here
it's not about nietzsche it's about us
so every reading of nietzsche i'm not
listening whether h.l menken or clarence
darrow or walter kaufman who becomes so
important to redeem nietzsche after
world war ii or huey p newton or
alan bloom are getting him right or
wrong i don't think that's the
interesting question for a historian to
ask
what i'm trying to do is listen in to
what they have to say about nietzsche to
listen to see what that tells us about
american intellectual life in that
particular moment
so the book is actually
not about nietzsche it's about us it's
about our intellectual life and it's
about our coming to
coming to our own ideas about truth
about
democracy about christianity about god
by way of nietzsche
but i'm dodging the question
has he in your view been a positive
influence in american
political and cultural life
uh you know what that's incredible i've
never been asked that question
i think he's a necessary influence
because i think he's right i mean i
think there's a lot of gunk in what he
says there's a lot of grandstanding in
machismo but you clear away some of that
gunk
and the the the ideas i think are ideas
that we had to
had to come to terms with
which is
again to to just repeat what i had said
earlier
the notion that so much of we what we
take to be universally true
um
whether it be god whether it be
democracy whether it would be whatever
it is
nietzsche gave us a way of looking at
those ideas those truth claims to see
their origins and their genealogy
and nietzsche helped
americans to see that so many truth
claims
are not rooted in reality they're rooted
in power
um they're rooted in needs they're
rooted in fear they're rooted in longing
but they're not necessarily rooted in
truth
and i think this is this is necessary i
mean for any culture uh truthfully but
especially american culture
because we have from the start been a
very pluralistic culture
um of many languages of many religions
of many ethnicities of different races
and so
part of what it means to be american
right from our earliest years here is
contested truth
is a pluralistic
sensibility is a land of many religions
and many beliefs and we haven't we never
did a good job of negotiating or we
didn't do it that great job of
negotiating this prior to nietzsche but
nietzsche becomes his ideas become
important as we negotiate this moving
forward
so an answer to your question do i think
is a positive force yeah and he's also
been a negative force although he had
nothing to do with it because he was
long dead
um
but and his ideas have been
read in all sorts of curious ways but i
think as i as i said i think he was a
necessary force and in that regard
salutary force because he helped
americans to confront
fundamental problems that we've had
which is problems of living in a
pluralistic society
and doing so in a humane
way
and
and
and for that i think
well here i'll just speak as a historian
many people were grateful in the 20th
century that they had nietzsche to think
with about these issues
university of wisconsin professor
jennifer ratner rosenhagen
teaches history here
at the university here's her book
american nietzsche a history of an icon
and his ideas you're watching book tv on
c-span 2.
here's a look at some authors recently
featured on book tv's afterwards are
working on capitol hill
and that's our program schedule
next about books
we begin with historian arthur herrmann
and a look at the ideas of nietzsche
freud and others who've predicted
decline for western civilization
after that book dealers and collectors
gathered for the 22nd annual washington
antiquarian book fair we'll show you
highlights
and then consumer advocate ralph nader
discusses his latest book no contest
corporate lawyers and the perversion of
justice in america
now arthur herman talks about his new
book the idea of decline in western
history the book surveys intellectual
thought about the idea of civilization's
decline over the past two centuries
arthur herman is professor of history at
george mason university and coordinator
of the western civilization program at
the smithsonian
he spoke at the center for equal
opportunity in washington
good d.c i'd like to welcome all of you
to the center for equal opportunities
regular ongoing series of book luncheons
and we are very privileged today to have
with us arthur herman who is the author
of the idea of decline in western
history
professor hermann is professor of
history at george mason university he is
also the coordinator of the western
civilization program at the smithsonian
institution
and we are particularly pleased to have
profess uh professor herman here today
to talk about his book
the decline the idea of decline in
western history
uh there have been as all of you know
many books written over the years about
the decline of western civilization
it is in fact an ongoing theme
in
critiques
of history and in a series of books that
have been popular particularly within
the last few years paul kennedy's book
even
judge bork's book slouching toward
gomorrah which has dealt with the idea
of decline
in the west and in the united states in
particular
but
professor herman's book is not
technically speaking a book about the
decline of the west it is rather an
intellectual history about the idea of
decline in the west which i think is a
very important and subtle distinction
and i'd like to read just a paragraph
which i think says very well sums up
very well
the thesis of professor herman's book
and it is from his introduction
some people talk about the decline of
civilization others live it
this is a book about the origins and
diffusions of an intellectual tradition
the idea of the decline of the west
we will see how it formed the dark
underside of modern european thought in
the 19th century and how it became
arguably the single most dominant and
influential theme in culture and
politics in the 20th century
not only has it affected people's lives
in unexpected and startling ways which
we will examine in some detail
but it may also be inseparable
from the idea of civilization itself
professor herman's book has uh met with
much critical acclaim
and
i'd like to just read a few of the
things that have been said about it
including one statement by gertrude
himmelfarb who is an eminent historian
herself and who happens to be with us
today
and she described the book as powerful
and persuasive
publishers weekly described the book in
this way herman takes us through these
heady thoughts with great panache and
erudition a brisk and cordial guide to
the slough of despond
fred siegel writing in the weekly
standard
said his book should trigger a long
overdue scholarly debate
and the los angeles times said
it deserves a significant audience and
we are very happy today to help provide
uh some of that audience and professor
herman we'll speak for about 20 minutes
and then we will have questions and
answers thank you
well i want to tell you that it's a real
pleasure to be here
this is a wonderful venue for me
and it's one that i would have
would have picked for myself
even if linda hadn't invited me to come
out here
because i think a lot of the issues that
i talk about in the book
are of interest to
the uh
ongoing conversation that does take
place here at the center for economic
opportunity and those kinds of things
and
and uh i think that the book has a has a
certain kind of uh
impact on that plus the fact that i
don't ever really turn down an
invitation to talk about my own book so
uh
that plays its part in
in this in this decision as well
um
what i thought i would do is just talk
briefly about
what i wanted to do with the book
uh which is also a way to kind of
summarize the major issues that inform
the whole the whole discussion there but
i thought what i would also do is talk
about some things some themes of it and
issues that are of interest to the kinds
of questions and again the kind of
conversation about the role of
uh
multiculturalism the role of different
uh and often conflicting ethnic
identities in uh
in the shaping of
of american civilization and whatever
whatever happens with it from from this
point on
and basically what i wanted to do with
the book was to try and explain
how an idea a way of talking about
history a way of talking about change
about the fate of societies and
of civilizations
a way of talking that centered it
centered those discussions on in terms
of inevitable decline
and degeneration
to show how this way of talking first
came into being how it originated and
then also to talk about how it came to
has come to permeate so many aspects of
modern culture
turning up in all kinds of surprising
and unusual places
from uh
from the
modernism of the early 20th century all
the way through on to on to figures like
uh figures bizarre figures like the
unabomber and
vice president albert garr
the um which i talk about in detail in
the in in in the book
this is um and this way of talking what
i try to show in the book is that this
way of talking is reflected not just in
the kind of pessimism
it's notions of decline
not just in the kind of pessimism that
uh
surveys
opinion surveys always manage to pick up
from the american public
in which uh every time they're asked
about 60 or 70 percent
uh of citizens believe that the country
is on the wrong track uh and that they
always seem to feel this regardless of
what that track might be
uh that this just seems to be a natural
reaction to where to where in a sense
america seems to be going
but i also tried to show that this
show how this idea this way of talking
this idea of decline
really underpins
the movement of various radical
discontents in this country
whether you're talking about radical
environmentalism
whether you're talking about
the post-modernism
that permeates so much of academic life
and intellectual discourse that takes
place in universities
uh and the whole series of movements
that people usually talk about usually
describe as multiculturalism
and what i wanted to show is that all of
these movements really share the same
basic assumption and that is is that
societies built on western industrial
models
are all doomed to destruction
that they all destroy human
vitality and creativity
that
industrial societies modern industrial
societies
uh tear apart communities and kind of
natural social holes that had
that had grown up before
industrialization and modern society
came into existence here and that in the
end in the end these modern industrial
societies have no values and that's a
key word here uh throughout the book and
the way in which the notion of values
becomes so is so you know permeates so
much of our discussion
here uh our current cultural debates uh
is itself in many ways reflective of
this idea of decline
but the only thing really that modern
industrial societies produce it's
assumed
are material goods which you know
everyone has too much of that anyway uh
so that really doesn't serve any purpose
and uh uh that and also these uh you
know sort of little armies of of of
shallow self-interested easily
manipulable
uh
little
automatons who come out of it what
herbert marcuza called
one-dimensional men
and what frederick nietzsche called the
last man the last man the last men
who would emerge at the end of at the
end of western civilization uh human
beings who were really
in nietzsche's views more insects than
they were human beings
and that and then
because of this then the assumption is
that in order to recover some sense of
humanity in order to recover our sense
of ourselves what we have to do then is
to turn away from the west and modern
western values
to look for some kind of new dawn some
sort of new order
that is going to replace its inevitable
collapse
and that we built upon the ruins the
ruins of that bankrupt and discredited
civilization
so that's the overall trajectory of the
book
but i also at the same time wanted to
show something else
and that is how the first people to
become convinced
that western civilization is in decline
and that idea by the way starts very
early in the 19th century that these
people
who who saw the west as systematically
unraveling itself were not in any kind
of way radicals
that
that it includes people's intellectuals
such as henry adams in this country
but we're instead people who were deeply
concerned uh and uh perhaps also deep uh
a little confused conservatives
who were generally worried about the
direction that their own societies were
taking
but that by choosing
to explain these changes and the
consequences in terms of decline in
terms of degeneration and the other
sorts of this other kind of gloom and
doom forecast that went with it
that that that in a sense that they had
that they ended up producing
this view of the west is systematically
destroying itself these are the people
that i talk about as the historical
pessimists and this was a matter of real
concern that the values the humane
liberal values and and western
judeo-christian values that they
believed in were coming under attack and
were were in a sense under a kind of
pressure that they couldn't withstand
and that by talking about these changes
in this way what they did what people
like henry adams did was to open the
door then two more radical solutions to
the problem
to those who had plans and agendas uh
springing from this basic assumption
that the that if the modern west is in
decline it's because it deserves to be
in decline that the that the fruits of
it that the seeds of destruction are
there from the very beginning uh and
that therefore if we're going to escape
from that kind of collapse what we've
really got to do then is to look for
that kind for a range of alternatives
these are the people i call the cultural
pessimists
and so what i was really trying to do
was to show how the historical pessimist
arguments
then open the door create a situation in
which these more radical solutions uh
suddenly come forward as being more
acceptable uh and becoming uh becoming
the solution as i say the basic idea
being that the faster the west collapses
then the better uh the better for
everyone involved
so this opened the way the historical
pessimism opened the way first to uh
racist
doctrines and
themes
which argue that the only way then to
save
civilization was through a radical
racial purity
that the the process of civilization
itself was creating a society of of of
of racial mixtures and cultural
degradation and that only by protecting
white the original white aryan
race
uh and its virtues from that kind of
pollution this is the only way in which
the west was going to
survive uh it paved the way for
race-based eugenics
with that same sense that the west was
facing a crisis at the end of the 19th
century
uh of uh degeneracy thanks to industrial
civilization that therefore what had to
be done now was a uh was to preserve the
race through various kinds of drastic
measures uh excluding those who were
unfit uh and unable to carry this burden
of civilization that the white race had
assumed for itself here and it also
opened the door for various radical
nationalist movements now which is what
happens is of course in germany
uh and in many ways the nazis are the
first european generation of cultural
pessimists
of men raised in a 19th century german
intellectual tradition
that was permeated by this contempt
for
bourgeois civilization
uh and its values
uh and also permeated by this fear that
industrial society was going to shatter
and disrupt the very precious sources
and sacred sources
of of cultural and creativity
that were found in traditional germany
that these would all be destroyed
through industrialization that therefore
that represent this this
this threat this direct mortal threat to
germany's own soul
now that german tradition that tradition
of german historical pessimism academic
uh a cultural criticism of the modern
west is also important i think for
understanding
our own multiculturalist impulses today
and the reason i say that is that
it that this german tradition
comes to this country
uh through a particular an important
channel namely through the intellectual
legacy of w.e.b du bois
uh the man who is of course today the
the prince viewed as the premier uh
african-american philosopher and thinker
but who is also the in a sense the
spiritual godfather of of
multiculturalism uh in its various uh
shapes and forms
now du bois reputation uh as being this
profound and important figure uh is one
that i'm not going to try and take away
from him it's it's built on very solid
foundations he was extremely prolific
as a journalist and as an author
historian philosopher
writer of fiction he was a brilliant
writer brilliant command of prose
uh he was a devastating critic
of prevalent white attitudes regarding
race
um and uh and and issues of segregation
which which uh du bois watched take
place
the pro the development of jim crow is
something which he which he watched come
into place uh uh during his lifetime
but it's also worth bearing in mind i
think that he is that his own
assumptions the assumptions from which
he produced this prodigious body of work
and study were the same assumptions as
that of other fantasy equal german
academic thinkers
and this is where the ground he comes
out of and i have a whole chapter on him
there to where i try and try and point
this out in detail and in many ways i
thought when i when i wrote it i was
remember thinking that this is this is
easily the most important part of the
book here this is the one that's going
to attract the most attention you know
stating that this major figure w.e du
bois is really uh
a crowd in a sense of an intellectual uh
intellectual german philosopher and that
these are the basis of all his
assumptions and of course what happened
was is that the reviewers all didn't pay
any attention at all uh to it well all
except i'll accept the weekly standard
fred siegel did pick it up and mention
it uh in detail
du bois's experience uh exposure to
german philosophy came during his two
years of study
at the university of berlin
1892-94
and those years really changed his life
it really had
and he admitted this later on it really
had much more of an impact on his
intellectual development then his years
as an undergraduate at harvard
and his work with
leading teachers there never really had
the kind of transformative impact that
coming in contact with with the german
educational system but also with the key
professors and intellectual movements
there did have
so what was it he learned what was it he
did pick up from it for those years in
germany
well first of all he did pick up this
idea that the industrial west is really
doomed if it continues to follow this
capitalist model of development
these were the ideas the armchair
socialists who supervised his phd thesis
uh who's preached this idea of the
inevitable need for a socialist state
here as a means of correcting this
inevitable direction of decline uh the
rhetoric that they used to talk about
the impact of industrialization on
workers of workers reduced to wage
slaves these kinds of terms the notion
of industrialization as slavery
certainly had an impact on du bois in
his way
and touched deeply on his own on his own
understanding of of the relationship
here between slavery and the west uh and
really had a big impact on shaping that
but also at the same time uh they also
the other point that he picked up was
that industrial societies like america
sapped away
the energy and vitality of the people
and culture that were part of it
uh and and here this german dichotomy
that was so important in the 19th
century between
soul-destroying
civilization or civilization
versus this soul-restoring
culture or culture this permeates all of
du bois's work and it becomes a key
distinction and dichotomy in his own
mind for understanding uh the role of
african americans are going to come to
play in american society uh as well
here that in a sense that black men and
women in america find themselves in the
same position and are going to be talked
about by du bois in the same way as
as these
philosophers talked about german
peasants
that in a sense they had the same
virtues of german peasants were those of
the virtues of of blacks who arrived uh
here in america this kind of inner
creativity a kind of natural vitality
which their situation in america and
living in this kind of oppressive
culture and civilization takes away and
saps away
and again that this is again a
distinction distinct from
although a process which was
a part and parcel of slavery but it is
also something which the end of slavery
and emancipation does not end
that that process of soul-destroying
civilization grinds on grinds on uh
whether free or slave
and and of course du bois term for this
kind of natural creativity and natural
vitality soul
we see takes place arises also from this
german context german cultural critics
have been using that term soul zela
for a long time
long before dubois appeared on the scene
and again it was the idea of soul
in was to be understood this natural
vitality a soul was to be understood in
racial terms uh that in fact each race
each race had its own little bundle of
vitality here
which in the case of
blacks was still uncontaminated by
contact with
you see this destructive civilization
the western capitalism and all of the
kinds of institutions that it creates
so what du bois did was to take up these
themes
and to use them
to intervene on the african-american
uh intellectual
uh
uh debates
that were raging
at the turn of the century
and he really reshapes them at a very
very crucial time
he's going to use those ideas not just
to discredit booker t washington's view
of how blacks are to assimilate into
modern american society
and the for for du bois the whole notion
of assimilation of assimilation in
washington's terms and that is of blacks
becoming active willing participants in
the free enterprise capitalist system
was for him this is the last thing in
the world you want to do you don't want
to attach yourself to the
soul-destroying mechanism at all you
want to break free it from it you want
to find alternatives from it so he uses
it first to discredit
booker t washington but he's also going
to use it to reject the earlier models
of black nationalism of figures like
alexander cromell
and henry turner
these were
black nationalists
of an earlier generation they had been
passionately committed
to black nationalism
uh they were passionately committed to a
sense of racial pride
but they had also insisted that if
blacks were going to change their status
in the world that they also needed to
acknowledge the values of white
civilization uh and its institutions
science technology
capitalism and of course also uh the
values of of christianity and the
judeo-christian tradition
both
cromell and turner were were bishops in
the methodist episcopalian church and
and for them white civilization also
included necessarily included these
christian this christian framework as
well
so what du bois is going to do is reject
all of that
and overturn it and it's interesting to
speculate i think how the history of
black nationalism
would have been different
if it had not turned its back at the uh
on this what historians call the
civilizationist's thesis this idea that
assimilation includes a kind of a kind
of a kind of assimilation in a cultural
um uh and in a value sense
as well as one of in terms of political
and social mobility that also has to
involve this embrace of a larger
cultural mobility but du bois makes sure
and the growth of his influence makes
sure that that does not happen
because du bois was convinced that the
west and the industrial colonial empires
that had clustered around it were now
finished
and in many ways his view about the west
here is very much akin to oswald
spenglers the overlap between spangler's
decline of the west and du bois writings
on these same themes is really
remarkable and they really do they
really do fit together very well
instead what dubois saw in the future
was the rise of what he called the
darker nations to global power
first in the case of the yellow races
and we have to remember that du bois was
writing at a time when japan was
emerging as a major player in colonial
conflicts and on the world stage at the
turn of the century
uh but then but then after the yellow
races had risen to power then it would
be then would be black africa's turn
and du bois is a notion the whole the
this famous phrase that this is the that
we live in the the age of the color line
but we have to realize is that for
dubois this was a color line uh the
balance of power
along which was now about to shift in
his mind
but these empires these empires of the
dark nations would all be based upon
again this racial vitalist model
in which technology
material wealth are tools tools to be
used by a racial elite uh as a means by
which to to to gain the levers of power
uh and to direct them here uh and would
be these empires also would draw upon uh
this
element of the marxist model
and again for du bois as for later
multiculturalism marxism's appeal
is simply that it is uh in fact a
revolutionary
doctrine that it is anti-capitalist and
therefore
implicitly anti-western
uh that the use that marxism is going to
play in these kinds of this kind of
development is as a
as a kind of anti-model to this larger
industrial western cultural and economic
complex
and it's really kind of interesting to
see how
the r how the rise of radical
racial movements
um
beginning in the 60s
follow also the rise of du bois's
reputation
as he moves from a period of time when
she was really in the shadows which was
the 40s and 50s
and suddenly becomes the great model
and the intellectual
mentor for a whole generation of of
black radicals starting first with the
black power and and figures uh like like
malcolm x
then in then with the development of
african-american studies and uh and and
and afrocentrism
and now
uh being treated today as a kind of
spokesman
for the uh for a black atlantic
consciousness
being put in these kinds of larger
post-modern terms as someone who who has
who has comes up with a new
a new alternative vision uh for
individuals and community as well as
culture
that really in the end du bois is the
intellectual godfather for all these
movements
uh which celebrate the essential
vitalism of the person of color and
again i want to point out this this link
again to this sort of german view of the
role of culture
of natural vitality here which western
society takes down destroys and
undermines in these ways
and of course these kinds of movements
this this movement of racial vitality
includes not just
not just movements
in black no radical black politics but
we also see it in movements like la raza
for example as a perfectly good example
and in fact their vision of a kind of
south western hispanic empire stretching
out has enormous affinities and very
similar uh
and coached in very similar terms to the
way in which people like marcus garvey
talked about a a black
empire uh in in africa
in fact marcus garvey is really a good
example
of
how du bois's influence works uh in this
story
because on the one hand uh garvey had
this strong emphasis on the back to
africa movement
of blacks actually physically returning
to africa which dubois
by
by the uh by about 1910 and really
abandoned as being uh as being
unrealistic
he also garvey also preached very much
the preach the the the need for
intellectual uh and economic advancement
which a theme by the way which louis
farrakhan has now picked up and is made
as central to him and is one of the
reasons why very often he's treated as
being as a sort of sympathetic figure in
certain regards uh certain aspects of
his ideas being treated sympathetically
here
but again it's important to point out
that this notion of economic advancement
for blacks
was seen as a way not to make black
people rich but instead but to make them
powerful
that wealth is again seen simply as a
lever for power not for individual
advancement not for individual
enrichment and pursuit of individual
happiness but as a means to gain
political power in this way
and for garvey that means to power was
to destroy white supremacy to shatter
the bonds of of white supremacy and
instead to create this master black race
as he said a grand racial hierarchy
and an empire on which he said the sun
will never set
again drawing upon that kind of those
kinds of imperialist models uh here in
order to in order to project a future a
future for uh for the darker races
well that kind of that kind of overblown
rhetoric
is no longer so present now in the
multiculturalist debate people don't
talk about creating uh creating uh uh
grand racial hierarchies
although it survives of course in people
like farrakhan and some of the some of
the some of the afrocentrists
but this whole way of seeing history and
seeing american society
in terms of group histories in terms of
group identities here all reflect that
du boisian legacy and again also reflect
that german legacy
here
that what we're dealing with when we
come when we confront these kinds of
issues in the multiculturalist debate
are essentially essentially 19th century
ways of talking about society and race
and then if you take that away
if you take away that that implicit
declinism
and the assumptions that under underpin
it that the whole multiculturalism
empires kind of collapses of its own
weight
and i think in many ways this is the
this is the last point i want to make
and and and it's an important one
and that is to and that is that the
goals of multiculturalism
of radical multiculturalism
again have nothing to do with questions
of assimilation
here or or
or inclusion
because it views from the very beginning
it views western society as corrupt as
soul destroying and all of its
mechanisms as as as agents of this kind
of corrupting corrupting power
no the question really for the
multiculturalist debate is the question
not about assimilation or inclusion but
about power
uh of how to construct a patchwork quilt
here
uh out of american society in which
eventually eventually and in
because inevitably white bourgeois
capitalism uh the pieces uh that it
contributes here are going to eventually
unravel and disappear
that in a sense that multiculturalism
can take the offensive and and and and
uh and have confidence in its goals
because in the end it's going to win
you see in the end as du bois had
wrecked had had asserted that the the
future of humanity you see belongs to
the people of color uh and that that out
of that will come will come the
emergence then of a new kind of
civilization uh when the west uh when
the west uh and its various uh
apparatuses for control have disappeared
so the issue of assimilation and the
question of how those kinds of issues
will finally be resolved i think uh in
the end has to come down to a really
close debate
uh and a critical analysis of those con
precisely those kinds of assumptions
uh that underpin it uh
and uh
and that drive forward its forces in
this kind of ongoing debate
um and that is its assumptions about the
west its assumptions about the the
direction of history and its assumptions
about the nature very nature of civil
society
that the that the virtues that civil
society that modern industrial society
can create its its social mobility for
example in geographic mobility its
ability to to generate large amounts of
material affluence
its ability to empower individuals
to enjoy freedom of all sorts in in in
various new and unexpected ways and that
that notion of freedom has itself a
fundamental moral value all of these
things are all of these are virtues
which are from the beginning screened
out from this kind of debate
um and the
notion the idea of a theory of history
which could incorporate
those virtues while at the same time
recognizing its shortcomings
uh may be a way not just to enable
americans to regain a sense of
confidence about the future but it may
also be a way to gain a new angle in a
new direction on this larger
multiculturalist debate that's going on
now
well thank you very much
[Applause]
the usual order now is to open the floor
up to questions and i will let professor
hermann uh recognize you but i would ask
those of you who want to ask questions
please identify yourselves
you spoke this afternoon on a much
greater length in your book
about various thinkers who were inspired
by marx
marcusy the frankfurt school this
afternoon du bois and so on
i found it curious that you had no
chapter in your book on marx
and i think had you had such a chapter
had you focused more directly more
explicitly in a greater length on marx
i think you might have had to modify
your opening remarks today and also a
theme that goes through the book
that the animus of all of these thinkers
these what are we calling them
declinists or declined us or whatever
uh their their animus is against modern
industrial society
and i think you would then have to say
that yes to be sure that's true of some
of them but for a great many others and
i think particularly for the moderns the
animus is against modern industrial
capitalist society
and as capitalism is crucial in the case
of marx for example who did not propose
to transcend industrialism
uh and i wondered i wondered what why
you did not in fact have that i didn't
why you didn't have that chapter on marx
well you know that that's an excellent
question and it's one that runs through
my mind not just now but from time to
time and and it's a and it's an issue
which
in the end was i think also an
intellectual one and that was that
um
that for me the the question about marx
marx really belongs as a as as a
theorist
to the school of historical progressives
and the the prophets of progress that i
talk about in the introduction of the
book and i mention marx and talk about
his theories there
and it's precisely i think because uh he
did see
the end of capitalism as creating not
something
that was non-western or that would
reject the kinds of values of industrial
society and the transformations that had
taken place but that would in a sense
transcend them raise them to another
level and enable large numbers of other
people to enjoy who could not he
believed could not enjoy them
under a under the existing capitalist
status quo
uh and that in the end i think marx does
belong to
this uh and does come at the uh
in a kind of odd way to the end of this
sort of liberal humanist tradition it
permeates his own views about many of
these kinds of issues here
and as we know there is a marxist
humanist tradition that does kind of
emerge out of that marxist
point of view here
now marx is going to become an important
tool
i think for those who want to talk about
capitalist society as declining as
degenerating he provides fuel for the
argument and in a way he also creates a
kind of larger apocalyptic framework for
this that the end of capitalist
civilization is itself inevitable
there's a kind of inevitability
to
uh these historical processes
that that a new order will necessarily
arise from what happens after that
collapse takes place
and of course he also shares this other
ingredient with the
with the kinds of cultural pessimists
that i have talked about here and that
is his tendency to see human beings
caught in these processes as being in a
sense essentially sort of helpless pawns
in what takes place uh that history is a
process that goes on regardless of how
individuals play their parts
and how they see these kinds of events
taking place
that the cultural pessimists
and like the marxist
sees history as something that's done to
people
as opposed to seeing history as
something in which individuals
act on the world on the basis of their
assumptions and beliefs
and that basic historical assumption is
one i think that builds a strong bridge
a strong bridge between between those
two those two kinds of movements
just how very interesting such a chapter
would be
because it tells us how very ambiguous
marx's legacy has been oh very much so
yeah i mean the marxism
is as you say right there in that
enlightenment progressive is tradition
indeed in a very utopian tradition but
that utopianism means that he has to
transcend in a sense the western
civilization as we have known it and he
has finally to create a new kind of man
which brings us right into
our into the kind of marxism
yes and not and into an anti-western
civilization tradition would have i
think it would have made made for a very
powerful chapter in the book
i'm uh roger national legal center for
the public interest
um
you know if you're if you're born in an
airplane uh and you live your life in an
airplane you're going to be very
interested in theories of crashes
it's just the
nature of human beings that's right uh
and i think uh here in the west um we're
conscious of the fact that
we are part of a civilization that has
been enormously successful
uh and we look back in the in the past
and we see that there have been crashes
it's not an unheard of thing there's
been lots of empires over
over the centuries that that have
crashed and um
i wonder to to what extent uh in in
other civilizations non-western
civilizations
there have been comparable
theories of decline
i
is
as i'm suggesting
a theory of decline
sort of part of
human nature and an inevitable part of
being in a civilization
where you can see that well we've gone
up what goes up must come down
and there are a variety of ways which
we might come down
and so you have different
intellectuals speculating on how
this
uh part of our civilization or other uh
well
you know is uh inevitably doomed to
collapse and sometimes they're right and
sometimes they're wrong
yeah
i mean
i don't know if it's necessarily natural
to human species but it does seem to be
something that appears in almost every
sophisticated culture or civilization
that sense and i talk about this in the
introduction in some detail that sense
that
with the way things
our forebears did did it were a lot
better
you know and that they were just a lot
more better equipped than we are and
really superior and all these other
kinds of things and that we've sort of
watched the sort of ongoing decay about
it part of it may be simply just the way
in which human beings i think experience
change in their themselves as human
beings as you lose certain kinds of
physical powers as time goes on there is
this sort of sense that you know what
the way one had lived before was uh with
those kinds of powers to be able to
to do things that that you that you
can't anymore has a kind of requires a
certain kind of a lure to it
and that this becomes sort of
transferred and talking about the ways
in which we understand how groups work
and interact
societies nations empires and then to
and then projected onto the sort of
grander scheme of civilizations
uh somehow a you know a link that's
established by historical tradition that
ties generations over hundreds of years
even a millennia
or more
and of course that's a part of permanent
part of the west as well western ideas
from
the ancients through the middle ages to
the reformation the whole notion of the
apocalyptic vision of the end of end of
the world all of these kinds of things
reflect
similar declineist kinds of ideas here
and in some cases generate a sense of
that kind of you know apathy and
resignation that goes with it
i think the difference though that comes
with the 18th century and was really
with the enlightenment and the
enlightenment is the starting point for
my book and some
really and it's also the starting point
for this
sense of ambiguity about decline the
ambiguities that are built into the
notion of of how whether history
progresses or declines
is the idea that the is that that is
that the
is that the ultimate reality to which
history in our events in our lives are
to be held accountable is in the here
and now in the secular time
and that the
uh and that the
the realization and the and the kind of
uh a transformation of our lives for the
better
that lifts us out from the kind of you
know the the the the sort of veil of
tears in which we find ourselves the
idea that that that that kind of lifting
out is something that takes place now in
the future this is what the idea of
progress brings or likewise that the
collapse and the winding down
that goes with it is also something that
takes place in the in the here and now
as opposed to something we look for a
transcendent reality religious a
religious escape and breakthrough to
make this kind of transformation this is
the big change that comes in the 19th
century
and the rejection on the one hand a
reaction against the idea of progress
things aren't getting better they're
getting worse
but also at the same time but also at
the same time this feeling that yes
things are getting worse but i have a
better idea of what we can do from here
which is how the historical pessimist
become turns into the cultural pessimist
that i can realize that greater idea
in the here and now by our next the next
society we create whether it's a marxist
utopia or whether it's a racial vitalist
vision of the future
um or whatever kinds of whatever kinds
of models models are going to be used to
uh to explain that
yeah go ahead
then i'll come around here
myself yeah uh i'm max green is there
some common reason or reasons why some
groups latch on to this idea of
decline and others don't
well
that's a that's an important question i
guess with certain groups or certain
individuals in any case um
certainly from the point of view of
people like henry adams and
in this country and people like yaakov
burkhart and europe in the 19th century
these were people for whom the big
sweeping changes the 19th century really
gave them a sense of displacement that
the world had really changed in ways
that the uh
where the world around them had really
become foreign to them all these people
suddenly surfacing uh from the kind of
lower orders that they had never seen
before this sort of enormous increase
and sudden appearance of this sort of
capitalist wealth
of a sort that they that they had not
recognized or seen before
and certainly that sense of being
displaced in one's own society and the
context in which one finds itself
makes it easier to latch on to
explanations or rationalizations as to
why this is taking place
but at the same time of course the whole
point is is that there's a kind of
paradox here because on the one hand you
are interpreting the changes and
experiences that you're going through
and they have an impact on shaping your
view of the society in which you live
but at the same time of course the ways
in which you interpret those things
depend on the assumptions you bring to
it from the very beginning here
and from my point of view from the point
of view of what i'm talking about as far
as modern culture
go how modern culture functions and is
permeated by these declines notions is
that this is in a sense that becomes a
process of a kind of intellectual
trickle-down effect here of a kind of of
a kind of cultural conditioning in which
the terms of debate and the ways in
which we understand these issues are
being constantly framed
constantly framed along those either
historical pessimist assumptions or
cultural pessimist assumptions so no i
don't think there's some kind of you
know natural mechanism that explains it
because you can have displaced people in
a society take
immigrants to this country the turn of
the century who don't at all
have that sense that the society in
which they're engaged in is you know in
inevitable decline and decrepitude quite
the opposite
there is in a sense uh instead there's
an enormous influx of energy and
engagement with that society that comes
with it
um
so it's i don't know if there's any
particular mechanism that's at work here
that that that brings people to it it
brings people to this notion of decline
but certainly you can see i think and i
try and lay out on the in the books what
the consequences what the consequences
can be
yeah
um john fonte alexis the social
institution i have two related questions
how would you fit
something say like robert bork's uh
slouching toward gamora in your taxonomy
he's more or less a cultural decliners
but he
suggests returning to the prince of
jeremiah returning to the principles of
the west rather than rejecting the myth
the west connected to the second
question is to what extent is
multiculturalism
not about race or culture but about
ideology in the sense and ideology of
western progressives an instrument of
western progressives
to essentially uh balkanize
uh into uh ethnic groups peoples and
then in the sense what's needed then of
course is a centralization a new elite
uh new clash that essentially rules the
roost in the form of some form of
utopianism as discussed to what extent
is this valid
um
that's an interesting point
bork's book i'm not going to talk about
bork's book that's first of all
i am
going to say simply this and that
that when talking about these kinds of
issues conservatives always have to be
careful
and that is that there is when you start
to use that vocabulary of declinism
and start
bringing in these kinds of images and
metaphors and begin to talk about
society and its institutions in these
sorts of terms that you do lend yourself
vulnerable to
various other kinds of more radical
solutions and and and uh
and
proposed
directions for those those institutions
here
and that in many ways the the same thing
happened with uh with paul kennedy's
book uh too on the uh
decline and fall of the great powers
that when you start talking about
american society in terms of these
decline that the only people you really
in the end make happy
are the people who are looking forward
to that decline into that end which is
not to say there's nothing to worry
about that's not to say that work may
not have you know valid points about
certain kinds of things that there are
things to worry about and to be
concerned about to take action towards
it
but i think that in some regards the uh
that attitude
and
we've seen it happen in the 19th century
that that attitude of historical
pessimism does create an environment in
which these cultural pessimist solutions
begin to move began to move to the fore
as for your other question with regard
to uh
whether multiculturalism is not in fact
a kind of statist
you know a kind of hidden statism that's
at work here uh on the part of western
progressives i suppose that's there's a
there's an ingredient to that uh that
there is this kind of
um danger that where multiculturalism
will lead us is to a situation that you
get in something like you know the
ottoman empire with the with the mila
system in which you've got religious and
ethnic minorities who are who are led by
a former community a ghettoized
community headed by certain accepted
leaders who are able to deal and serve
as power brokers with the with the
centralized power holders uh and then
what you get is this kind of this close
relationship then in which the
centralized power distributes favors to
various of these ethnic groups
in exchange for obedience to the laws
there is i suppose some danger that that
is what's at work and there may be some
people who are aware of what's of what's
taking place here
um
but the uh but the multi but how
multiculturalism itself views the west
and how the figures who are engaged in
this kind of discussion is really what
is really the issue that i find
interesting and that i've been that i've
been trying to address here too
i don't i once uh richard grenier i went
to school in france i don't want to
inflict this on you
but for people of my generation who
studied this sort of subject shall mohas
is very large and highly interrogative
question i just wonder how you'd pretend
well mohas i think is someone who
i talk about him
very very briefly in the discussion
about the french prophets of doom the in
the kind of the background to what will
happen later on in the 20s and 30s in in
paris
here
um
morris is a classic declinist he's a
historical pessimist
in all these other kinds of ways and he
sows again this sort of
this sort of
pessimism a kind of undermining of
self-confidence in the french republic
or even in the possibility of the his
own political program being
being coming into existence here there's
no way in which the french monarchy
could come into the french monarchy that
could come into existence would be one
that mohas would not have recognized and
would refuse to he would have turned to
some other kind of political system
instead
but that kind of that sort of
declinist view that refusal to
participate
in modern
normal political institutions such as
they existed in france
again played a part in creating an
intellectual climate a climate first
among
intellectuals on the right but then
later on with intellectuals on the left
that again that western bourgeois
society is uh is inevitably doomed and
is going to have to be overturned
and that in a sense that almost anything
that takes its place is going to be
better than what we've got
one last question one last
yeah
i'm just curious i feel like you haven't
really explained why this time it's so
different because i mean the greeks
weren't terribly
when socrates had plato and they you
know viciously criticized their own
societies didn't i mean didn't
necessarily believe in uh sort of an
otherworldly uh
recompense for what happens here which
is what you say change in the 19th
century so i just feel like
i don't really understand what has
changed so much that we would have a
sort of uh vicious turning on our own
society i mean
how does the the one explain the other
oh in terms of the vicious turning well
that could be
that's a slightly different point what i
think let me let me try again and try
and explain that
seems like sort of a sort of vicious
view of questions this is terrible we
should we should replace it as opposed
to a sort of depression that something
we like is gone wrong that's right but
don't forget the cultural pessimist is
in the at the end he is building upon an
historical pessimist argument namely
that the west is winding down
but the cultural pessimist is saying
there's something that lies beyond that
not lies beyond in terms of a
transcendent reality which is where you
see they would differ from let's say a
christian or a judeo-christian tradition
or or a plato or a socrates view and
that is is that you know
the world is the way it is
that's all there is to it and if you are
looking for a happiness if you are
looking for a virtue you have to move
outside of that but the cultural
pessimist is saying no don't do that
that's
lost cause anyway it's an illusion
instead
that
lost virtue that sense of lost morality
and lost values can be recovered in the
here and now
we see through secular historical
processes and through political
processes and that's the key difference
is is that the cultural pessimist is
building on the historical on this idea
of decline but he's creating a new
progressive vision to emerge out of it a
new progressive version that's going to
come but which you see has to detach
itself entirely from
from that from the moribund predecessor
the morbin prototype
thank you very much
i i'd like to say a few words to
professor herman about your chapter on
multiculturalism because one of the
reasons that we were interested
in having you here is the whole way in
which multiculturalism has infected not
just higher education which is where we
read about it most often and where we
see some of its most radical forms but
multiculturalism in public schools in
the united states and and notions that
were once uh
the purview of intellectuals in ivory
towers are now
very much the education of most school
children in america today and these
ideas of decline
and particularly the way in which
multiculturalism plays into the ideas of
decline and the profound
anti-americanism
that is sometimes found in these
programs i think is something that i
know concerns us here at the center for
equal opportunity
this whole
idea that
children must be indoctrinated in the
notion of the evils of the west and the
failures of western civilization and the
way in which
although many of the multiculturalists
talk about inclusion as uh their purpose
and
uh moving many children from from
different racial and ethnic backgrounds
into the mainstream of america the
actual doctrines that are promoted the
actual materials that are used the
actual models that are put up are often
very much in in a different direction
and i think your book um did an
excellent job in in that chapter of of
talking about those themes so i want to
thank you again very much and thank all
of you for coming and invite you again
to our next uh book luncheon which john
do we have we don't have uh a date yet
set but you'll be getting invitations
from us all thank you very much
[Applause]
in a minute a look at the 22nd annual
washington antiquarian book fair
and later consumer advocate ralph nader
talks about the effects of large
corporations on the american legal
system